good
morning
it's it's Monday February 8th
2021 it's 9:03 a.m. and as the chair of
the criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance and the Governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuing to executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
with the potential for an executive
session to be held
throughout please note that there are no
physical locations for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules in RSA
91a anyone who has a
problem accessing this meeting should
call
27136 or email HCS
l.st do.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that that are on the meeting as
assisting us Brad uh Brad Greenland the
committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call
vote let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call
attendance when each when each member St
present anyone in room during this
meeting which is required under the
right to no
law clerk will now take the
role Vice chairman
Welch he's here representative Alexander
here representative
poer representative green here
representative Wallace here
representative testerman here
representative true here representative
crap yeah represent ative Marston
president Clark is here representative
har G president representative panus
pres representative oarn
present representative Gordon
present representative Muse here and
alone in my
office representative
Newman here and alone in the room
representative Balden here
representative
Conley representative K
Knight here and my husband's in the
other
room representative
lebranch here and I am alone in my
room chairman abis
present Mr chairman um representative
Welch here but he was not here for
representative Welch is in the building
and we'll be
here um representative poer and
representative P
are no we have a long day ahead of us
so we'll get
started Marson you do have to remain in
your
seat yes yes we
will
All Join Me inting col
leads Ali to flag United St of America
the stands
Nation
indivisible and jce for
all
[Music]
so before the criminal justice and
public sa Safety Committee we now going
to open the public hearing on House Bill
5:30
iot yes I'm looking looking to see if
the representative is to introduce the
bill
represent want to add
represent and we try to make it off so
they can turn the video
on yeah so I'll
promote okay so uh first I'd like to
thank the chairman of the entire
committee for letting me introduce HB
530 it's sponsored by representative Tom
Dolan representative Tony leus but they
have other bills to introduce at the
same exact time but my name is
representative Brody Dees and I
represent Carol 6 which is the town of
wolfboro the bill before you this
morning allows an employer to share
certain information with a law
enforcement agency about a candidate for
a position as a peace officer or other
position within a law enforcement agency
but simply this legislation would allow
for a thorough background investigation
of a candidate who is to be employed by
law enforcement agency only upon the
request of the law enforcement agency
who who is hiring said candidate some
former employers fear releasing
potentially negative information on
candidates for law enforcement positions
because of potential lawsuits this
causes former employers to limit the
information they provide law enforcement
agencies this can put us all at risk and
create potentially costly lawsuits for
municipalities the information this
legislation allows to be collected is
only to be shared between the prior
employer and potential new law
enforcement agencies it can be further
shared with subsequent law enforcement
agencies too these are the only parties
who will ever receive this information
and as previously mentioned it prevents
any lawsuits from taking place when the
necessary information is collected it
also protects the privacies of
candidates for positions this addition
to the law and background investigations
make it clear that our law enforcement
agencies are able to collect the
information they need on candidates from
their former employers this allows for
the full vetting of any potential
candidates The Proposal before you
encourages more thorough background
investigations and provides
confidentiality and the liability
protection for employers who provide
such information this is important for
some obvious reasons one reason is the
law enforcement agencies need this
information in order to make informed
decisions during the hiring process
these decisions always have the Public's
interest in mind the second reason is
this legislation protects previous
employers from being sued for helping
law enforcement agencies with this
process law enforcement agencies
properly vet vet candidates and only
hire individuals with the correct
temperament to guard the public and
promote Justice in their community and
again it prevents cost to lawsuits
whether it be lawsuits caused by
necessary collection of information or
lawsuits caused by law enforcement
officers who acted in bad faith this
bill also addresses one of the concerns
raised by the governor's Commission on
law enforcement accountability community
and transparency specifically
recommendation number 14 according to
this commission the New Hampshire police
standards and training Council should
quote amend administrative rule
p3105 on background investigations this
is located in RSA 106l col 6 Roman I and
is the law that supports P
30105 rule p
p3015 in order for a complete background
investigation law enforcement agencies
need access to personal records
employers need protection from lawsuits
HP 530 would give access to the
information needed to screen applicants
as proposed under recommendation number
14 again thank you for letting me speak
and I would ask that you reserve your
questions for those who represent our
law enforcement agencies their
professionals who know vastly more than
myself and requested the drafting of
this legislation thank
you seeing no questions I want to thank
the representative for his
testimony saying this right Andrew
chori Chief Shor he's promoted you may
you may begin your
testimony uh thank
you Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh representative Des has
really done a good job explaining the
issues and and what we're facing at
times it doesn't happen often but it
happens often enough that it ought to be
a
concern this bill I asked for it I've
run into it a few times I've been in law
enforcement 32 years um sometimes I
wonder if we miss something if we don't
get a good
full assist
it's
not it's meant to cooperate and get
cooperation and get us the information I
first ran into this uh kind of a thing a
few years back with a I got a request
from another state and part of their
request for information on an applicant
that had come before Tuftonboro was this
kind of lettering that you know you need
to comply with this for this reason and
you know you're
covered it doesn't just say I can ask
though I have to have it in writing I
have to have a release I have to provide
that kind of a I have to go through
certain steps before I can request this
information it also provides another
part of this is a level of insurance of
uh assurance that the information given
won't be shared so that businesses that
reveal that can a feel assured they're
not going to get sued and that their
secrets that could expose them to uh
issues won't be shared Beyond what's
necess necessary for the background
investigation
um I certainly think that uh it's
important and in light of uh the Lea
recommendations this will be uh critical
going forward I'll take any questions
you
have I
would one more thing though um there is
a bill in the Senate that does cover
some of this and that's the only
question that comes up is whether it
should be under this section of law
which is I I asked for this section
because it's right next to the municipal
background law for Municipal Employees
and the second part of that is or should
it be with the
106l um the laws for uh police standards
and training
Council that's what the Senate bill that
has essentially the same language uh uh
is putting it towards there so that's
the only thing that we might want
to look at also is where where should be
in the laws the language is pretty much
the
same representative tesman thank you
thank you for taking my question uh I
think it's a great Bill I just have a
question I know that we have a tendency
to
hire
some small municipalities
you people to be Chiefs of police from
out of state who have have some law
enforcement background would this cover
or be applicable to their former
employers and police
departments um I believe it would be at
least that maybe we wouldn't have the
enforcement ability of saying hey look
you got to do this but at least we have
assurance that what they do share will
be private and that might and they can't
be sued uh under our law anyways I can't
speak I don't know that we can set it
that they can be sued in other states um
and I defer to somebody with a probably
a better legal mind than I but uh I
think it provides at least some
assurance that they can't be sued under
New Hampshire law and that what they
share with us will not be shared uh
Beyond what's necessary for the
background
investigation thank
you representative
Muse yes I I see in the existing RSA
this would actually uh this appears to
actually add a separate process for
background checks for police officers
and looking at the the background check
process described in the
419b employee candidate background
checks there are are quite a few things
in there that are um that are not
referenced uh in this particular piece
of leg legislation and I'm I'm curious
is this section intended to work with
the rest of the extended with the rest
of the RSA so it becomes part of a
broader background check process or does
this effectively repace the candidate
background check process that
municipalities and towns use for other
positions that require background checks
in addition
to thank you um so by way of back we're
by way of we're fall under police
standards of training Council and their
rules like representative desay
mentioned their administrative rule
which is a very
detailed uh background process I think
what this would do is add to that what
you're you're referring to the municipal
one we have to do all that already
through uh RSA
106l uh and the administrative rules
enacted by police standards and training
Council we're required to
look into things that go beyond what
that law year citing talks about already
uh this just provides that level of
comfort beyond that that you can't sue
that that you need to cooperate you
can't be sued if you do and you this is
going to be private but we do well
beyond what's required under uh the
statute on Municipal
Employees and required to by police
stands of training thank you very much
seeing no further question Chief I want
to thank you for your
testimony thank you I have another
meeting to attend to but I appreciate
the time and
uh thank you for all you
do thank you for your service as
well I'm there any me are there any
members of the public uh that
are in attendee that wish to uh provide
any testimony please raise your
hand seeing no hands at this time the
chair will close the public hearing on
House Bill
[Music]
5:30 we in recess till believe
9:30 and Mr chair we do have we did have
people who uh who signed in there were
14 people who signed in in support of HB
530 uh and there were zero people who
signed in in opposition to
it you got you're well rested over the
weekend
We're not scheduled till
9 representative
Muse yes you have the amendment for 498
yet
we do not we're probably not going to
get that until uh this afternoon uh it
was emailed to OS yesterday um and they
are working on it uh but evidently
they're working on a bunch of other
amendments as well uh so uh I will I
will look through it for it throughout
the day in email we finally have some
downtime this is the this is perfect
time to exec something we're not opening
again until 9: next heing at 9:45 but
just check your email at
9:30 I I'll keep checking it no how we
check about this
one not the executing the one we just
heard am I allow to open the ex
recess you said we're in till
9:30 are we so representative Muse and
the people remotely because I said that
we will be in recess till 9:30 we'll
stay in recess at
9:30 till 9:30 but I think at 9:30 we
can open the executive session on HB
I can exact right
now let's do it now
then
at this time the the chair is now
opening the executive session on House
Bill
5:30 on this 8th day of February
2021 at 9:23
a.m. would anyone like to be recognized
to make a
motion
rep represent this is a question of the
chair the ranking member has stepped out
of the room and is unaware of his
proceeding I wonder if we could just Hal
this for a moment or two just so that
she's uh can come back and we can begin
on a with every member aware of this
process I think that's a fair point of
order
because she left the room when I said
that we will be in recess till 9:30 so I
feel that would be very disingenuous for
us to vote on anything while the ranking
member of the other caucus took me at my
word I appreciate youting I thank you
for pointing that
out issues speaking of the ranking
member representative
Gaff we have some downtime till 9:45 so
I decided that we would open the
executive session on house bill 530 the
bill we just had the hearing for
representative Cony raised the a very
good point of order that you left the
room based on what I said that we were
being recess and asked we wait for you
so you've now returned
yes my my my apologies after that thank
you representative Conley would you
still would you like representative
pakus I'd like to make the motion or to
pass
second is there a second representative
Wallace second that motion has been
seconded by representative
Wallace representative pakus do you wish
to speak to your motion no I think it's
a very good
bill does anyone I wish to open the room
for discussions does anyone wish to
provide any comment
or seeing No Hands raised uh the clerk
will now call the role if you are in
support of the motion of a to pass
please say yay if you are
opposed please say
nay Mr chairman you
are
correct representative Alexander yay
yes representative Hopper yes
representative green yes
representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative TR yes representative
Pratt yes representative Maron yes the
clerk votes yes representative haret G
yes representative
pacus yes representative o'n
bord yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman
yes represent just turn just turn your
you got to keep your video on for the
vote you don't mind u i my apologies Mr
chairman I could not unmute myself and I
accidentally hit the stop video button
was while I was trying I'm not a very
good aim I missed the thank
you representative Balden yes
representative Conley yes representative
kle Knight
yes representative
lebranch
yes chairman abis the chair the chair
votes
yes Mr chairman the vote is 20 yay Z
nay
representative do be done by done by
motion but I believe I can go on consent
calendar does anyone have any objection
to uh HB 530 going on the consent
calendar seeing no objection it will be
on on
consent representative pus will you be
preparing a a majority report or a
consent report yes I
will and mail it to car
right thank you very much see you
and send it to you can you send it to
myself anther
Karen yes I will thank
you thank you very
much at this time at this time the chair
will now close the executive session on
host
530 I think
watch
hopefully we do a better job with
represent
time what's this one
this
and this is 202 what's this one there
two all right that's okay
last time they put us in a different
room we still all came in here took it
over oh
really like to be consistent that's
all
J signed up this speaki
twice and said she needs zero
minutes that would be
good
is
um wasn't speaker
Sheri Marshall y Marshall or was sheriff
or something like that he would be great
to
testify I was told he was going to um
send in um a
testimony but I don't think I got
it
I don't know I think people should have
concerned with that one
really I P J call me you know and she
never called
she sent a letter and I couldn't find
sh's number because I wanted to talk to
her personally I was feel uncomfortable
I have no idea rationality why you do
because not only that you I'm afraid for
all these people these and that are here
that's
crazy
what and then it says somewhere along
the line some of them have to be trained
by with certain information but others
they AC so just little hey Linda we can
hear
you thank
you sen Wallace you are the in charge of
the mute button over there thank
you
[Music]
yes
for
e
that's
all
for
that's
okay
for
and
that
for
[Music]
what
Schmid
good morning I'm glad we got you on
right away this time too accept
our no this time I actually filled out
the form correctly thank you very much
for your patience with me uh shall I
begin yes thank you very much and thank
you Mr chairman and honored members of
the criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee for the record my name is Jan
Schmidt and I represent Ward one in
nasua and today I offer you HB 365 this
bill allows federal law enforcement
officers to be certified by the
commissioner of the department of safety
for the purpose of making arrests the
request for this bill came directly from
a constituent a neighbor in Ward one a
man who helps keep us all a little bit
safer and a member of the FBI I was
rather surprised when he explained his
request I didn't know it was in question
but he explained that a Vermont recently
put this into law and he was request
requesting this for New Hampshire um New
Hampshire uh Vermont does and there are
many other states that do as well he
Illustrated his request by saying that
if he by his presence was able to stop
an assault he couldn't arrest the
perpetrator they would be free to escape
and if this occurred in some areas of
the state notifying the police would
mean that the person had more than
enough time to disappear OLS has
produced for us a limited and specific
addition to our law enforcement laws
mirroring the current law in Vermont and
other states that I believe May benefit
the entire state so I ask you find HB
365 ought to pass thank you and I'll
take any
questions I I I do have one
question
so how how would this work is this still
allow federal Offices to enforce state
laws in New
Hampshire this is this is only in the
case of arrest and when someone is
arrested by uh an FBI agent in this case
they need to take that person directly
to the state
police uh if you see uh section number
three it uh specifically identifies the
use of this power
it's very limited and it's simply meant
to assist local police who may not have
the opportunity to be available at that
time
Branch I'm
sorry our representative branch has a
question oh you to the thank you for the
thank you to the chairman my question is
are you concerned at all about possible
Federal
overreach in this case it is only if the
person is
certified by um by New Hamshire and it
was only in a limited case and so I
would see that in the I don't know
maybe 30 other states that do this they
do not have a problem with overreach and
at a time when we're very very uh
careful about a police and giving extra
Powers this actually is is helping
police so that they do not have to uh
extend their own powers in a case such
as this it would be someone available at
the time and at that space who could
help local
police representative
night uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question are you concerned at all with
uh immigration Federal uh laws and our
communities that um that this might
endanger some of of these undocumented
communities uh in that case uh if you'll
check current law you'll find that
there's already a place I believe it is
in RSA 594 colon 27 uh excuse me 26 just
prior to where this would be added where
that is already taken care of and this
is this is specific only about to
prevent The Escape of an individual let
me see if I can read one whom the
officer reasonably believes has
committed a crime in the presence of the
officer so this wouldn't be like going
into someone's house knocking on their
door and taking them away this this has
to be immediate and it has to be right
then and
there repres Newman you had your hand up
did you you wish to withdraw wave yeah I
withdraw I put my hand down in the in
the uh
computer representative Marston thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
I my
question representative Smith do you
have any law enforcement officers
agencies Chiefs of police vum this
bill
uh I asked my friend who is as I said a
constituent uh if anybody else was going
to be supporting it and I believe uh our
previous speaker is also on this bill uh
as he believed that it was an
appropriate thing to do for the state um
and I asked the gentleman who uh asked
me to bring this forward and he said
that his boss was uh watching this
carefully and may come to speak as
well thank you you're welcome
representative true thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative for taking
my question you gave the example of a
federal law officer uh witnessing a
crime um even without this bill wouldn't
he be allowed to enable to uh make a
citizen's
arrest uh I don't think that a citizen's
arrest would have the same value of this
and I don't I I think that the person
who was captured in this case would
probably bring suit against someone I
know I would I um I think that giving
them the power to do this and making
sure that it's followed through exactly
as we say it is allowed as I said to
take them directly to uh the state
police uh Barracks um that we've limited
what can be done and we've narrowed it
just to what would be
appropriate representative
o' thank you Mr chair thank you take my
question I guess question would be is
where is
the the bosses of the federal
government directors
stand I'm sorry you've broken up and I
can't quite understand the last part of
your your comment okay I'll I repeat it
again I would like to know where the
stance of the bosses such the director
or the chief of federal government St
saying it being brought uh
by Federal Officer but where are the
bosses
stand uh I think you're asking me that
the boss of my friend my my FBI neighbor
yeah uh he I was told that he would be
here to speak or he would at least be
watching this to offer his own
comments I'm sorry I don't have any
further information on uh further up the
the
chain oh do you have a
followup no trying to figure out my hand
down I have a
question was training you have any idea
number of
hours it says here uh section on line 17
complete study in answer law I know that
answer police officers do like a 9
training you know how long training it
would
be I do not know I believe that would be
for the commissioner of of safety as
they have to be the one who uh actually
uh certifies this person to do
this representative the chair would like
to ask a question
is is can you give me any examples where
an FBI agent witnessed the crime or
really any of the the examples listed on
the A B C or D where they witnessed this
happened uh any of these but chose not
to act because this law wasn't in place
I I don't think it's so much that they
chose not to act I'm sure what they did
was appropriate for what they were able
to do I'm sure they able to stop
whatever was going on and I'm sure that
they were able to uh identify the person
for the police later on this isn't a
matter of not being able to do anything
this is being able to do something
immediate that would assist the police
force no I'm sorry I don't have any
access to their to their files I I I
can't give you any specifics I I
apologize if I just ask a follow I'm not
sure if you would have this information
but for any of those instances did did
any were any of those FBI agents or
federal agents were they charged with
any state crime or would be subjected to
any civil liability that you were aware
of no not that I'm aware
of thank you for taking my question
absolutely
seeing no further hands I want to thank
the representative for her testimony
thank you very much for your questions
and uh always a pleasure to be here
thank
you there is a member of the
public John John
skipper
should be all you may your testimony
please Begin by stating your name uh
where you where you were from and
whether you were testifying in in
support or an opposition of the
bill uh thank you Mr chair thank you
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is John Skipper I am the
director of New Hampshire police sers
and training Council and oversee the
certification of police officers here in
the state of New Hampshire uh I uh speak
today in uh support of this legislative
Bill uh specifically and uh some some
people have asked some excellent
questions here uh with with regard to
concern on uh
overreach and um uh possibly uh exposing
uh those those people who live in our
communities uh uh who may be um May have
uh status issues here in the country uh
that is not what this bill is designed
to address uh if I could
uh very quickly uh many of you
understand that a lot of law enforcement
activities here in the state that deal
with a high uh dangerous uh criminals
and criminal activity uh those
investigative uh efforts are are
conducted by task forces and these task
forces are made up of both uh local New
Hampshire police officers and they are
augmented by federal uh Law Enforcement
Officers as well uh during my 30-year
career I had the occasion to interact
with many members of these task forces
uh these task forces uh are really uh
looking hard at uh people bringing uh
dangerous drugs and weapons into our uh
State uh the the task force members from
federal agencies uh bring the additional
support and resources that we would not
otherwise have available to us if we
were acting
unilaterally uh often times uh when
these task forces take uh action they
serve a warrant to arrest somebody who
is uh dangerous that's highly armed and
uh uh moving a lot of drugs into our
state uh these are very Dynamic
situations and uh in cases like that
it's imperative that the federal
officers have uh limited State
Authority uh so that they can act uh
unilaterally if they're on one side of a
house uh and and they're the only
officers in the back of that house and
then the suspect tries to exit the back
of the house this provides them with
very very sound uh legal authority to
take that action that is outlined uh in
this proposed Bill uh further uh this
situation already exists for spe uh
Federal officers uh here in New
Hampshire we already we already do this
but it it's only for uh Homeland
Security uh officers those officers that
are working on the border uh in Canada
uh and so this uh this special Authority
is already granted and it is already
overseen by our agency uh we uh here at
police standards and training there's a
a process in place uh for registering
and receiving appropriate training so
that they do have uh the state level
training that allows them to uh to act
in this fashion and carry this
Authority and uh I I don't see this as
anything more more than uh really just
extending what we already have to other
federal law enforcement officers in a
way that will provide them uh the
authority to do their job and to help
New Hampshire law enforcement keep our
our state safe and uh I would I would
ask uh that this committee support this
bill going forward and I stand ready for
any
questions representative Hopper uh thank
you Mr chair and uh thank you for taking
my
question um the sponsor seem to imply
but I assume it's not necessarily
strictly that
the uh federal Offices this would apply
to would be people that are reside in
the state of New Hampshire but the way
you just described it I foresee
possible uh Federal officers who reside
elsewhere and coming into new is this
was this intended for people who just
live here and might happen to see a
crime in action and want to do something
or is this broader than
that uh I I believe that uh this is
probably uh broader uh understand that
we do have police officers that work in
New Hampshire that do not reside in New
Hampshire uh their residency is uh could
be in Maine it could be in Massachusetts
or Vermont that that is not
uncommon uh I I really think uh in
speaking with um uh my my counterparts
here in New Hampshire and speaking with
uh specifically the special agent in
charge of uh the New Hampshire FBI
office uh that that really the intent of
this legislation would be to uh to
provide
uh strong legal footing uh and and State
Authority in those very uh Dynamic and
dangerous situations that need immediate
action uh who are assigned to those task
forces and are are helping New Hampshire
law enforcement uh keep our state safe
uh and not to say that um uh you know
any help is good help uh when one law
enforcement officer wants to help
another law enforcement officer and it's
not uncommon for a federal police
officer uh to to you know inadvertently
find him or herself in in a very Dynamic
situation where they they don't have
time to wait for help and uh their
ability to step in and and uh protect
somebody uh and
and stop something before it escalates
into a real problem you know would
certainly be a benefit to New Hampshire
as well I hope that answers your
question thank you representative
GFF so
um if an agent okay let's say from
Florida or wherever is vacationing here
and they feel they feel someone may be
committing a crime um that particular
agent can enforce the law and that's
what this Bill is saying
correct uh no sir uh and I can
understand how how
uh you might come to that conclusion but
in fact uh the agents that we're
speaking of uh and the way I understand
uh how this bill has been constructed uh
is really very well controlled by the
state of New Hampshire th those
individuals who are federal law
enforcement officers would have to do
two things uh the first thing is that
they would have to complete a block of
instruction through New Hampshire police
standards and training that would bring
them up to speed on state law that is
specific that is specific uh to that
limited Authority that they would be
receiving in the first instance and then
secondarily they would have to then be
sworn in by the commissioner of safety
uh in order to uh to meet all the
requirements uh set forth in this bill
so it's not as if uh any federal law
enforcement officer that happened to be
vacationing uh coming through our state
uh could uh unilaterally and without uh
recognition through police standards and
training and without recognition through
uh the department of safety uh they
would not have the authority that were
that this bill speaks
to I a
follow representa Gaff you recognize for
a followup question okay so if this bill
was generated based on one agent um out
of Nash from what I understand is that
correct it wasn't something that um the
police um training or anything came up
with
correct
uh so uh candidly uh just prior to uh uh
the events in Washington DC I had the
occasion to speak with uh special agent
in charge uh jibli uh who is the special
agent for the FBI here in New Hampshire
so he oversees the FBI operation here in
New Hampshire and uh he and I had a very
uh clear conversation relative uh to
this effort uh I don't know who authored
the bill and I don't know who the FBI
agent is who spoke with the author of
that bill but I do I can speak uh to the
fact that special agent jibli and I
spoke about this and his concern about
uh being able to provide this type of
law uh law enforcement Authority at a
state level for his Task Force officers
that are assigned to New Hampshire task
forces
representative
Hearn thank you Mr chair and thank you
uh for taking my question I guess you
kind of answered the question about uh
the bosses um but I still uh going back
to the Border you said that the we
currently have it up there and how long
ago was
that I I'm I'm sorry sir I I don't uh
know the answer to that
question okay because the followup
question to that was is why didn't we do
it then uh and why are we doing it
now and and again
um for the record I've only been here
for about 10 months I and I so I can't
speak uh to that that question I don't
know
followup representative Hearn you
recognize for a
followup do you know of any
uh thing on the federal level that may
be coming down the pike uh in regards to
uh broadening the authority of the
federal officers due to the recent
uh last month's situation and that we
may be doing something that um we may
not even have to
do uh I I know of no uh kind of ideas or
thoughts or anything that would be
coming from a federal level and can ly
uh I don't believe that they that the
federal government would have authority
to um to extend uh state level authority
to any of their officers that would that
would need to come from
us one more
followup representative for another
followup and can you tell me how many
other states currently have these uh
laws that they've passed I cannot
sir
representative
Knight um thank you chairman and thank
you for taking my question uh sir uh how
many times during your career so far
have you experienced specifically in our
state that the lack of this law impeded
your ability to carry out
Justice I I can say uh from my very uh
personal experience uh on the the few
times that I assisted with a a warrant
uh that was enforcing state law uh and
that warrant was being served by a task
force that was made up of both uh New
Hampshire police officers state police
officers uh members of the
DEA uh while uh it there was never a
time uh where I can say it the lack of
authority caused a problem uh with those
Federal officers I can tell you
unequivocally that had had the service
of those warrants not gone exactly the
way that we had
planned uh in those they can be very
Dynamic situations and and we want to
make sure that these federal law
enforcement officers are are
are acting under the color of state law
uh
so so to to specifically answer your
question I never personally saw an
impediment uh but I think it was
because of the fact that the service of
those warrants went without any kind of
uh changes they went the way that they
were planned to go so I um I wish I had
more to offer on
that representative KN recognized for a
fall question thank you chair have you
considered uh to start to document um
this for us for the state as as we move
forward we would it would be great to
have that data so we could um get a
clear understanding of how to better
help our law
enforcement yeah uh uh representative
Klein I I uh one of the things that uh
we are uh definitely trying to get ahead
of and this is not only on this topic
but on a number of different criminal
justice topics across the board and that
is this this you know high high level
discussion on uh the collection of data
and uh uh certainly very very important
um we
probably we definitely can do a better
job of collecting data than we do right
now and there and again that's that's
widespread across New Hampshire law
enforcement and criminal justice so uh
you're definitely on point and that
would be something that um you know we
should we could very easily begin to
start collecting that data
uh I
agree represent you have a followup
question I do not thank you
chair representative Marston thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking our
question it seems to me that the
testimony here this morning on two sides
and the presenting the case they want to
talk about an isolated situation where
somebody visiting the state can jump in
and then at the same time we're talking
about a plan to have people going
through a training program so on and so
forth and then we find that you are
doing it already with warrants so I'm
confused why you need this bill
and and I've had a lot of people send me
emails speaking up against it on various
levels the question is do you see the
the
jbless in it's an incident isolated and
then it's a plan having a bunch of
people signed
up I'm sorry sir I'm not I'm not clear
on your question if you could rephrase
please representative Marson do you want
to re uh rephrase the question
yeah it's a
confuted it's a confuted situation that
you're presenting to us on one hand it's
an isolated incident that happened and
one officer had wanted to be able to do
it on the other hand you want to have a
whole organized situation where you're
having federal Offices get certified
within the
state
why uh thank you
sir so I I it is my understanding uh and
based on the discussion that I've had
with uh the special agent in charge here
of the FBI uh that this bill is is
specifically to address uh providing
State authority to Federal officers who
are assist
New Hampshire police officers in the
enforcement of uh New Hampshire laws
that that
um where we we as a law enforcement
Community really rely on our federal
Partners to help uh you know enforce
these laws and take these these uh
criminals off the
streets uh I I did not take part in any
kind of a discussion
with the special agent in
charge uh relative to the one-offs that
you spoke of earlier just uh granting
people Authority you know so that if
they're
in you know a store a local business and
a crime happens in front of them that
they could act I think that that would
be a
um you know maybe a you unintended
benefit but but clearly I think this
legislation is is being put forth to
help provide federal law enforcement
officers working in an organized kind of
environment with New Hampshire police
officers to give them that state
Authority so that when they're doing a
drug warrant or they're they're trying
to arrest uh an
individual uh who's bringing guns into
the state or something that you know a
child
pornography uh New Hampshire law
enforcement really has a difficult time
addressing these these uh types of
situations without Federal partnership
and so to that end uh I see that that's
why this bill is being introduced the
way it
is representative Marson recognize for a
followup question yes thank you Mr
chairman simply put aren't you already
doing that you guys get together and you
carry out a warrant you use the federal
government and the local police as it is
right now this becomes a move point to
add another piece of
legislation I I uh I think um that there
could be a situation in the service of a
warrant or uh the the attempted arrest
of an individual
uh by members of a task force where uh
that Federal Officer that's part of the
task force may be separated from the
rest of the group and will have to act
unilaterally and it's important that
they have state
Authority uh to take those types of
actions including uh responding to any
kind of force that's used against them
um and that that is uh that is why I see
that this bill is very
important representative Hopper uh thank
you Mr chair thank you uh for taking my
question um it has been a longstanding
understand uh understanding of the
Constitution that we're really not
supposed to have a federal police force
and yet you actually said in your
testimony I believe you called them
federal
police um don't you see this is uh
encroaching on the constitution in any
way no I'm sorry if if I I I I may have
used the term federal police officer ERS
to kind of Encompass the FBI the DEA the
ATF uh and and so I I apologize for any
miscommunication
uh and I I
don't
uh I don't see that that that is a
concern um if that if I'm answering your
question if I understand your qu
question
correctly thank you
representative board name thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
question um in the in the bill it has uh
requirement that the law enforcement
officer needs to completely satisfa Rec
complete a course study in New Hampshire
laws procedure I assume that this is
going to done at the
uh you speak
louder
okay so I'm looking at the uh training
required and I'm wondering how long the
course of study this is and what it
takes to be mean satisfactory
complete I I'm sorry sir I only heard
bits and pieces of that but I I want to
make sure that you're asking uh what
what the components of the training are
and how long it takes for them to
complete it
that's
correct uh candidly I don't have the
number of hours in front of me right now
I do know that they do have to complete
a block of training uh that speaks
directly to those uh pieces of limited
Authority uh that they would be entitled
to
enforce um we have uh and again this
process is already in place for for
Border agents we already do this for for
just that that one
agency and
um there was a question asked about how
long we're doing this for I that I don't
know um but it is a it is a very uh uh
strict process they have to uh that
agency uh has to send us uh the names of
these officers uh we have to make sure
that they have gone through the training
once they complete the training they go
to the commissioner of safety who swears
them in and and this is monitored
annually so um there may be times when
uh a a uh FBI agent is assigned to uh a
task force and then a year later that
FBI agent has been transferred they
don't carry that Authority that we've
granted them with them uh it is it is
very tightly controlled by New Hampshire
police standards and training and if
they do not uh meet the requirements and
rep reporting requirements
annually then uh that that Authority is
no longer granted to them so it is very
it's very strict it's very narrow uh the
training is very specific we keep
records of uh these officers that um go
through the training and then have the
authority granted by uh the commissioner
already for border patrol so I I I
didn't see this as any any other real
change other than uh extending what
we're already doing with border patrol
to those other uh FBI DEA ATF uh task
force
members thank
you representative
Newman I don't have my hand raised I
don't
think
your your hand is raised but we'll lower
your
hand representative
oarn thank you Mr CH thank for question
two you said earlier in your testimony
that had a candid conversation with the
the special agent in charge of the FBI
um my question would be is have you had
candid compensations with uh the
Department of Treasury the uh US
Department of Justice
the DEA the ATF and the US Marshals in
regards to
this I have
not
followup representative recognize for a
followup would you think that it would
be in our best our best interest as to
me we're going to authorize this that
probably hear from
them AB
absolutely thank
you
representative
Conley thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking the question sir um
forgive me if this has been asked before
stepped in and out of the room a couple
times but we've heard a little bit about
the types of officers or the types of
law enforcement who might be certified
under this proposal do you have a
ballpark sense for how many um people
would carry this um this extra Authority
in any given time
answer I I am going to um uh answer that
question through uh antidotal knowledge
uh just in my time here in New Hampshire
law enforcement uh and and the number of
task forces that uh I have been familiar
with during my career and I I don't see
that there would
be I can't imagine there would be more
than
maybe
40 and maybe tops 50 I if we uh included
you know
every every federal agent that is
working within the borders of the State
of New Hampshire actively working in a
capacity where they they would need
these Powers whether it's um because of
border patrol uh and and their their
position on our state border with uh
Canada uh or whether it was deah FBI
agents ATF agents that were working in
um group task forces I know that I I
spent the majority of my time in the Sea
Coast so I know that there was a there
was a Portsmouth group um and then there
was
uh there was actually two Portsmouth
groups um and I think uh you know
clearly there's uh there's going to be
some heighted groups which are the
height uh high-intensity drug
trafficking uh
groups uh that work uh across the
borders of U our state and and those
those states that border us um yeah I
can't imagine more than 40 or 50 at a
time and that's that's including
everybody thank
you if I may ask a question do you thank
for taking my question is is there
any discussion or consideration on how
when it comes to subing a federal agent
who was involved in making an arrest at
the state
level I mean if there's going to be a
Cas or a civil case that's usually
something that could happen I'm just
wondering my understand a stateena
served out of state on a federal agent
can
be problematic
I apologize I I I'm not understanding
the question is your
question can a state can uh can a
Federal Officer be served a civil
subpoena well how would you how I'll
rephrase it how do how would a person go
about who's either whether they were
arrested for in charge of the crime by a
federal federal agent under New
Hampshire law if that if that defendant
wanted to
subpoena the federal
agent and that if that federal agent
resides out of state how would they go
about doing
that for for an action that uh and I
think we're we're talking about If This
Were
uh if this bill was in place the the
officer the Federal Officer Had State
Authority they took an action in the
State and
then uh the the defendant wanted to
bring them to court is
that if they're arrested prably they'll
be in court right it was a let's say a
federal civil rights case that could be
brought this I mean that would be a
federal case I'm just saying if there
was civil liability per se at the state
level how would a person whether in a
criminal case or civil case go about
subpoenaing or serving process on the
federal agent who resides out of state
in state
court I would say that they would use
the same
process that that any other uh person
was going to get served who lived out of
state I don't I don't know that by
virtue of the fact that that individual
is an employee of a state agency that
had check that a federal agency that has
State Authority would be treated any any
any differently in a civil case I I I
don't
know thank you for taking my question
yes
sir seeing no further questions I want
to thank I want to thank the officer for
his testimony thank you for your time
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
members I appreciate
it didn't get his name yeah I was just
saying what uh who we
represented director police police
standards are there any members of the
public that would wish to provide
testimony please raise your
hand
can you hear me yes we can uh Sophia
please identify yourself with the record
please state where you were uh
testifying from and please State whether
you are testifying in support or in
opposition to House Bill
365 great uh thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee for taking my
testimony today my name is Sophia Bondo
I'm for 14 I live in Manchester um I'm
just in my house um and I'm speaking
today on behalf of the New Hampshire
High School Democrats in opposition to
HP
365 I'm testifying in opposition to HB
365 because we do not need additional
law enforcement in our communities who
are disconnected from locals in daily
life rather than expanding on already
well-funded law enforcement we should
focus on reforming the system we have
now as we have seen in Portland during
black lives matter protests Federal
officers only incite further tensions
and there's often little communication
with local officers
Federal officers should not be given
peace officer status as it will give
Federal officers who may have no
connection to the town the same power as
a local officer who has a family in town
the difference between these two types
of officers is clear one has a life in
New Hampshire with family and friends
that they truly care about while the
other may have no connection to the real
people of New Hampshire and little
understanding of the specific dynamics
of the unique towns and cities I ask the
committee vote against this bill to
support law enforcement and police
reform
thank you very much for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised I want
to again thank the thank the me uh
witness for their testimony you
excuse are there any members of the
public in attendance that wish to
testify please raise your
hand seeing no No Hands raised at the
chair will now close the public hearing
on House Bill
365 and Mr chair we had um a number of
people signing in on on this bill uh
today we had five people sign in to
support it and we had 28 people sign in
in
opposition
thank you representative
M we're cons we're consistent with that
at
least at this time we're going to open
the public hearing on house bills
CH we'll call Representative
Conley testify thank you Mr chairman
committee members I state representative
from Dober here to
ince3 this bill would require law
enforcement agencies within New
Hampshire to equip officers with body
cameras and EST is a grant program to
help Department Aid these devices B also
clarifies procedures for body camera
footage captured in violation of
existing rules but which is potentially
exculpatory in a civil or criminal
matter there are a lot of arguments out
there uh in support of body cameras I
suspect the committee has heard many
before uh but to me the most compelling
argument in support is that body cameras
improve trust and police build support
for law
enforcement this is particularly
critical now in this current atmosphere
influenced by the event from last
summer excuse me in fall but it was also
true uh 200 years ago in England well
before social media could amplify these
events and well before smartphones
existed to capture encounters with
police way back then Sir Robert Fel
considered a father of modern policing
observed that and I quote the ability of
police to perform their duties is
dependent on public approval police
existence actions Behavior and the
ability of police to secure and maintain
public
respect quote body cameras are an
important way to maintain and builds
that public respect and
approval they provide firsthand evidence
of what happened in a given incident
they can refute claims of excessive for
ORS of conduct data from the Department
of Justice they shown they can lead to
better compliance with police
commands this Viewpoint is increasingly
shared across the political Spectrum
Governor senu as we know issued an
executive order last year effectively
calling on the state police to take
steps to adopt
body poll after poll is shown nearly 90%
of Americans want their police wearing
these devices cost has long been a
hurdle for broader adoption of body
cameras particularly for small
departments and this bill establishes a
dedicated fund to offset those
costs as proposed 1% judicial fine
assessments would move from the general
fund to this new fund specifically for
funding body cameras and in round
numbers that comes to about 35,000 a
year available for
purpose
um we know body and dash Camas are
included in the Senate's Omnibus police
Reform Bill that's making it way through
that chamber
one key difference is that that bill
does not include a funding mechanis it
does not include funding although I
understand that could be approv
separately in the budget until we have
more clarity on those issues I ask the
committee to recommend passive of this
bill
um and I will finally note that this
bill uh was developed by the former
chairman of this committee
um and although I had intended to defer
some questions to him I believe he's not
available to testify today with that I
will do my best to answer
question representative
testman thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
um you talk about $35,000 a year in a
fund or something like this for a
grant real expense on body cams as I
understand it because we've heard this
issue before are on the long-term
cataloging of these uh the film and or
not film but the the memory cards and it
effectively probably take one person
extra at each police agency uh how do
you propose to to fund that or you just
pass that down to the to the cities and
towns thank you representative my
understanding in researching this bill
is that um you can purchase packages
that address the storage of this data
and as existing statute around body
cameras already makes clear that this uh
data is not kept in perpetuity it's um
it's there are strict rules for handling
this data so uh I hope that answers your
question
followup representative tman recognized
for a follow-up
question that's exactly what I was
talking about was cataloging and uh
responding to requests for it and so on
I mean I guess I'm trying to figure out
how you're going to pay for that in a
small community let's say Chichester
over here which had four or five uh
policemen right now they're not their
job is not to catalog this when they
come in off the
shift I'm trying to figure out how
you're going to do this
thank you representative so the again I
refer to the existing statute which
carefully
uh clarifies when these devices would be
used so that they're not collecting um
you know eight hours worth of data on a
ship um I don't know the the inner
workings of small departments to know
what a what an officer's responsibility
entails um but I think the statute is
limited such that officers are not doing
precisely what you describe or having to
hire extra personnel and so
on thank
you representative green thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my
question uh with a police office will be
able to turn this off if he uh was
approached by someone that wanted to
give him some information but didn't
want to be involved under the
recording thank you representative that
scenario and many others like it are
already covered under the body camera
statute the key difference under this
proposal is that uh this uh departments
are currently uh not required to have
them uh to have them in general so the
current standards uh would remain in
place under this
proposal representative Maron thank you
Mr chairman thank you than question in
the course of listening you're saying
that there's already a law we have a law
on the books about body cameras and
you're just trying to arent it with more
RS thank you representative so yes uh
body cameras are carefully regulated in
our state uh many basically any scenario
one can imagine um is is a rest in
statute this the difference is this is
voluntary now nobody's required to do it
this bill would make body cameras part
of uh a required part of a police
officer you know uniform and
so thank
[Music]
you representative Hopper uh thank you
Mr chair thank you representative for
take my question
um I love the idea of uh of having
having uh body cameras the curdle I'm
trying to get over is the 28a issue of
we're not allowed to uh create
expenditures at the local level without
financing them and is this is this
actually is the expected revenue from
this bill really enough to cover the
cost for body cameras and wear and to as
uh representative tester pointed out to
maintain the
um
um volumes of
information representative thank you
um I've had that same thought uh I do
not believe the revenue stream uh is
will cover every officer in the state
nor I don't believe was it intended to
uh cover I think it was meant to
supplement uh the cost of these devices
which range from pending on packages and
so on 100 to 7 or 800 per unit so
certainly not going to outfit every
officer in the state but it could go a
long way to
outfitting many officers across many
departments over a couple
years I will also point out that the
statute there's no penalty uh for a
department that's not in compliance I
think
um it would be presumed that this might
not
happen thank you representative
Welch yes this uh uh Bill provides a
public safety enhancement fund is that
only for the purchase of the
cameras
Happ thank you representative um as the
dra or as the bill is written funding
for these uh cameras shall be provided
by the state in the form of Grants the
grant is not specified so um we
hopefully got to a point where every
officer was equipped sufficiently and
the the funds uh continue to appr in
this account and could go toward that
purpose representative wels recognize
for a followup
question as we we've heard in the past
when we've had similar bills that the
major cost for body warn cameras is in
the retention of the images catalog as
was brought up before this is a a
an unfunded mandate under 28a we
probably shouldn't be
doing you
agree thank you sir for the question uh
that is not the intent of the
bill follow question my reading of the
bill indicates there would be a
considerable cost for the
locality theill
thank you uh I believe that the roll out
uh of this bill would be would structur
it would not cost additional money to
departments
than representative board
name thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um I'm also concerned
about the funding level for this being
coming in a mandate I'm wondering if you
would be uh
uh would mine a amendment that changes
uh line 25 from Shia to
May that way departments that wanted to
uh uh carry out this uh
um the body uh cameras would be allowed
to as long as there resp money in the uh
funding um and if we did this on a uh uh
a trial basis we could find out whether
or not the funding sources actually were
sufficient to uh cover the
cost thank you representative um not
being involved in the drafting
um I hesitate to offer an answer but I
believe uhing more officers through this
fund versus no officers would
be thank
you representative col the the chair has
a question I want to thank you in
advance for taking my question on the
second page lines five and eight what is
the rationale only allowing the body cam
footage to be used in in a Court
proceeding if it's exculpatory but not
if the footage is
incriminating representative thank you
um I'm going to offer to the best of my
knowledge which is this is a a snapshot
of the quite long existing statute
around how this footage can be used and
the key provision that I want to point
out to try to answer your question is
that this addresses a specific subset of
footage that was in violation of the
statute but which is also culpatory so
that's the key point so
U I would I would expect and having not
memorized the statute that it covers
what you were ask incriminating evidence
throughout and that this is the special
uh exception for exculpatory EVs and I
hope that answers your
question thank
you
seeing no further hands raised I want to
thank the representative for his
T the next person uh representative on
the list of testify now now
representative franch you are also here
participating on the committee you're
free to testify if you'd like or yes I
would like to Mr
chairman uh as one of the sponsors I
cannot ask questions so I would rather
testify um thank you for for letting me
testify uh I'm here to say that if you
are in favor of police if you support
the police then you should support this
bill because body cameras help police
officers perform their duties by filming
criminals in the act and that is truly
the important part is that it adds an
independent verifiable source of what
happened and that is why I am in favor
of body cameras and that's all I had to
say
representative Pratt it's a quick
question are you a police
officer are you a police off I'm not no
sir seeing no further hands raise
representative H thank you for your for
your
testimony next witness is Len
Harden I got
it should be
outside Mr Harden you begin your
testimony
um are you able to hear me
sir yes yes okay sorry about that a
little technical glitch um thank you Mr
chairman so my name is len Harden I'm an
attorney that practices primarily up in
Coos County and Grafton County I also
practice over in uh Carroll County uh I
am a defense lawyer I'm on the board of
directors of the New Hampshire
Association of criminal defense lawyers
uh which is a organization consisting of
approximately 250 New Hampshire lawyers
um we focus our work primarily on uh
criminal defense work uh our membership
includes private practitioners state and
federal public defenders we're an
affiliate of the National Association of
criminal defense lawyers and we share
our mission to ensure Justice and due
process for folks accused of crimes and
uh seeking to promote a uh fair and
proper administration of Criminal
Justice uh I've personally been a
defense lawyer for over 25 years and and
uh I'm taking this position as uh an
individual practitioner as well as a
member of the board of directors of New
Hampshire Association of criminal
defense
lawyers um in terms of the uh background
what I'd like to share with the the
committee would be that uh I personally
have handled thousands of cases uh
dealing directly with police and arrests
um during that time I'm constantly
amazed at and I understand that the
representatives concerns about cost but
I would actually submit that the cost of
a body warn camera actually reduces the
cost of an actual case on a Town um I I
practice as I said primarily in Grafton
Coos and Carrol counties and in large
part those towns uh some of those towns
are among the poorest in the
state among the poorest in the state I
would suggest that and it's my
experience that those towns actually
have been voluntarily using body warn
cameras for example Lisbon Berlin and
hail all use bodyw warn cameras what is
amazing to me is that some of the more
affluent towns in the police do not in
fact the state police do not use body
warn cameras uh in any of the cases that
I have had um and and quite candidly I
believe that that's simply wrong it's
not only wrong but it's dangerous it's
dangerous for the people in the public
it's dangerous for Citizens that are
accused and it's dangerous for the
police one of the things that I'd like
to share with the committee are a couple
of examples of what we have seen and and
some of the turmoil that it's created um
unfortunately there are fatal shootings
in New Hampshire and we have been
involved with some of those up in the
northern part of the state there are two
cases that I'd like to highlight for the
committee in particular there was a
fatal shoot shooting that was captured
by um body warn camera from the hail
Police Department it involved the SD
Lenin shooting in bath and in that
situation the haal police officers
confronted an individual um who had a
knife he took the knife and he charged
at the police the police were wearing
bodyw warn camera and it captured this
lethal potentially deadly attack and the
police responded by ordering the person
to stop they responded accordingly and
ultimately fired and shot the man dead
but the bodyw warn camera captured all
of that the urgency The lethality the
encounter was memorialized and able to
be observed by people under a a calmer
much more cool collected perspective and
it helped heal what was
occurring in contrast what I would
suggest is the the horrible shooting up
in
Franconia of Officer McKay was not
captured by by bodyw warn camera and it
I I don't know if you folks are familiar
with the situation but if I may I would
just go through the facts very briefly
there was a a young man Leo Kenny who
had been stopped by Officer McKay
previously they had had a runin um
officer McKay and he did not see well
eye to eye and um Mr Kenny was pulled
over by Officer McKay for a speeding
ticket
um we're there's no body warn camera so
we're taking people's uh we're taking
Snippets of people's recollection that
survived what we were have been able to
glean is that officer McKay ultimately
was told by Mr Kenny that I'm not
stopping for you I want another officer
and he sped off officer McKay forcibly
stopped Leo Kenny's car um forcing it to
stop stop um approached Mr Kenny pepper
sprayed him Mr Kenny then fired four
shots and and shot and killed Bruce
McCay um at that point uh Mr Kenny tried
to take off uh a passer by a George
Floyd provided a narrative that he saw a
gun and he picked up the police
officer's gun and he shot Leo kenned
when he refused to put his gun
down I tell this story so that you can
have both the example of having a body
born camera and the example of not
having one this town of Franconia is a
small village it's a very tight-knit
Village and prior to the shooting of Leo
Kenny and officer McKay I would say it
was a mostly harmonious Village since
that time and it's been quite a while
now um that town still has raw nerves
and wounds it's a town that's not well
it's not healed and it's been years and
years since those events have
transpired um so what I would urge this
committee to do is not to strike the
language of mandatory language requiring
body warn camera body warn cameras solve
situations that you could never imagine
arising they eliminate the conflicts
Because the actual footage of the event
is
preserved it makes it easier for courts
prosecutors lawyers citizens to feel
that they actually can observe the real
disputes instead about of arguing about
what happened what we spend our time
doing is
litigating the actual legal issues
there's no more question of he said this
or he said that you can hear the voices
you can see what was actually done and
we now consider whether something was
done properly or improperly so in that
regard I would suggest that having body
warn cameras actually saves times in
cour court because we're no longer
questioning what a person said or did we
actually get to see the body warn camera
the footage it also is safer because it
helps prevent examples of racism sexism
and bad
policing if there's an officer who is uh
repeatedly using language that's
inappropriate when addressing
individuals um it's going to be
captured we live in a state currently as
we all know which is mostly homogeneous
in terms of race especially in the
northern part of our state where I
practice however the rates of arrest the
rates of charges even stops and
ultimately incarcerations of people of
color is significantly higher body warn
camera would assure that the color of a
person's skin isn't the reason for a
stop a detention an arrest and
ultimately a conviction and
incarceration it's simply better for the
public it's simply better for our Citi
citizens and for the police I would also
suggest that the good police officer and
there are many Among Us um and I'm sorry
I have a hand up does that mean that I
should entertain a question am I allowed
to do
that that the questions will be asked at
the
conclusion okay I'm sorry haven't done
this
before so the as I was saying the video
footage saves towns time and money in
terms of court cost in terms of
uncertainty but it also ensures
accountability professionalism and
enhances training a supervisor doesn't
have to guess at how an officer is
behaving out on this on the road a
supervisor can watch the actual
interaction with citizens they can see
and and I can tell stories upon stories
there are certain officers who
ultimately
are repeatedly in conflict with citizens
and and it's not
it's very common that those officers
know how to rile people up or they're
just they're overly aggressive to such a
degree that they cause there to be
conflicts body warn cameras can help a
chief can help a Department's uh
officers that are in charge to take
control of the situation and help that
officer to learn how to lessen the
severity or or lessen interactions with
citizens it also has added benefits in
terms of saving cost because of reducing
um actual uh use of force it's there are
studies and I believe I submitted some
studies to the committee before uh this
hearing took place there are studies
that show that use of force decrease
with the use of bodyw warn camera that
when the police know that their
interactions are recording that
unreasonable behavior or anger or
hostility is De escalated it also has
been shown that the public feels more
trustworthy when they know that their
interactions are being recorded it helps
us to avoid the situation where we have
to guess because we now know what's
going on obviously the history this past
summer I believe that houseu 253 is more
important than ever in the past year
there have been police shootings and
they were shootings that were captured
by video and those shootings appear to
have been able to be resolved Because
the actual evidence
existed a lot of times those videos were
captured by by cell phones this law
would allow there to be a mandatory
recording so that we don't have to guess
and hope that there's somebody who's
nearby I would also point out that it
certainly where I practice in Northern
New Hampshire Coos Grafton and Carol
counties that there are frequently times
when a police officer is alone in fact I
I have colleagues that I consider
friends in the state police and the most
common Trooper on at night is Trooper
vacant what that means is that there's
no v no trooper that covers a certain
area it's not uncommon in Northern New
Hampshire that a single Trooper is
patrolling Coos and Grafton County
geographically that's an area that
probably covers three hours in
drive that officer is alone in a cruiser
any interaction that that officer has
when the blue lights go on would be
recorded using House Bill
253 what that means is that we're not
going to have to guess about what
occurred between that individual officer
and the public what it also means is
there's going to be a decrease in terms
of officers being accused of sexual
harassment officers being accused of
foul language officer who are accused of
misconduct of
abuse all of those situations can be
humiliated by having body worn footage
it just makes sense it makes sense for
the public it makes sense for the good
Troopers the good individuals that are
are in
uniform it makes no sense to continue
guesswork which is what we currently
have I'd like to share another story
about a situation that I think it
highlights how important video can be I
had a case a little while ago where a a
young lady accused a bar manager of
assaulting her the bar had video
recording system the bar video recording
system was able to exonerate that person
it was able to show that he was
wrongfully accused and
ultimately gas stations have this
technology uh convenience stores have
this technology if restaurants and
stores gas stations have all this
technology and it helps alleviate
potential thefts it alleviates and helps
identify things that could be going on
in a in a business what's more important
than police work in our streets and in
our communities I would suggest that the
public confidence the public and the
police uh assurity knowing that their
actions are going to be recorded will
help the good police officers will help
the citizens to feel safe secure and
protected I believe I did submit some
data to you and there are certainly
different com opponents to that data
about use of force and the complaints
but in short what they do show is that
police aggressiveness and recording have
been decreased when there is recordings
more importantly though the uncertainty
and the ambiguity is eliminated we know
what has
happened this bill for bodyw warn camera
making it man mandatory would protect
New Hampshire in five ways I would
submit that it captures the best
evidence of what was said and done
second that it leads to accountability
for the police and citizens third it
saves time in court by eliminating
issues and reducing frivolous arguments
and lawsuits it provides valuable
training to officers who can their
supervisors can use it it allows the
police academy to actually determine
whether somebody is a problem if they
have sexist if they have racist if they
have other aggressive tendencies which
need to be uh made that that the
authority needs to know better they
actually lower the cost to ensure good
quality procedures and protections are
followed and I think as the uh the
representative indicated who was
sponsoring the bill there already are
protocols in place for storage and
maintenance and those are legitimate
concerns I can tell you candidly working
with the towns like Lisbon and Berlin
and hail the towns that are among the
the poorest in the state that those
towns have fewer trials fewer conflicts
and save money because of this they do
have an administrator who provides the
video to my office or a defense counsil
that requests it or a citizen that
requests it what's even more important
about that is that this the cost of this
provides integrity and ensures public
confidence when you can actually watch
an interaction and the the Attorney
General's release these videos that have
resulted in fatalities people can feel
this was a Justified fatal shooting or
they may feel that it's not but it
provides daily access the the sixth
reason to support this would be that it
provides daily access to police work
allowing supervisors judges and citizens
to feel confident in short I would
conclude by saying that this is good
policy and it should be approved for the
citizens for the police and for the
betterman of New Hampshire
thank you for your
time thank you for your testimony
representative baling you recognize for
a question thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question I hope you
can hear
me um I thought it was interesting you
said that the use of body cameras um
would reduce the cost of a case as I
understand it our courts are funded
through the same mechanism that F this
bill so are you saying that we can save
money with this
bill I think the C yes I I think that
the the situation I I can just give you
a a a brief story when when there's an
accusation of uh somebody says that they
hit another person and it's captured by
Body warn camera there's no longer an
argument that the person said that it's
it's on film or if they actually get to
the scene or they watch a person driving
across the yellow line there's no
argument that they cross the yellow line
at the stop was
legitimate and for for years before
these towns had bodyw warn camera we
would certainly argue about whether
there was an actual admission or whether
the person displayed bad driving or
impairment represent B Bing you
recognize for a followup thank you Mr
chair have you heard of any situations
in which someone made an accusation
against police that was disproven using
body camera footage
uh yes I I I would say that I have heard
that I've also had the situation where
an officer has forgotten that the bodyw
warn camera is on and indicated that a a
defendant made a statement and the
statement wasn't actually made so it's
I've heard and seen both um and I would
say that the when people are in
emotional heightened States they don't
remember what happened as well as they
do in a normal calm state so the body
warn camera actually captures a person's
actions and words and I've seen it where
police have said things um that were
disproven and I've seen it where
citizens have said things and it's been
disproven and I've also seen the
opposite where the police say it and
then it's verified by the video and when
the citizen says it so it it really I
think is a is essential to helping our
system be more able to determine the
truth of a of a
matter representative
Knight um thank you chairman and thank
you uh for taking my question um you
spoke in your testimony about two
different towns one you gave an example
that had body cameras and one that did
not in your legal experience or time in
this profession can you can you give us
a rough estimate on how much a town pays
or using the ones in your testimony
versus how much they pay out of pocket
for a
lawsuit where they don't have evidence
such as this versus how much they pay
how much a town pays when they do have
this evidence I I can't give you any
numbers I am I practice exclusively in
criminal defense so I don't know what
the cost is to end suit but the towns I
believe do have legal counsel that I
know I know the lawyers from fton W um
frequently are involved in defending
these cases and they certainly spend um
significant amount of funds I I see that
a representative is hand up maybe he
knows the
answer Mr chairman um actually this is a
question for you
um do you since this bill doesn't have a
financial note does this this bill go to
a second
committee that is a great question and
and I I'm wondering why it does not have
any type of fiscal note makes it really
hard to
evaluate that issue and I know that the
custom is is that we're really supposed
to consider just the legality of that
and not the fiscal side of it but I have
a hard time ignoring that or following
that customer
s so I'm not sure if
this
should well then there's a 28a issue I
understand that I
don't we can discuss that more in
executive session I I don't know if this
will go to a second committee but it
certainly should go to a second
Committee in my
opinion but thank you m
CH if I may ask a question and I just
want to thank you in advance uh for
taking my question it it says
under under the paragraph five that
you the person who the police officer
encounters has to consent to being
recorded So
is there any estimation on how often
people ask to not be recorded So I feel
like there I agree that there's a lot of
positive that will happen for both
prosecution and defense by having these
you know encounters recorded but if the
person they encounter ask them to turn
it
off all that's out out the door and then
just curious if you know how often that
happens I I can't give you an actual
number but but I can tell you that um in
my experience the cases that I have seen
um I I very rarely I would say it and
this is anecdotal but I would say it's
less than 1% of the time that people ask
to have the camera shut off um typically
the encounters that I see are motor
vehicle stops an officer normally walks
up to a person and indicates sir ma'am
you're being recorded I'm letting you
know that you're being audio and video
recorded and then they say license and
registration and they're off um I can't
think of a case where I've had a citizen
indicate I don't want to be recorded I
have had cases where um people are
making allegations of sexual nature and
personal nature and they've indicated
that they would have lik to to go into a
room where there's not a recording and
they've also I've also seen cases where
people have gone into a room where they
wanted to provide information or
intelligence about drug dealing and
again they they asked not to be
recorded and those are in departments
that typically do recording of
interactions so in my experience I have
not seen people um demand that and
that's currently in our in our law as as
well that it has to be a the the
existing voluntary body warn statute I
think encompasses and requires
consent thank you questions
seeing no oh excuse me representative
hoer thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question what about a
circumstance where the uh person in
question is uh incapacitate
incapacitated and can't give consent uh
traffic accident the person's injured or
they're drunk and they're not in any
position to give consent to
any
I can't answer all situations but I can
tell you that I've certainly seen a lot
of body warn camera of people that are
incapacitated so um I know what happens
um I don't I think it's more a situation
that a person has to actually assert the
right to not be recorded and as long as
there a person has been advised that an
interaction is recording I also think
and one of the concerns that I I know is
going to be raised is the uh issue of
civil liberties and whether we should be
recording people with without their
knowledge and that's what
this portion of the statute actually
addresses is that a person can demand
not to be recorded and it has to be a
volitional act to say that I do not want
to be recorded um but again I would
point out the the common occurrence if
you work in a convenience store go to a
gas station you're recorded if you go to
Walmart you're recorded I mean we're all
being recorded um all the time we we may
not have audio in Walmart but we're
certainly being recorded there's
monitors on our lives I think it's
incumbent upon us to protect our
citizens and our police by recording
their
interactions thank
you representative Pratt I have a
question is this
video Freedom of Information
material I'm sorry you broke up sir I
couldn't hear you um is this information
available the Freedom of Information Act
so somebody said I want to see the video
of so install stop the other day would
they be able to get that information
from loc the there's actually the the
current law prohibits this from being
disseminated through the Freedom of
Information Act there are situations and
there are protocols that a person can
get it
revealed um but generally speaking it's
not permitted there's a there's a fairly
uh tight window if you will allowing
dissemination
thank
you representative
Ms just one uh one quick question we
were talking a little bit earlier uh
about the benefits of requiring this
versus making it optional in your mind
what are the benefits of doing this
uniformly across the state I I think
they're off the charts fantastic um one
of uh the benefits that have from having
done this for a while is I go to
seminars across the country and I can
tell you that in other states in
particular I know South Carolina has a
mandatory requirement and they'
centralized all of their video um body
warn cameras and Cruiser cameras and
it's available to the defendants
lawyers without anyone having you
basically have a password and it allows
you to watch them it streamlined it
enormously one of the things that most
is is my one of my biggest concerns is
that the New Hampshire State Police
simply don't use body warn camera or
cruiser camera and they're probably the
mo they I without a doubt they're the
most well-funded
agency that I deal with and I think
there's no good reason for them to be
opposed to it I think it ultimately it
streamlines cases completely it
eliminates credibility issues and it
protects officers and the public from
false allegations um but think making it
uniform is essential to making it um to
helping to pay for it because the towns
currently that are doing so like Berlin
and havil and Lisbon are among the
poorest towns in the state and they have
seen the benefits of it and it it just I
think if you had more towns bigger towns
that were participating the the benefits
would continue to grow exponentially so
I I absolutely would encourage uniform
application of a bodyw warn statute it
it makes perfect sense in every possible
conceivable way that I can
imagine thank
you seeing no hand hands raised I want
to thank the witness for his testimony
thank
you are there any members of the public
that are presentent would wish to
testify please raise your
hand Mr chair I also had a chief
Goldstein that signed up to
speak what called Chief Goldstein
please
Mr chairman I think you called On Me
Chief
gste yes oh thank you sir um it just uh
knocked me out and then brought me back
so um and just before I start um and
introduce myself for the record uh Chief
acki would also like to speak after me
if you don't
mind his hand is
raised okay um you can hear me all right
then yes we can fine thank you uh good
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee I'll be very brief in my
remarks uh for the record my name is
David Goldstein I'm the chief of police
for the city of Franklin I've been a
police officer for 41 years and 16 of
those years in two separate police
departments both which have been
financially strapped police departments
by the way this morning I do represent
the New Hampshire Association of chiefs
of police and we are taking a neutral
position on HB 253 at this time for the
most part Chiefs are not opposed to U
the use of body cameras however it is
the funding issue that brings us uh
before you today uh and we feel that to
some degree some of what's been written
up in this bill may be somewhat
shortsighted um there are often grants
uh available for police departments to
purchase install and Implement body
cameras but those monies have a tendency
to dry up very rapidly after after the
fact and here in Franklin we've
experienced that twice with our Cruiser
cameras uh so there's very little money
for sustainability of the um of the
initiative many departments have found
that other costs are storage
administrative cost data retrieval and
Freedom of Information Act requests to
name a few and according to the police
uh Executive Research Foundation uh
depending on the size of the department
obviously costs are very uh large
consideration and their research in 2018
indicated that for a large Department
such as uh Manchester or Nash you'd be
talking somewhere in the vicity of $1.4
million uh just to just for the agency
cost the uh storage Etc for a large
agency like that would be close to $4
million a year according to um according
to what per found obviously for smaller
agencies uh such as my my agency and
others in the state which is the
majority we're speaking much less but
they're looking at figures of around
$997,000 um to implement the program and
storage costs uh certainly are expensive
as well so that is uh on
record we question the source of the
funding uh somewhere in the in the bill
it was mentioned about the penalty
assessment uh contributing to this quite
frankly that's been declining for a
number of years and that's why the
legislature a few years ago opted to
take the the funding of the police
academy out of the penalty assessment
and give it to the general fund uh
because we no longer um uh collect the
fees that we once did and in fact at the
time and I testified on that bill some
years ago at the time um there was a he
said she said type of argument between
AOC and law enforcement and that we were
maintaining and and asserting that the
courts were not uh collecting um penalty
assessment in the courts are telling us
we weren't charging people with the uh
with the violations so you can leave
that to your imagination as well
questions that we do have is how do
these allocations work certainly the
bill has made reference to the fact that
the Attorney General's office will come
up with some sort of Grant proposal and
program but when you're a small
Department such as mine or chief a
Becky's eventually when he speaks uh as
compared to let's say a Manchester
nashille or any large town for that
matter such as Derry London Derry or
Salem uh do we get the leftovers and
they get the The Lion Share of the of
the monies that's not meant to be
negative that's meant to be a legitimate
question and certainly uh if we do
initiate the process what happens if the
funding
decreases or actually disappears are we
then in violation of Statute and are we
now under again an unfunded mandate we
do feel that the bill can work certainly
and as I said we're more than happy to
participate in any process that'll bring
us these um bring us up to date with all
of these um initiatives however we feel
that we need some more work on it it's
not ready as I've heard so many times in
committee not ready for Prime Time thank
you and I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you chief for your
testimony representative Knight thank
you chair and thank you chief for
answering my question do current New
Hampshire police cars have Dash C
some do and some don't
yes represent represent n you recognize
for a followup
question thank you chair have an
approximate number of how many do and
how many don't I do
not representative
Newman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you chief for taking my question um we
hear a lot about the 28a
costs and usually there are costs that
you can predict like um
funding um when organizations like yours
do you know if your organization or any
others when they figure the funding cost
include those predictable costs and take
into account also the reductions that
are
potential that we heard from previous
witnesses that indicate that there could
be even a greater or maybe even a much
greater um
cost savings if you did not if the town
or the city did not have to do the
litigation that they may do now which
might be eliminated by the use of body
cameras do you have any information on
that kind of um
sure that's an excellent question
representative um certainly when we
prepare our budget every year we go
through all of these machinations
and we try to predict what we're going
to need what we're not going to need uh
outside the realm of this for example is
court time uh so for for instance if we
have a very busy year I'm paying a lot
of money in court time if we have a less
busy year I'm paying less money in court
time so certainly we try to go through
these these calculations with things
such as uh body cams uh first and
foremost you have to remember that
communities such as Franklin and
Manchester are tax cap cities so our
city managers have to come in on budget
period it's against the law for her not
to do that so right then and there I can
certainly ask for let's say $100,000
round figures uh for body cams to try to
alleviate any difficulties that might be
forthcoming but certainly uh that money
isn't isn't predictable at this
particular point in time at least for
Franklin I can only speak certainly for
my own City uh as far as litigation
issues are concerned I heard what
council had to say and I certainly
appreciate that how however I can tell
you in 11 years here as Chief in
Franklin we have not had one lawsuit uh
so I think that's a pretty good record
now that doesn't mean that tomorrow we
won't but certainly that that speaks to
the professionalism of this particular
police department and the people that
serve this particular community so I
think that you're talking about a lot of
um abstract uh numbers here as well but
certainly to answer your question in
totality uh we are uh always playing
that that type of scenario game if you
will what if what will we need so on and
so forth and many's a year that I've
gone without new Cruisers because of
budget
concerns I hope that help thank you no
thank you for your thorough question I
qu
answer representative
Muse yes thank you for taking my
question uh our previous witness uh
talked about the fact that uh there are
some communities up in po like uh
I think ha
R and Berlin that he mentioned already
have in our using body Cs and um the
fact that those towns don't have
especially bright phical pictures either
uh I'm I'm curious if you know just how
they managed to do
it I'm sorry representative I lost the
last part of that it broke up sure I'm
I'm curious to know how community like
Berlin uh Franklin and Lisbon uh who who
don't have a lot of Revenue and have
Financial issues uh have been managed to
have have been able uh to manage to
afford to equip their police officers
with body camps uh in the absence of a
requirement from the state uh or from a
funding mechanism like the one in the
bill certainly and I can't really answer
for those departments because I don't
work for them and nor do they work for
me but uh again I can make perhaps an
educated guess to some degree here and
say that they have made that a priority
uh for their budgetary considerations in
their in their respective towns um and
that certainly knowing those towns as I
do uh their activity levels are a little
bit less than we are down here in the
central and southern tiers of the State
uh Etc so that does take a u take its
toll uh financially and again uh being a
tax cap Community uh we have to come in
on point uh one year my manager came in
18 cents under the budget the required
budget that's how specific and precise
these budgets are so uh I still have to
pay um uh benefits I still have to pay
salaries I still have to pay court time
I still have to pay overtime Etc equip
my officers buy new Cruisers and all
that just like everybody else so it's
what the community will bear it would be
my best guess
Muse you recognize for a followup
question
thank actually I think uh I think you
actually answered my question um thank
you you more than
welcome representative true thank you Mr
chair thank you chief for taking my
question you had given some an example
of a yearly cost say for the city of
Manchester uh could you uh run those
past us again I think it was maybe a
million dollars a year for equipment and
four million for storage or what what
was what was that money for this the the
figures I have uh were for by perf again
that's the Police Executive Research
Foundation uh they do a lot of work for
us obviously research Etc
um they came out with some general costs
Nationwide uh certainly uh the uh larger
agencies they considered it 250 sworn
plus officers so their maximum agency
cost in that regard which Manchester
might well fit into would be um in 2018
was 1 uh3 almost $1.4
million uh to fund the uh initiative
cameras
Etc were uh excuse me storage was $4
million um per year for a large agency
now certainly we're probably talking uh
agencies that far exceed those here in
New Hampshire as well so these are just
general figures but the point of the
matter that we've all discussed amongst
ourselves as well as with our our our
bodies whether it be select persons or
councils city councils is the fact that
these are still very expensive
propositions for us to uh to engage in
and as a result we have to be very very
frugal and decide what best what's the
best program for each and every
individual
Department seeing no further hands
raised I want to thank you chief for
your testimony my pleasure thank
you CH We Now call uh
Sophia
and welcome
back hello can you hear me yes we
can do I need to turn my video
on we lost you for a moment so we want
to start from the beginning okay um do I
need to turn my video on or
anything you don't you don't have to
it's
it's all right um so thank you Mr chair
and members of the committee for taking
my testimony today again my name is
Sophia Bondo I'm 14 I live in Manchester
and I'm speaking today on behalf of the
New Hampshire High School Democrats in
support of
hp253 I am in support of hp253 because I
believe that it is a bill that can
receive bipartisan support and will make
a meaningful difference in our state
requiring body cameras for police make
sense they can be used by police
departments as a training tool and to
determine when police take courageous
actions to protect our communities they
can also be used to bring Justice for B
victims of unlawful and potentially
deadly conduct body cameras raise
awareness and accountability for both
the good and the bad in our police
forces the usual financial implications
of a change like this may also be a sing
point for some of you however this bill
lays out a grant system to pay for the
cameras that is Created from
appropriating just 1% of funds from the
penalty assessment fund so in conclusion
under hp253 the police will benefit the
people will benefit and the taxpayers
will not be impacted please show young
people like me that bipartisanship is
still possible in politics today and
vote in support of hp253
thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witnesses
excuse chief
hcky
Chief you may you may begin your
testimony can you hear me uh CH Mr
chairman yes we can Mr chairman members
of the committee my name is Joo Becky
I'm the chief of police in Hollis I'm
also the first vice president for the
New Hampshire Chiefs Police Association
I testify today um really as a neutral
position on behalf of this bill um I
felt inclined I I didn't plan to testify
however I felt inclined uh to just say a
few words about this uh proposed
legislation uh my agency Hallis PD we
are of an an agency of 16 police
officers we currently have body cameras
we've had body cameras since
2016 we recently updated to a integrated
uh Cruiser camera
body camera system actually as of last
week we did that and I can tell you that
the cost over a 5year period is
$160,000 um and that includes the
equipment in the cloud storage which is
considerably uh which is the most um the
highest proportion of the uh the costs
associated with the program
itself um I do know that Chief aldenberg
from Manchester has the same body warn
camera system that we have here in
Hollis and I believe he's listening and
he can certainly provide you um some
ideas on um the cost of the program uh
from his agency which is a a very large
a agency of course I will say this that
I was uh a member of the leak
legislation workg group committee and um
so we worked on Senate Bill
96 which includes language relative to
setting up a fund in the state budget
for the purchase of body warn camera in
incar camera
systems um I certainly think that this
is probably a better Avenue uh in terms
of trying to fund this important program
I am a firm believer in body warn
cameras and agree very much with the the
testimony of the previous
Witnesses um I would say that in terms
of reduced litigation I have not really
seen a reduction in
litigation uh because we do have body
camera systems in terms of uh criminal
prosecution of course we haven't had any
lawsuits thankfully um but certainly I
don't know that there you know the use
of body cameras has resulted in a
reduction in uh criminal prosecutions or
criminal cases of of any sort so I can't
really speak to that because I can't
quantify that for you at this time I
will say I do have concerns with funding
it through the penalty assessment if you
recall and I know uh Chief Goldstein
testified to this uh the police academy
used to be funded by the penalty
assessment fee um their budget their
annual budget is about $3 and A5
million and we found that the penalty
assessment fee was insufficient to fund
a $3.5 million B uh budget I can tell
you that body cameras a body warn camera
system throughout the state a mandatory
system would be far more than $3.5
million um so just to put that into
context I am more than happy to work
with members of the committee or any
other stakeholders to help figure out
innovative ways to fund this I believe
in the program I believe in the system I
think it helps increases
transparency and so as such I will Avail
myself to assisting in whatever capacity
I can as a chief of police with that uh
this concludes my testimony I'll open it
up to any questions from members of this
committee thank you chief for your
testimony representative
c um thank you chair um thank you for
taking my question um so you find Body
camps to be a win-win situation for both
the um officers as well as the public is
that correct I do yes ma'am thank
you representative Muse
thank you for taking my question Chief
um uh it uh it sounds like you are a
participant on the on the leak
commission uh so uh I'm hoping you may
have some insight into uh into uh some
additional insight into s sp96 does s
sp96 the Senate Bill actually require
body cams to be worn which this bill
does so representative Muse so I was um
actually on the work group the
legislative work group so I can't speak
on behalf of the the commission uh but
what I will say is initially yes
initially we were going to mandate that
departments uh were required to have
bodyw warn camera uh systems however
when I explained how significant the
cost
was uh it was pretty clear it would
become an unfunded mandate it just
wouldn't be realistic to accomplish that
objective without some some source of
funding realistic source of funding and
so we changed um the language um to set
up a fund um in the budget the state
budget for purchase of bodyw camera uh
and incar camera systems uh at a future
time and I think that's a more logical
approach let's face it if I had you know
a magic wand I would wave it today and
everyone would have these in the state
that just that's just what I believe but
I'm one Chief and I'm fortunate enough
to have support in terms of funding this
program so I hope I answered your
question sir thank
you representative
Newman uh thank you chair Mr chair and
thank you chief for taking my
question um I was recorded for 26 years
as an air traffic controller and I found
that there was a benefit in recording
for training and in fact even lawsuits
where trainees alleg that they were not
trained properly do you see any uh
benefits like that might ACR from the
fact that you do have body
camera AB absolutely
um you know there there's always a
training component uh in terms of these
videos um
additionally it ensures that when we
conduct Internal Affairs in
investigations that we have the best
information and evidence available in
order to come to a impartial and fair
finding on a given complaint or
allegation of
impropriety and I can tell you that the
body warn cameras have resulted um in
officers being cleared of wrong
wrongdoing and they've also allowed us
to hold officers accountable for any uh
minor or major policy violations of such
um so you know in my humble opinion as a
as a law enforcement practitioner I mean
why wouldn't you want a tool that
provides a higher level of transparency
and does many of the things of which
Bonnie War camera systems do
do representative
Newman thank you Mr chair for a followup
um do you think there's any possibility
that these unknown benefits that would
have a very very hard time to uh figure
what the C what the savings of them
would be could possibly outweigh the um
the drawbacks uh that we suffer due to
tax caps and uh
28a concerns about
the yeah I think um with every cost
there's certainly a saving
somewhere um um so I look at it you know
strictly from the aspect of civil
litigation I
mean if there is an allegation of
impropriety or misconduct that results
in um civil litigation that results in
some type of
settlement um the reality is those costs
could probably fund a bodyw warn camera
system for our
agency for many years over um so I look
at it in terms of that you know cost
benefit analysis um and you know real my
job as a chief representative is to m is
to mitigate risk you know and sometimes
when you mitigate risk there's a price
tag that's associated with it and that's
the reality of it but I would not be
doing my job in mitigating risk if I
didn't provide my officers with the best
tools available to keep them safe to
make sure they're operating in a highly
transparent
environment and then you know providing
a even higher level of uh uh
accountability for them for both good
and bad because it work it works both
[Music]
ways thank
you representative
board thank you Mr chairman thank you
chief for uh taking my question
um I did hear that you are not your
department doesn't necessarily have body
worn cameras have you asked your funding
agency probably visable government to uh
fund such
apparatus uh representative we we do
actually have them we've had them since
2016 and uh we recently updated to a new
system which provides some better
Technologies and
capabilities represent board a followup
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
Chief um so did you have to allocate for
uh body War cameras were or did the city
that you work for uh
mandated um so so we were not mandated
um we proactively um entered into an
agreement in 2016 in which we followed
the you know um appropriate budgetary
requirements and funding
requirements this time around um we had
planned to fund this new program in the
capital Improvement plan which would
take effect in 2021 April of
2021 however it became aware to us that
the cost would significantly increase
come January 1 so what we did do by the
some vacancies and such we had some
Surplus in our 2020 fiscal year budget
we were able to fund the first year and
that allowed us with the opportunity to
lock in that price before the costs
increased uh on January 1st so we knew
we were going to do this and we were
able to actually save a little bit of
money to the taxpayer by um being
creative with our budget process I again
I think it comes down to what chap
goldsteen said you know if agencies make
this a priority they'll do the their
best to find the funding for
it thank you thank you
sir representative m
Chief do you think that there's any
possibility of uh communities um working
together or or do you know maybe in
other states if uh if communities and
municipalities actually work together to
do things like get cloud storage at
lower prices to buy equipment in larger
Lots so um is there a
way we have if we do if we do choose to
make requirement uh do you think there
are ways that um that the cost could be
brought down for communities through
smarter
purchasing yeah I do I think
um you know I think very much like with
the state bid
program if the state were to release
some type of RFP and I believe they're
working on this for body War camera
systems and identify you know lowcost
vendor um that agencies could enter into
agreements to have a lower funded or a
lower cost body War camera system or
maybe even you know bulk based on region
or at the state level I mean there's a
lot of logistics that would go into it
but I do believe there's some
opportunity to do that and if you look
we kind of do that already with
integrated um r with radio
interoperability and uh combined
dispatch centers with police and fire
and regionalized centers so I think the
stru is there I think it's just how we
can best approach this but really the
funding part is the most important piece
and if we don't do that it would be like
having a car with an engine you know you
can't drive the car without the engine
so I I think we have to have that
realistic logical funding mechanism in
place
first representative you recognize for
PA
question um one of one of the things
that I'm
kind of curious about is um your
reaction instead of the idea body cams
you know optional versus
required um perhaps extending uh
creating a timeline uh that would uh
phase in uh it would actually phase it
in as a requirement uh over a period of
maybe two or three years um that would
seem to give community the ability to
take advantage you know of Grants when
they're available of maybe a better year
than this one on the budget cycle is
that is that something that
uh you would be open
to yeah I mean I don't want to speak for
every Chief in the state but if I was
looking as a means to intitute Institute
this program I think you know the whole
having a realistic funding mechanism and
then some type of obtainable timeline in
order to do this
um it certainly doesn't benefit us that
we're in the midst of a global pandemic
and there's a lot of budgetary
restrictions on this but you know for
example States like New Jersey with some
of the uh recommendations following the
incidents from this past year I believe
New Jersey made it a mandatory
requirement that body cameras be used by
agencies in that state but what they did
do was set up a state fund for it for
agencies to purchase the equipment with
so you know again I think the funding
piece is most important and as you know
representative that's always the piece
that's most
debated hope I answered your question
yes you did thank
you thank you and uh see no further
hands up I will excuse the
witness thank you sir before I call the
next witness given
the unticipated amount of time that this
just took we're probably going to have
to work for the lunch break so if any
member wants to take a five or 10 minute
break on the on their own
time feel fre to do that but we're going
to have to get through a lot of the we
have we're behind already we have two
bills this
afternoon
so use that as your
discretion calling the next witness will
will
Stewart so I I can limit testimony going
forward there was only three Witnesses
signed up on the list for more raised
the hand thereafter
and my it's the purpose of the chair
that if I do limit testimony that is
limited start to finish so unfortunately
uh going forward I'm probably going to
limit testimon on every every Bill and
essentially the amount of questions we
just because we do have time
frame and especially when we're talk
about funding when there's no fiscal no
Tas
Mr chairman can you hear
me yes we can excellent sorry for the
delay there uh just got let back in for
the record uh my name is Will Stewart
I'm the executive director of stay work
play New Hampshire which is a Statewide
nonprofit whose mission is to attract
and retain more young people here in the
granite state and here today to speak
very briefly appreciate uh the time the
committee is putting into this uh
hearing uh but here to speak today in
favor of uh of how Bill 253 so by way of
explanation I will say that attracting
and retaining more young people here is
critical to the future of New Hampshire
uh as you may know we're the second
oldest state in the country with one of
the lowest unemployment rates and on top
of this we're the number one exporter of
high school graduates seeking a
four-year degree so 62% of these young
people leave the state every year and
some eventually come back but many don't
so in short New Hampshire needs all the
people that we can get just in general
and then all the the young people we can
get in particular our businesses need
workers and customers our towns need
volunteer board members our nonprofits
churches and Civic clubs all need
volunteers to accomplish their vital
missions uh without which our
communities just can't function so about
three years ago stor play commissioned
this big survey to collect data on why
young people stay in and might leave New
Hampshire and one of the reasons we
found that young people might leave is
due to our state's lack of diversity and
we heard this over and over again last
fall and winter as we talked to young
people all across the state in nine
locations um as part of our policy and
pint series and indeed New Hampshire's
lack of diversity was a top three reason
that young people cited for potentially
leaving New Hampshire and so as a result
of these findings increasing diversity
equity and inclusion here in New
Hampshire has become a policy priority
for stay workk play and it's the reason
that we support House Bill 253 today
which seeks to increase accountability
from and Trust in law enforcement which
uh is very necessary if we want to attra
attract and retain more people of color
so uh thank you for your attention and
consideration of um supporting House
Bill 253 thank
you thank you for your
testimony the wance is
excused call l l Marie husack
thank you Mr chair committee members can
you hear me yes we can thank you very
much I am the director of Professional
Standards for the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections and the New
Hampshire Department of Corrections is
in support of this bill with a requested
amendment I will first say that body
warn cameras are essential to the
correction setting for the same reasons
that have been articulated already by
attorney Harding and the chief of police
um that have already spoken to
you quest that we have is that right now
under the current
105d um the state of New Hampshire
Department of Corrections has obtained a
grant for a number of body warn cameras
that Grant however is not sufficient to
cover all of the areas that we would
like to cover the current language as it
is drafted and the bill is introduced
limits what we believe the Department of
Corrections ability to get any grants
that might be obtainable under this new
law so for example and I did submit
testimony already but unfortunately
there was an error in the testimony
where I spoke about line 20 what uh
we're actually looking to do if you on
page one in the bill as introduced at
line 13 and at line
16 on page one we want to eliminate the
word police and maybe it we don't know
that it's definitely needed but if you
need a different Lang a different um set
of words in there to put for certified
Law Enforcement Officers so the
provision would
read at line starting on line 12 as
provided in this chapter this fund shall
be used to pay the cost of local count
and state use and then strike the word
police or of um police body War cameras
and add for certified law enforcement
officers and the same would be at line
16 striking the word police warn body
cameras and putting in body warn cameras
for certified law enforcement
officers and with those changes the
Department of Corrections again supports
this bill um recognizing though too as
our testimony did point out that that
right now it does appear that it is an
unfunded mandate U but to the extent
that the bill will be passed uh we would
request those
amendments I'm happy to take any
questions I want to thank thank you for
your testimony and W witness is
excused thank you
see no hands raised in the public uh at
this time we can we will uh conclude the
hearing close the hearing on House Bill
553 and Mr chairman we had uh for for HB
253 we had 71 people signing in in
support and three in opposition
thank you representa
AB at this time the chair open the
public hearing on House Bill
here recognize representative long
introduce
Bill good morning chairman abbis members
of the committee I'm representative Pat
long representing Hillsboro district 10
within the city of
Manchester H Bill 375 as a result of a
request from lieutenant Louie of the
Manchester Police Department that I had
a discussion with to understand the
problem and look for its potential
Solutions my first question was on Val
valueless Contraband we all place value
on items that uh may have value to us
however it has no value to someone else
it was explained to me that items that
are that are taking up valuable space in
the evidence room for example a backpack
with to brush dirty socks and underwear
also property that the auctioneer would
not include in an auction
um that in their opinion would not
receive any any bids uh my second
question was on a time frame that would
be expended in Sinking the owner or said
property and the answer was over the
required 90 to 180 days and often times
longer uh the attempt in locating the
property owner were more often difficult
because of the transientness of this
population also of not of value they
were not interested in recovering the
abandoned
property as a as a Manchester Alderman I
recall discussions on leasing space for
the expansion of evidence and and adding
evidence technicians to the department
compliment of course they both came at
an added cost after reading Lieutenant
Lou testimony related to
20192020 uh the processing of over
29,000 articles with thousands of items
fit in the description of this bill I
clearly saw a justification uh in
bringing House Bill 375 forward for your
consideration um I want to thank the
committee for their consideration on
House Bill 375 and I ask that it leaves
your committee with a favorable
recommendation and if it pleases the
chair um I have a Manchester Police
Department evidence technician Rachel
wad Witch uh who's uh prepared to
articula articulate better than I could
uh any questions the committee could
have I I could give him a stab at too
I'm not sure I don't get to see who's
here or not so I'm not sure uh if Rachel
is here but I uh and I and I just want
to confirm that everybody received uh
Lieutenant uh Lou uh testimony and I I
thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
your testimony what was what was the
name of the uh man
officer
uh Lieutenant Louis testimony but the
evidence uh technician is Rachel uh is a
Rachel Brad witch she is present Mr
chairman please please call um the
evidence te
testify actually she doesn't have
testimony Mr chairman she's just here to
support me and any questions the
committee may
have yes all
right my my mistake I thought I thought
the that's
okay
represented
Bo I don't believe that
Rachel
okay repres you
recognized I'm sorry
um so what happens to uh if the U
counter ban owner is imprisoned is that
90 days still uh
apply good uh question uh representative
I I I believe the case is yes but miss
raditch would you know further details
on
that
hi good afternoon my name is Rachel Mar
just want to confirm that you can hear
[Music]
me Mr chair she was confirm me if we
could hear
her
hi good afternoon just want to confirm
you can hear
me's mut Chairman's
mut
um Miss Brad witch there's an incredible
large amount of background noise we
can't really hear you so that it's it's
actually louder than than what you're
saying so so we that's why we muted you
I don't know if you can either SM
written testimony or find
a part or place I'm not I'm not quite
sure what the difficulty
is representative Muse do you have an
answer for
this I I don't have an answer for this
uh other than she tried to get to
acquirer
place
[Music]
well while we while we figure that out
representative long do you have any
additional uh testimony you wish to
provide I don't
no seeing no questions representative w
we can we can excuse you can be excused
if uh representative rad wishes to
testify uh we'll give her that
opportunity thank you Mr chairman Mr
chairman she she's she's not g to
testify she was just here to help me
support an answer question so I answered
the question for representative vnet and
um so yes she's not but but could I
confirm that everybody did receive
Lieutenant Louise testimony that I sent
to the
committee do you are you in receipt of
that committee
members did he sent it who sent it when
when when was it sent I sent it to the
committee uh I believe THS Thursday or
Wednesday
Friday I have it yes it was s
all right thank thank you Mr chairman
thank you committee
members they both need to be removed I
just removed them thank you can you move
Rachel r as well um yeah I will make
sure I'll disable
talking they're
both see you know hands raised
from the public at this time we can
close the public hearing of House Bill
375 if people the members of the public
who wish to
testify just for the sake of timing it
would be uh the chair's preference and
really to preference of the whole
committee I would assume if everyone
raised a hand from the start so we we
have a better way of of timing
everything
so we have a call-in user
a and before and before you begin your
testimony please State your full name
where you testifying from whether you're
testifying in support or in opposition
of housefield
hello yes let me turn down my speaker uh
I I did the star six I didn't know
somebody told me star n sorry about
that uh my name is uh Joe H I live in
gilmington and I've been before your
committee before this is the first time
by by zoom and I just have a comment on
uh Roman numeral
2 you can hear me
okay we can hear you
fine okay uh the key word is
determined uh in the middle there if it
is determined in good faith by the uh
police department what I would my
suggestion is because of past experience
I'll tell you in a minute is that the
determination should be made by another
body of the town I think sort of like
the board of selectman because let me
give you an
example is I was involved in a court
case once and my stun gun was never
returned by the police chief this was
town of Ashlin Ernie parette I never got
it
back and uh it it would have been nice
if it was gone over to the board of
selectman then they would have notified
me saying well the police chief I guess
he uh pocketed it or gave it to somebody
else I don't know I never got to the
bottom line but I just thought it would
be a like a checking balance that's all
I have to
say unless you have a
question determination deter
determination should be done by third
party not not just the
cop thank you thank you for your
testimony seeing no further questions
the the witness is excused thank
you
this time the chair is going to close
the public
hearing on House Bill
375 and Mr chairman on House Bill 375 we
had three people signing in in support
and two people signing in in
opposition thank you representative
Muse representa M we're gonna
now we're going to we're going to break
until well we're going to try to S some
get some executive s done would have
been our our lunch
break but we'll we'll break through at
least
123 I 1:30 is the next schedul hearing
no next heing is at
1:30 you guys want to stay
late I don't have Aur we can 12 1230
13 12:30 sound good for everyone yeah
true Mr chair are you what come back at
12:30 and work on exacting some bills
yes it's not dead time it's exact yes
yes okay 12:30 it is we eat here
uh yes everyone needs to turn off the
their
cameras
unfortunately the St house sort of a
dead area Mr Mr chairman the room is not
muted that is normally the
responsibility of Representative Wallace
who
95 20
[Music]
minutes
yeah that's
fine being responsible track I saw a
spinal tap in Boston I was the only one
there they didn't even show
up Mr
chairman
name uh did you notice that I submitted
an amendment for uh uh
553 553
just uh it was not going to be ready
until Wednesday so we can postpone it uh
executing that until that until
Wednesday what what's the
amendment uh changes the uh word CH to
May and makes the the change that the
Department of Corrections wanted from uh
police to uh a certified public
certified law enforcement
well let's listen let's just who knows
how long is going to go for number
one
[Music]
for
all right can everyone hear
us at this at this time the chair is
going to open the executive session on
House Bill
would you like to be recognized I
believe you have an amendment Le be a
positive
motion uh yes Mr chairman I would like
to be recognized to move uh an amendment
to HB
498 uh the amendment is uh 2021
d0
255h
I may just have a
moment sorry represent representative I
didn't mean to interrupt you I think my
understanding is it has to be a positive
motion first and then you can offer the
the
amendment Mr unless I'm mistaken I have
we did an executive session on
498 we did we did an ex an exe we so we
there was a motion made by
representative John BT uh representative
BT and then that that motion of the pass
was withdrawn so we did a roll call to
withdraw to withdraw the motion every
vote because we're doing this uh hybrid
style digitally one of the requirements
is that every vote is done by roll call
vote
so so we'll do another I will the same
form CH another list yes okay thank
you representative M you can be
recognized um thank you Mr chairman um I
would like to be recognized to propose
uh uh an amendment to HB
498 uh the amendment is 2021
d02
55h
you may speak to that
Amendment thank you um this amendment
will hopefully uh draw to a a conclusion
uh a kind of an ongoing uh controversy
and issue uh that we've been attempting
to try to resolve as a committee and A
legislature for uh for about the last
three years now uh representative
Alexander and I were on a study
committee that actually looked into the
payment of bail Commissioners training
issues identification issues a whole
bunch of issues but one of the things
that really I think jumped out at
everybody was the fact that the way that
our system is set up now Bill
Commissioners are the the only people uh
who work for the state and who work for
the court system who actually do their
job and aren't guaranteed to be
compensated for it um so what
essentially uh we we've done with the
bill uh I think we we all heard the
concerns of Judge King uh judge king
last week and one of his uh biggest
concerns was um uh the fact that he
seemed to want the uh the legislature to
Define indig indigency for the purpose
of the bail commissioner's fee um one of
the things that representative Alexander
reminded me of offline is that uh HB uh
1645 which was the the Omnibus criminal
justice bill that was passed last year
um actually requires the court system to
do that so the the court system was uh
was and I'll essentially read you the
line uh out of the
RSA uh but the the line out of the RSA
says the court shall develop uniform
criteria to evaluate and determine
whether an offended uh whether an
offender is Indigent or not Indigent for
the purpose of the offender's ability to
pay the bill Commissioners fee based on
the criteria the court shall render a
finding of indigent or not Indigent for
the purpose of the offender's ability to
pay the bail commissioner's fee so in in
in other words we left it up to uh the
administrative Court to figure out how
they wanted to handle this and uh it
became apparent or it's become apparent
that they haven't quite figured that out
yet um I think representative Alexander
and I both agreed
that this is something that they they
need to figure out so what the amendment
does is it it essentially inserts a
reminder uh and a reference uh to the to
the
RSA um and it uh it essentially does not
change the requirement in the in the
bill at any way that the court system
pay the the bail commissioner fee um and
what it also does is it does remove some
of the other things that were concerned
to judge King uh so he was concerned
about the ad about appointing 10
different uh County commissions uh to uh
to you know to to recruit and approve um
new bail Commissioners uh and he was
also uh uh concerned about um the
transfer of
responsibilities uh from the administ uh
from the administrative Court of the
Circuit Court to the uh to the Superior
Court uh for bail commissioners so we've
removed that and so essentially what you
have in front of you in this amendment
is what is the entire bill now and what
I would say is that this bill really
sort of does address the concerns of the
bail Commissioners that have been coming
to us uh year after year after year
trying to have uh trying to get our help
to uh to to basically make sure they get
paid this this amendment uh will make
sure that they get paid um and and uh
and it will allow the rest of the court
system or the the the rest of this the
bail commission system to essentially uh
proceed uh the the way that it
is so that that in a nutshell is uh is
is is what this is up
to thank you representative M I believe
representative Alexander is in the
process of I just emailed it it should
be avilable forwarding the committee a
copy of the amendment that you were just
speaking
to I'll just give
everyone minute to just kind of look
look through
it representative Muse I may ask a
question about the
amendment I know one of the concerns
judge came raised was that there was a
perceived conflict between having a
panel where you would have the county
attorney and involv in
the appointing of a bail commissioner
this amendment fix that problem correct
well what this what this amendment does
is it essentially leaves the current
system in place um so uh rather than
having a separate commission Bill
Commissioners would continue to to be
appointed by the court I I think one of
the things that we heard from Judge King
was that you know they haven't had much
of an issue attracting new bail
Commissioners lately it's it's not
necessarily a problem that needs fixing
and we also heard from several of the
bail Commissioners themselves that you
know if there if there are any issues
with a bail commissioner they're they're
pretty much taken care of by the court
and and so the the current way that
things are set up ensures accountability
for the bail Commissioners uh and I
think what we're trying to do in passing
this amendment is just to make sure that
that you know that the bill Commission
actually uh could get paid for the
valuable service that they
render does anyone else wish to speak on
or participate in discussion on the
amend what does the amendment actually
do I haven't seen the
amendment I don't know what it
does
I can add that it it gets rid of all of
the commissions and oversight groups and
everything like that just deletes all
those and all it's left is the first
part first paragraph that and it in that
first paragraph it then says by the way
do your job and Define the uh what inent
means is that
right maybe not exactly the way I would
have said it but but I think that's I
think that's the gist of it
y represent that that's in a nutshell
just like what represent Des providers
and I think that what is important with
that was that the there was a perceived
conflict of interest even though it
wasn't per se conflict having the County
attorneys involved in the appointment
they thought that they should there was
something about that that the church
King just didn't think gave a good
perception of public this solve that
that was kind of a concern that I didn't
think of Judge brought that up it's good
point but it fixes that what does this
due to the
fiscal um issue here the so the one of
the things that was a little bit hard to
determine in the testimony was exactly
what the criteria were to create the
fiscal note um and one of the things if
you if you if you basically look at it
it looks like the assumption is about
50% of the cases will be declared
Indigent there are elements in the bill
I'm sorry in the RSA that this sits on
top of that actually delineate processes
for the court um you know to to to
basically go uh I don't want to say
above and beyond but to ensure that you
know a a a good faith attempt is made at
first you know just simply to collect
the fee uh so job one is if the fee if
the fee is collectible if the the person
is not Indigent let's go ahead and uh
and and collect the fee and and I think
one of the things that is he was talk
judge king was talking to us about what
he would like to see us do is is I think
he was kind of advocating for a system
that just wouldn't that wouldn't uh
simply allow anybody to just sort of
stick their hand up and say I'm Indigent
and be and not be able to pay the fee um
so if you if
you if you take into account that no
people in our state government have more
experience with bail Commissioners and
how the system should work than the
administrative court if anybody should
be able to figure out how to make that
fee or or or how to to minimize the
amount of uh of money that's actually
paid out uh and and how to put some good
qualifications around what constitutes
indigency for the purpose of a bail
commissioner's fee which is different
from from Council um then I think it's
it's something that the administrative
Court should be able to do so I think
you know I I think my my take on the
fiscal note um is um uh it likely
overestimates what um the actual cost
would be to the state uh assuming that
the administrative Court uh puts
together um some workable processes to
ensure collection of the
fee
representative TR thank you Mr chair um
I've heard it said that the
basically the uh the amendment becomes
is the bill
now I have enough
difficulty reading a bill and trying to
comprehend it when it's in front of
me I'm incapable of reading an amendment
that's not in front of me
I just think perhaps we we used 15
minutes and I I I haven't gone anywhere
in that 15 minutes I haven't been able
to read the
bill U representative true
that I
uh we will not we will not vote on a
bill that you didn't have an opportunity
to read the amendment so what I'll do is
I what I'll do for now let me we can
close or not close but we can recess
this executive session I'm going to ask
the committee assistant uh print out the
amendment um we have any other
amendments on any other bills have have
those be print out as well so any
anything that could be exec today please
email that to Karen have a print out 14
copies of the room but also make sure
that that's been emailed to the the
committee members working remotely
justay
and representative M we'll uh we'll open
this back up on the executive session
waiting for that print out and then
we'll we come
back we'll suspend the executive session
on excuse me we'll recess the executive
session on house 498
at this time we're going to open the
executive session in House Bill uh
365 representative tesman you recognized
for a
motion
uh I recommend that we
uh
remove that we
itl HB
365 which gives peace officers status of
federal law enforcement
officers second as there represent
Wallace you recognize the thank you Mr
chairman I second the motion of
uh
represent thank
you represent T do you wish to speak on
your motion just just shortly just a
little bit uh I just have difficulty
with more and more Federal involvement
at the state level and I know that there
are cases drug cases weapons cases and
so on where that appears to be
appropriate uh and you know I I
sympathize with people who think it is
but I really have difficulty with
federal agents coming into the state to
enforce laws of any
kind
representative Hopper yeah U thank you
Mr chairman I I support the itl motion
we're getting it was one of the people
testifying the officer uh referred to it
as the uh federal police force that's
that's a pretty dangerous term and I I I
agree with representative teser and
we're getting way too much
um Federal Inus into our state so I'm
going to support the IDE
motion representative
B thank you Mr chairman I'm going to
oppose the itl motion I think that this
bill makes sense um there are ready
federal law enforcement and involved in
uh task force uh there are occasional as
noted in the initial testimony uh FBI
agent that uh witness a crime this bill
basically allows the uh federal agent if
they have been
certified and trained in New Hampshire
law to arrest and immediately take that
person to State Police
um I don't think it's overstepping uh
the federal overstepping their uh their
job um
and I think that if uh a federal agent
was involved in a task force arrest and
they were not uh uh permitted by law to
uh uh do that arrest they could be
subject to uh liability uh issues so I'm
going to uh protest this motion of
itl thank
you representative Marston thank you Mr
chairman I too will consider the igl
what I see here from Newman was a five
to support 28 to oppose and I've had
nothing but a flurry of people emailing
me to oppose this bill therefore I will
vote
toote to affirm it
repr green thank you Mr chair I also
have had a lot of constit constituents
uh contact me saying it was bad and
during the break I spoke with a lot of
law enforcement officers are against it
because it's uh it's against that
Constitution representative
Newman I'm going to oppose the uh um itl
of this bill and I think that's because
as it originally drafted I had concerns
about any federal law enforcement
officer could just Pony up and and
request for this um the waiver I guess
or or the what the result of the bill
being able to arrest and it turns out
that I think from the
testimony it shows that the uh person
that testified I forget his name but
said that um when they had their task
forces this this was a benefit to them
in the the cases where they were on an
activity and they had a federal law
lauring officer who was part of that but
did not not have the power to arrest and
that this would help that so for that
reason I'm uh going to oppose the itl
motion representative
ohar thank you Mr chair um I'm going not
in favor of pass reasons that I asked
two questions and the only answer I was
receiving is I don't know I hadn't
reached out um I don't see where uh
there there's anybody else other
than witness referred to as the special
AG the FBI nobody from other agencies
such the treasury Secret Service ATF or
da uh have reached
out pushing for this be
done was no overwhelming evidence
representative
Knight thank you uh chairman uh thank
you colleagues I'm gonna support the
itale motion at this time when I asked
uh the chief how many times during his
career or his in his experience
specifically had the lack of this law
impeded his ability to carry carry out
or perform his duty and he said n none
of those times so at this point I think
that we need more documentation we need
more evidence to support why we would
need to address this and I don't feel
that that was adequately represented
thank
you representative
bden thank you Mr CH I was impacted by
the testimony about um the interaction
between um Federal officers and
protesters in Seattle and I'm concerned
about um some of the issues surrounding
the differences in in law at the state
level in New Hampshire versus Federal
level are things that are uh as I
understand it legal at the state level
that are illegal at the federal level
and I think for that reason I'm going to
support
I I will say just one thing that jumped
out to me I have a hard time believing
that any federal agent would watch a a
felony or someone who's injured and just
sit there and do nothing because they're
afraid of civil liability I I think
First Responders in
general uh that's just not how how I've
never heard of a first respond that
would sit there and just watch something
like that go happen they they sit idle
and do
nothing
uh it seems like that that wouldn't be
something that if they did have wouldn't
happen very
frequently so in as representative
Knight said no witness could tell us an
example with that happen other than one
hypothetical
so I'm going to support the
itl seeing No Hands raised uh the clerk
will
uh make the roll call vote and if you
are in support of the motion of
inexpedient to legislate please say yay
if you are opposed to the motion please
say
nay Vice chairman Welch yes
representative Alexander yes
representative hoer yes representative
green yes representative Wallace yes
represent representative testerman yes
representative true yes representative
Pratt yes representative marsten yes the
clerk votes yes representative Harriet
GFF yes Representative
panus
no represent P you just have to turn off
turn on your video
okay my vote is
no thank you representative o'n
yes Representative
bord
no representative muse
no representative
Newman
bden
yes
representative connley yes
representative F Knight
yes representative
lebrand
yes chairman abis chair votes yes Mr
chairman the vote is 17 yay4
nay and who represent Tes you will be
doing the majority report yes will be a
Minority
Report yes it will
be think that's not going on
consent who said they were
doity report repres M were you going to
draft The Minority
Report
represented here said you
would
lean is it
lean chair the representative Ms yes I
had a message earlier from Karen saying
that City member the day was able
to Okay so we've been told is that a
substitute member which applies to two
members of the committee today cannot uh
write the majority or minority
Bo I was under the impression that both
substitutes voted yes no I I heard
represent M said he was represent you
are you going to write The Minority
Report
yes
at this time we can close the public
hearing on how uh excuse me close the
executive session on House Bill
okay at this time we'll open the
executive session of House Bill
375 chair recognizes representative Mars
would you like to make a motion no I
have a
question did we have a did we have a
hearing on
375 we did it was very
three tracking
correct this
morning I take it you don't want to make
you don't want to be recognized to make
a motion this time I don't have any
information to make
it would anybody like to be recognized
to make a
motion
wow representative true thank you Mr
chair to make a motion yes you recognize
to make a motion uh I move uh uh post
Bill 375
OT is there second
second well uh representative panas
you've been recognized to second the
motion about the pass I second it okay
representative true do you wish to speak
to your motion about the task uh uh
thank you Mr chair briefly Mr chair um
I I don't see uh any value in forcing uh
police departments to keep valueless
cont
um if it's if it's not worth anything um
after due time let
allow do anyone else wish to
speak see seeing No Hands
raised I will now put the matter to
question the motion is ought to pass cl
to call the role if you are in support
of the motion of about to pass please
say yay if you are opposed please say
nay chairman well
yes representative Alexander yes
representative Hopper yes representative
green yes representative Wallace
yes representative testerman yes
representative true yes representative
Pratt yes representative
Maron go with the
yes clerk votes yes thanks
representative Harriet GA yes
representative
pacus yes representative o'n
yes representative B yes representative
Muse
yes representative Newman
yes representative Balden yes
representative Conley yes representative
Klein Knight
yes representative Le branch
no chairman
abis the chair votes
yes Mr chairman the vote is 20a one
may I a vote of 20 Y and one a the
motion ought to
pass yes
representative true move to
consent any objection to consent
representative
n no just second
sorry 3375 was put on the consent down
will there be a a majority
report
uh Mr chairman aren't all um bills
supposed to have reports on them ma
majority reports on you are correct and
representative Welsh beat you to the
punch thank
[Music]
you you were a lot nicer about
it
we're waiting on an amendment on
197 and we're waiting on an amendment on
represent
friend
we have 5
the and then we
have
at this time we're going to open the
executive session on House Bill
564 representative Hopper you recognized
to make a
motion uh yes Mr
chairman remind I don't have
it it involves rubber bullets and yeah
yeah sorry yeah I make a motion of
inexpedient legisl
second represent Mar do you wish to be
recognized I
do
second represent harer do you wish to be
uh do you wish to speak on your motion
of any in speeding to legislate yes Mr
chairman thank you um basically all the
testimon that I heard during that um on
that
bill the testimony of evidence for its
necessity seem to be out of state even I
I believe a representative Schmidt who
was testifying for her bill in nashwa
said the the police in Nash are pretty U
measured as to using um
non-lethal um
ammunition in their community and that
they're well trained I think we got the
same testimony for
Manchester so it seems like it is not an
issue in the state of New Hampshire so
uh for that and other reasons I I think
it should be in expedience
legislation representative Maron thank
you Mr chairman does Mr Newman have a
did he have one PR or does he have a
report on people opposing and supporting
understand uh I believe you're referring
to representative Muse and it correct me
if I'm wrong are you asking about the
the numbers on who is in support
of H
hb564 the
public yes the public okay the public
support numbers and the public oppos
numbers that is that what you're asking
yeah representative n do you have that
that information available to you I do
we had 220 people sign in in favor of
this bill and 29 people sign in in
opposition representative Testament I'll
be somewhat redundant to the testimony
we heard but it's just ludicrous to me
that the person who's barricaded in a
house U possibly
firearms and we wouldn't let them try
tear gas to drive them out of that house
yet we'd let them
use uh firearms and you I don't think
the people who are opposed to this uh
are thinking that because the only
option left to police if this goes
through is to use a 9 mimer a 40 cal or
you know 223 that's a whole lot worse
than a rubber bullet or tear
gas representative GA I am against the
itl of the bill and if you recall um
there was an amendment done on this bill
and this um talk to demonstrators that
were um their right to demonstrate and
they were peaceful demonstrators as well
so there was more to them
than that original
Bill don't
know
represent thank youate represent G
reminding the committee of the amendment
um the bill before you clear has
problems I think even the sponsor
acknowled that testimony the amendment
is a good effort to address those
problems and to to recognize what
represented test has said there are
situations when these non-lethal weapons
um are are perfectly appropriate and
lead to better outcomes uh there are
times when um maybe they should not be
used and this bill provides some guard
rails uh around their use that do not
currently exist and it's although you
know things may or may not be problems
quotequote now in our state this would
provide some um some I guess regulation
moving forward which is always helpful
so I appreciate the
motion um there is an amendment that
fail
um even
here in New Hampshire there's been U
several demonstrations and their
demonstrations with children and the
parents and they're peaceful
demonstrations and so we just want to
make sure that if the if they're using
something that is not something that's
directly at a person that's not causing
any
harm and that's a serious
issue so to say you want to kill a bill
that really protects the
public I think we really need to rethink
that call can what is the amendment
number uh mrman if I
could it and your question just just
raise your
hand representative
Marson I do have a statement but I have
a point of order first
I believe the ranking memb spoke once
and then spoke a second time before
everybody
else
so it is at discretion of the chair I it
is I will say the Mason's man does
suggest that if you do call on a member
to speak for a second time during a
discussion you should only do that after
all the members who wish to speak for
the first time if I made that mistake
represent Marson I I
as you know I did not interrupt let me
State what I wanted to State about this
bill I find the bill is all too
overreaching to begin with officers do
not carry or have regularly been issued
either rubber bullets or tear gas in
their arsenal when they go out on the
your
controls those are issued only when when
the Departments and the Chiefs find it
necessary because of facing a large
crowd or a riot and the use of tear gas
is a crowd control measure to help
disperse them would that being all
said I wait to hear about the Amendments
but I still would like to see this
it representative Balden thank you Mr
chairman
um there are many non legal options
available to remain if we eliminated gas
and rubber bullets an example is um the
this is um a machine that makes an
incredibly loud noise uh the man police
actually had it um set up and ready when
there were some protests over the summer
that kind of drag their way down on the
south Bow Street from uh I think stre
where the protest is there was a group
of people there agitating they were
yelling at police they were live
streaming themselves really enjoying um
the Limelight I think for a little bit
and Manchester police have their l r set
up and we're prepared to use it if
necessary and this is something that
would have made an extremely lar sound
that would um be aible from my house
miles away uh and the whole purpose is
to use nonlethal efforts um to disect
out and encourage people to go back to
their homes day instead of
agitating um so there are options that
remain even if we eliminate tear gas and
rubber bullets which are perceived maybe
in error to be nonlethal because they AR
always
nonlethal additionally I think it's
worth noting that there may be many
things that don't happen very often in a
state like New Hampshire that we still
oppose and seek to eliminate from
society um examples could be kidnapping
murder carjacking TR Invasion these are
incredibly rare in our state but we have
laws against them
nonetheless so whether or not there is a
common use of death or rubber bullets in
our state to dat isn't really relevant
to the moral issue of whether police
should be using uh tools like this on
people who might be um encouraged to
with something something
like
um and again I'm interested in opposing
the motion because I'd like to see this
amendment and give some consideration
how the bill can be improved thank
you represent did you find the amendment
I did thank you I'm not going to speak
to the
amendment we have that opportunity but
the amendment was sent to the committee
multiple times by accident on Friday um
is amendment
0229 and if the committee would like I
can send it again your
email also
wa I would just recommend sending it to
pull it up if they wish to
do Casey sent it out on February 5th at
10:14 a.m. and then C sent it out on
February 5th at 1:21
p.m. there was there was two amendments
actually out there that's that's why we
having make sure talking same I think Ma
representative
abson had an amendment out there too so
I'm just making sure we're all talking s
that's
why represented true
thank you Mr chair with all due
respect I am not trying to gum up the
works in any way but we had an itl
motion on the floor and then we start
talking about an amendment that has not
been introduced that's not on the floor
that I have no idea what we're talking
about and if somebody says well I send
it to you
representative I'm swamped in my
computer I get hundreds of emails a
day if amendments are going to be
introduced I would like them physically
to be here so everyone has equal
opportunity to read the
amendment I don't have a I have no
problem with that statement right now
there's no amendment being offered the
amendment can only be offered on a
positive motion I believe the reference
to the amendment by the two members of
the committee they were using they're
referencing as a point of advocacy in
opposition to
the itl which I I I would say that's a
fair point of discussion without arguing
the amendment itself because I think
what the argument is is that the
amendment makes it supports their ARG in
opposition the we have a motion on the
FL we have to act on yes yes we have to
act on the itl motion first which I'm
not going to I wouldn't beem that out of
work I understand the
frustration
just in regards
to excuse me represent Holden I'm gonna
call on uh representative Muse first
I'll recognize you after representative
Muse M you got unmute yourself Sor that
my issue with this particular building
less about the the Banning of rubber
bullets and uh
tear gas itself and it's it's more about
their utilization so so one of the
things that I like about the amendment
that was offered um is that it really
would um draw some pretty tight
guidelines around shooting these things
into crowds and I think that's really
the biggest issue um it's the
indiscriminative firing or use of these
weapons uh in in protests and I do I I
do believe that the uh that the we
didn't get any testimony from the police
standards and training folks but I do
think that there are some some uh
administrative guidelines and uh and
some training that goes around
utilization of these weapons but I think
as we've seen Time After Time across the
country um these weapons uh are if they
if people are outfitted with them uh if
officers are outfitted with them in the
con in conjunction with a protest maybe
just because they're not used that often
uh and because they are build As
non-lethal Weapons it's a little bit
easier to think gee well what's going to
happen if I just fire this thing into a
crowd um the testimony that we got from
The Trial New Hampshire trial ERS
Association had some pretty graphic
pictures of injuries that people have
suffered as a result of these um so you
know to me I think that there are way
there's a way that we can actually
improve um or you know increase the
public safety of people who are
exercising their first amendment rights
while not necessarily removing these uh
from uh you know the the Arsenal police
to useing things like situations where
um you know people are holed up in a in
a in a in a ho in a um in a building or
an apartment they're not going to come
out um they're shooting at officers or
whatever I you know I I don't
necessarily think that we have to to um
you know we have to look at this as as
purely a black and white issue and and
again this is one of the reasons why uh
sometimes I wish we had a little bit
more time with these things because I I
do think that with this particular one
there would be a way to fix it that
would make it amenable to the most of us
I
hope
representative representative
pakis yes Mr chairman could we is there
any way that we could
have uh legislative service email leads
to us so we have
them these
amendments representative panelas U do
you mind repeating your statement I I
apologize
guys is there any way that we could ask
legislative service to send these
amendments directly to our emails so we
would have
them what I what I would say going
forward if anyone in this committee puts
you know has an amendment they should
take it upon themselves to make sure it
gets
forwarded I know I represent probably
might have done that twice anyway but I
would still do that uh just to make sure
it gets done
and if if the other thing I would
recommend is if you want that amendment
to be everyone have a print out you
contact the committee assistant to do
that I that's that part of that falls on
my responsibility
but for the people remotely I you're
going to have to just liveit it by
email representative Nas a followup to
that
uh I what you were saying is if I wanted
to put an amendment out that it would be
my responsibility to tell them to send
it to the other
members I was recommending that the
member just forward it as a matter of
practice just to do it there's no harm
in that uh for us to do that it's not
it's not a a rule that you one must
follow but it certainly seemed like a
good practice to me and thank
you
representative yes sure um as you know
and I think my ranking member knows that
uh I've stayed long with like but I have
head to work so like would have liked to
continue on with this uh conversation
but I have to
leave we are not in the voting mode so
there there's no obligation
that
restriction have a
motion we're not in the
voting marking about amendments we got a
motion of an it we should fall motion
fails and we deal with the
amendment I haven't seen any amendments
yet since I've been on this
commit somebody bring it
down I'm going to recognize repres
[Music]
we're not GNA vote on Amendment
the
you you recognize thank you Mr chairman
I'm going to ask us to uh vote down the
it motion so we can hear and the uh the
amendment that's been brought forward
uh I cannot support the bill as written
today but I think that the amendment
does make it a uh a bill that I can
support um so I'm going to ask us to uh
vote down itl motion if we adopt the
amendment uh we'll try another motion
but if we don't adopt the motion then uh
I will move
itl
you recognize from point of
order if we vote down the
itl before you can take the amendment up
you must vote the bill
up it means my understanding is there
needs to be a positive motion on the
floor in order to offer the amendment so
we're we're pretty far from that at this
point in time but
correct representative
Newman
thank you thank you Mr
chairman um I know we're in kind of an
unusual situation about these amendments
and it's difficult I realize there is a
motion on the floor to itl I also
realize that the majority uh can
probably pass that with the uh today
right now and I I just think that uh
based on a conversation that I had with
a member who is an expert on this kind
of stuff this
weekend um we if this motion is passed
itl it will go
forward um if it and then it would not
be able to be considered for two years
if this is an amendment that uh the
majority of the committee thinks could
be improved to the point where it might
protect the citizens uh with the
safeguards involved whatever may be in
that Amendment then this this rule May
if it is voted down could have a
positive vote I believe it's a positive
um um uh motion to retain if in fact the
committee felt that they could do some
work on it this year rather than um uh
making sure that we could not vote on
this or another thing like this for two
years so I I hope that's a correct
understanding and that's all I have to
offer as far as this
goes what I'll say just before we we
move this this motion uh put this motion
forward for a vote I understand what the
the intent of the amendment is but that
conduct addressed in the amendment in my
opinion is already would be considered
excessive force if you look the RSA
6275 discusses the use of non-deadly
force and if there's a peaceful protest
or a peaceful group of people crowded
together and the police officer decides
to fire a a rubber bullets into that
crowd of people without any Rhyme or
Reason on who they're aiming at I would
find that to be excessive force some of
the current law and I'm I don't
know um I'm not sure the amendment is
creating any new law because that would
already be excessive for us that is the
reason why I'm going to support in
support of the motion of it I I would
think if a police officer did do that
that that would be very inappropriate
behavior I believe that they would
probably be liable under the federal
civil rights statute you can even make a
strong argument that they could be
criminally prosecuted that is that is
very inappropriate use of force for any
police officer to do that and I I would
presume that that uh I would hope the
Attorney General at least investigate
that in consider of pross it it ever
happen because it's clearly what I would
look at is not acceptable use of force
under the current the amendment
articulates it again but I think it's
already an appropriate use
we're not we're going to have we're
we're running up against the clock so I
recognize the last two members I
representative B made the uh represent
ho you made the motion but I'll I'll
recognize repr first let you close it
out I just wanted to mention I don't
know if it was obvious to everyone in
the committee that umly emailed out the
amendment again within the last minutes
and I assume everyone else in the room
getting there a lot of emails right now
about other bills hundred of emails but
if your the time stamp in my inbox is
1:18 p.m email from represent with
the thank
you representative popper thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Conley for the amendment I did read it
and it still Falls really short it's
still basically those people haven't
read it unless a
misunderstanding says that an officer
cannot use rubber bullets and um tear
gas unless he feels he is in direct uh
chance of being uh physically armed
which would mean he couldn't use it to
protect members of the public so I
really think this is a training issue
this isn't I don't think we should uh
pass it bill today one way or the other
because I think it's a function of
making sure officers who dispense that
type of ammunition are well trained and
so far all the evidence we' had in
committee is the people officers in the
our I'll stick with my IDE the last
representative has not spoken yet so I'm
recognize represent wel unless the
member has already spoke no additional
discussion lot important person
professionals and when they they don't
carry Rubble bullets and tear gas with
them on their
cruises the only time that these things
are ever even considered is in certain
instances usually have a squat team show
up or something of
that and if we don't trust our police
officers to make the right decisions why
should we make decisions farther we not
we're not trained on that
area I'm
supporting this time the matter matter
we put the question first call the role
if you are in support of the motion of
inexpedient to legislate please say yay
if you were opposed please say
next Vice chairman Welch
yay representative Alexander yes
representative Hopper yes representative
green yes representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yay
representative true yes representative
Pratt yes representative Marston
yes the clerk vot yes representative
Harriet G no representative
Kus represent are you are
you unmute yourself
yes representative over
hear
um representative
b i
no representative muse
no representative
Newman
no representative Balden no
representative Conley no representative
pin Knight
no representative Le
branch
no chairman abis the chair votes
yes Mr chairman the vote is 12 yay 8
may vote of 12 Y and eight days the most
inexpedient legislate
pass representative will you be
preparing a majority
report is there a representative that
wishes to prepare The Minority
Report representative
Conley Mr chairman I will a Minority
Report will be completed I will be happy
to take that on if No Other
M that
be um
yes that would not
be at this point will uh the chair will
close the executive session on House
Bill
564 this time uh chair would now open
the public hearing for House Bill
4 we call Representative Roy Terry Roy
introdu
[Music]
B right that chair and you can face the
screen welcome back
welcome those you don't know
representative Roy was a member of this
committee last
year thank you uh Mr chairman uh Mr
chairman uh members of the committee
thank you for he my testimony my name is
representative Roy I am representative
from Rockingham 32 representing the
towns of candy at Deerfield Nottingham
in Northwood I'm here to introduce HB
471 to you
today this bill would
make disciplinary hearings for police
officers for their certification at the
state level open to the
public as some of you may recall I was
here last week and I advocated that we
not get involved in making decisions for
the police as far as their ability to
make calls regarding the use of
force and as such that grants them great
Authority police officers in our society
enjoy an extreme amount of power and
authority that we invest in
them and I believe that with great power
comes great
responsibility as we've seen across the
country country there's a great call for
transparency and
policing and I believe that this bill
would be a good start towards that in
New
Hampshire now this does not mean that
their employment hearings are public
their hearings between themselves and
their employers would still be a matter
of personnel matter but this is their
certification to be able to police
officer anywhere in the state of New
Hampshire it's my belief that if you are
in front of that board
there's a question whether or not you
are qualified to remain a police officer
and I believe that due to the power
police officers hold in our
society transparency is important and
the public has a right to know what the
allegations against them are and whether
or not they are clear to those
allegations or they are
founded keeping these matters
transparent only creates and
fosters an atmosphere of distrust
against the people that we rely on most
and have trust in the word of a police
officer has relied upon to get search
warrants to make arrests and indeed as
we've heard to use Force sometimes
lethally and if we cannot have
transparency in those folks especially
in their ability to be a police officer
at the state
level it just creates more and more
distrust among the
citizenry so that is a HB 471 I'd be
happy to entertain any
questions I'm freaking
out representative
Knight chair and thank you
representative Roy for taking my
question um in the interest of uh
protecting police officers as well
um could you give me an example of how
or when one would go about um saying
that they can seek confidentiality for
com what their compelling interests
might be just as for me as an
example sure I believe that would be
left up to the hearing officer and there
are there are certain instances in Juris
Prudence such as the names of children
if it involves
um a matter that would be um that would
be considered more a Personnel matter
than a matter of public interest or
safety there's very few limited
circumstances in jurist Prudence where
the public would not have access to it
in legislative intent it would be a
clear indication that the legislature
intends for it to be public so it would
be very limited
application I don't think it would be
possible for us to delineate all the
possible scenarios where privacy May
Trump public interest but there is as I
said um jurist Prudence on the matter
already representative Balman and
representative if you don't mind raising
your voice if
you
okay my question I just you could um
tell us about your words or employment
um I I was a a municipal police officer
I was also an investigator for the state
um Board of Medicine and I was an
investigator for the Department of
Education in Massachusetts as
well
representative yes would like to ask a
question I thank you for your testimony
and taking my question it I understand
that and I I agree with the provision
about having issue of comp confidential
information do you have any opinion on
if if there was an amendment to add
privilege information to that as well
I'm what I'm concerned within this me
just me being nitpicking but if someone
did have a f privilege
or if they chose not to wave it maybe
that that would also not be something
that
public I'm trying to um think about
currently with regard to employment
matters and Licensing matter if you have
a fifth amendment
privilege um I believe invoking that can
be can be used against you in a civil
matter that so that they can read into
that if they choose not to testify
because of an ongoing criminal
investigation they are allowed to draw a
negative inference from that but if you
felt like they needed an amendment I
would certainly support
it and I'll just follow question I I
agree that it it does create negative
inference because it's civil hearing I
guess if someone were to challenge that
the cl uh the person assarting the
privilege it would have to be
I I I suppose presented before the
hearing so that that's where I'm
wondering with that might not be
something that that's something I feel
should also be maybe done in closed
doors at discretion of
the that just I feel I feel what I'm
bringing up is the very not to come up
NE off this confidential information but
maybe again I be opposed to an amendment
like that or any Amendment so long as it
didn't change the spirit of the bill
making these hearings
public representative
pelas thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Roy for taking my
question I was wondering if you can give
me an
example of a
disciplinary hearing that this would
relate to
thank you um representative uh for
example if a police officer were charged
with something of misconduct by his
department and the department referred
it to the um to the state for
decertification that hearing at the
state level because a police officer in
New Hampshire requires a certification
to be a police officer anywhere in the
state so you could be disciplined by
your department and not be disciplined
by the state but if you referred to the
state so that you couldn't be police
officer anywhere that hearing would then
be open to the public based on this bill
whereas right now it's
not okay thank
you representative Knight excuse me
representative G
um Can Can you sort of describe what
happens now when they go into
hearings to the best of my knowledge
currently there's a hearing but it's not
open to the public and the findings of
the hearing are also not open to the
public as far as I know and I believe
that this relates somewhat to the Lor
list issue and I think someone will be
testifying after me that we'll be able
to explain it a little bit more in
depth follow follow question um do you
know of any incidents recently
where there were serious issues where
someone probably was reprimanded but was
never and followed up with other stuff
more rep
reprimand um no I don't and that's
exactly my point that we don't
know thank
you
representative
green thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question would this involve
more time in uh setting up uh Committee
involved in here in actions like this in
other words uh right now they probably
where it's
closed they can say well we going to
have it in three days but we're talking
to the public is this going to extend
longer I I can't imagine it will
generally speaking I would think that
there's a significant amount of time
between the referral time and the actual
hearing um it might take longer right
now because they probably would have to
install some type of ability for the
public to see it while we're in this
lockdown but generally speaking I I I
can't see why it would create any
greater burden especially on time
to make it open to the public thank
you representative Marson thank you Mr
speaker thank you for taking my question
do you know of any
instance in general public
corporations
businesses where when they discipline
one of their personnel they make it open
to the
public uh Yes actually there uh several
other um other uh licensing boards the
for example the
um the board of bar overseers um when a
license for a lawyer is revoked that
information is public um I believe
there's several other professions as
well that are licensed by the state um
that are public public information and
again it's just the license not their
it's not their employment hearing
between them and their employer it's the
state license
issue
repres we're not talking about licensing
here we're talking about
discipline um
technically no discipline would be by
your by your employer where you could be
terminated suspended
the state revoked your license we call
it a certification so and really they
have no power over your employment other
than to take away your ability to be a
police officer so it
is represent Marson
one this is not where they're trying to
isn't there a provision in the law from
and what have that they're actually not
just disciplining them they're taking
them up to the intent
with the intent to get rid of them and
that open is it not currently
no currently it's
not representative
Muse I was wondering if you could give
me an example of the sort of
confidential information that would
create a compelling interest that
actually outweighs the Public's right to
know and how frequently do you
anticipate things like that might come
up in the course of the hearings you've
been involved
with
um an example of would be strictly
hypothetical but like I said things that
might involve the names of children or
situations that were where the if a
police officer was accused of of some
type of misconduct against someone were
given that the hearing was make it
easily identifiable to know who that
person was um but generally those type
of things are left up FactFinder or the
judge has to decide whether or not and
there is jurist Prudence on the matter
that where they use to guide their
decisions as far as about whether or not
something is open to the public or
not thank
you
representative M do you have a followup
question I do
not she yellow
hand representative Roy I want to thank
you for your testimony seeing no fur the
hands you are excused uh thank you very
much thank you to the
committee just for the remainder of the
day we're going to have to we're going
limit with the exception of the bill
sponsors we're going to limit testimony
members of the public to 2
minutes is there a anyone who's present
in the attendees who intends on
testifying uh in regard in in response
to regards to House Bill 471 please uh
raise your hands now so we can at
least thank
you and we're going to start with
Gregory
Sullivan you may
begin
I will start over can you all hear me
now I hope yes we can hear you thank you
my name is Gregory Sullivan good
afternoon uh Mr chairman and members of
the committee I strongly urge this
committee to vote not to pass this bill
471 i' like to start off quickly with
two quotes the first would be from a
preamble of chapter 91a our right of no
law openness and the conduct of public
business is essential to Democratic
Society purpose of 91a is to ensure the
greatest possible public access to the
action discussions and records of all
public bodies and their accountability
to the people now with respect to the
New Hampshire City standards and
training council is the only licensing
body that conducts the business
currently historically in private and
those days should be gone even without
this bill I urge the passage of this
bill but without it I say that part one
article 8 of The Constitution of New
Hampshire and chapter
91a requires openness quote judge
Schulman from the superior court and the
case of Union Leader versus town of
Salem which was decided by the Supreme
Court last May in favor of openness with
respect conduct J shman said bad things
happen in the dark and the ultimate
Watchdogs of accountability that is the
voters and taxpayers are viewed as alien
rather than integral to the
process this bill 471 does not create a
blanket rule there are many times where
things in a desertification hearing
could be held in private portions of the
hearing redating record a confidential
informant the name of a confidential
informant the victim of a sexual assault
and and one representative said it very
well we do these uh decisions in in
courts and in public bodies every day
judges lawyers doctors nurses all
certification licensing hearings are in
public and the word discipline in this
in this chapter is a misn excuse me Mr
Sullivan we have through the time
constraints we have to limit testimony
to uh to members of the public to two
minutes uh per person do you mind just
concluding your testimony with a a
single sentence
Mr chair he's muted but I did
not I I did
okay Mr Sullivan you you you're on mute
right now so please unmute yourself I'm
sorry my final sentence would be that um
parts of these hearings can be
confidential um the Constitution and 91a
demand that these hearings be held in
public I will point out there is
litigation pending Union Leader versus
New Hampshire police standards and
training Council paralleling this bill
asking for the same thing I thank you
for your attention and
consideration glad to answer any
questions thank you for your testimony
seeing No Hands raised the witness is
excused thank you very
much hi can you hear me welcome back we
can hear you uh thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee for taking my
testimony again today my name is Sophia
Bano I'm 14 I live in Manchester and I'm
speaking today on behalf of the New
Hampshire High School Democrats in
support of HB
471 I support HB 471 because it is a
simple solution that will increase
police accountability and public trust
in New Hampshire greatly public
disciplinary hearings are not something
limited to New Hampshire across the
country there have been calls for this
type of legislation organizations like
the NAACP and the ACLU have come out in
support of publicizing disciplinary
hearings New Hampshire could be one of
the first states to make this change and
show its commitment to transparency and
public accountability this legisl is not
complicated it is common sense that when
people are given the opportunity to act
without consequence they will take the
easy route and behave improperly we have
seen the danger effects of a lack of
accountability in the events of recent
years and how these systems have
impacted New Hampshire specifically
keeping these hearings behind closed
doors is enabling law enforcement's
misconduct and telling the people of New
Hampshire that our police cannot be
trusted transparency has always been a
priority in New Hampshire and it's time
that we follow through on that
commitment were these hearings public it
would not only allow New Hampshire
citizens to hold police accountable for
their actions but it would increase
trust within the community and promote a
healthier relationship between police
and those in their jurisdictions I urge
the committee to vote Yes and support
h471 thank you for your testimony
representative Marston thank you Mr
chairman thank you for your testimony
and taking my
question you uh I believe have testified
in the past year that you're a high
school
student um yes that correct would that
being in mind if you were being
disciplined in school would you want the
whole school to know what you're being
disciplined
for just please suspend for a moment
representative Marson it's it's I'm
gonna ask the witness at least give her
the option she's not the answer the
difference between a minor involving
school records which are confidential uh
in par because the person's a minor it's
I don't think it's a fair comparison to
a police officer when it's involving a
displine here even if the school records
are disciplined I don't think that's a
fair
question I would just although the
witness is very competent and uh
testified well and several times today I
would just be uh conscious that we are
it is she is a minor as well
so representative Marson I will draw my
question thank you
seeing no hand uh no hands raised the
witnesses excuse and thank you again for
your
testimony sorry I should I should don't
don't remove yet unmute
her thank
you
Melissa
Davis yes thank you good afternoon my
name is Melissa Davis and I'm here to
testify on behalf of the board of
directors for the New Hampshire
Association of criminal defense lawyers
in support of HP 471 I have practiced
criminal law in New Hampshire for over
15 years first as a public defender and
now is director of the criminal Practice
Clinic uh at UNH Franklin Pier School of
Law I make this statement in my
individual capacity and as board member
for nhac CDL the opinions I'm expressing
are solely M and are not those of either
UNH Franklin Pier School of Law or the
University of New Hampshire as a
practicing criminal defense lawyer I'm
support in support of this bill because
it is one way that uh my clients can be
guaranteed ACC access to possibly
exculpatory evidence that they are
entitled to through the New Hampshire
and United States Constitution but I've
also had the opportunity to see up
closed how the closed door process for
hearings on police misconduct breeds
suspicion skepticism and distrust within
our
communities unsurprisingly those who
have the courage to bring a complaint
about police misconduct to light are
some of the same people who find
themselves charged with a crime it's
hard for so many of my clients to
believe that the criminal justice system
will treat them fairly when it seems
that those charged with enforcing our
laws are rarely held accountable that
perception may or may not be accurate
but without an open and public
disciplinary process the community is
left to assume that there were no
consequences particularly when the same
officers are back out on patrol as if no
complaint was ever made it is difficult
for me to make claim that the justice
system is fair when it seems like there
are two sets of rules one for my clients
and one for police and for clients of
color there are a whole extra set of
rules dist trust for police by by those
being policed affects the entire
Community for clients inexperienced with
the criminal justice system getting
their first glimpse of the process they
see the power of the State against them
when the perception is that police
aren't held accountable it's hard to
believe they will be treated fairly I've
represented people who should have
fought their charges but ultimately
chose not to do so because they didn't
believe they could miss Miss Davis uh we
due to time constraints we do have to
limit testimony uh to two to two minutes
per person do you mind including your
your
testimony you want need to unmute
your yes um I'll just say that in
addition to my interactions with clients
I do interact with members of the public
as jurors as is reflected in my written
statement um and those interactions show
me that um our jurors who come into
court um to serve as community members
are also affected by uh the distrust of
the police Department um in their
decisions about police credibility uh
and I'll leave it with that and refer
you to my written testimony thank
you thank you for your testimony seeing
seeing No Hands raised uh the witness is
excused
Joseph Las SK
yeah thank you thank you Mr chair and
committee for taking my testimony today
I would also like to thank
representative Roy for sponsoring this
legislation which would increase New
Hampshire transparency involving police
misconduct my name is name is Joseph Las
scaz and I am a smart Justice organizer
and I will be testifying on behalf of
the American civil liberties Union of
New Hampshire in full support of HB
471 I will also be representing the
prospective of a criminal justice and
law enforcement reform Advocate a
concerned Community member a New
Hampshire native born and raised my
whole life this past summer I um excuse
me I served on Governor sununu's leak
commission which is which was
established to bring uh much needed
accountability and transparency to law
enforcement in our state the
recommendations we made were to increase
transparency and accountability and it's
in that Spirit of advancing these
principles that I strongly urge this
committee to pass this
legislation this legislation establishes
the same standard for law enforcement
that's been set for licensed employees
lawyers and judges and uh former
Attorney General Gordon McDonald
expressed his support for this type of
legislation when he specifically drew
the comparison between certification
hearings for police vers similar
licensing hearings that exist for other
professionals I'm asking this committee
to support HB 471 because it advances
accountability and transparency
involving situations where law
enforcement members consciously choose
to misrepresent their badge and abuse
their positions of power as we saw
former Salem Police Sergeant Michael
verac's case I am also asking for the
support of this legislation because it
sends New Hampshire residents in all
districts a clear message that this
committee believes in accountability and
transparency um when it involves
situations of of New Hampshire law
enforcement members engaging in blatant
and public uh racist speech such as we
saw in former Manchester police officer
Aaron Brown's case now I'm not going to
go into details about the case as I
recognize conversations around race can
be uncomfortable for people who are not
ready for it however I haven't met
anyone who has said that referring to
Hampshire black and brown community
members as the n-word or bragging about
purchas purchasing a gun to take the mou
was acceptable behavior period that's
the type of behavior that gets put in
front of a decertification here
so I would like to just highlight that
this legislation does not disregard or
infringe upon the due process rights for
law enforcement and still provides
Provisions for sensitive information to
be private it's for these reasons and
more that I ask that this committee
passes this legislation and I'm happy to
answer any questions you may
have thank you very much for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised uh the
witness is
excused
you see how many
hands
we have one
one Charles
Reynolds hello can you hear me yes we
can
oh okay uh good afternoon chairman abis
and member members of the committee I'm
Charles Reynolds and I'm here to speak
on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police
regarding House Bill
471 please note that I signed in as a
neutral giving that that that was the
best option available however I asked
the committee to recognize the New
Hampshire Chiefs are supportive of the
intent of this bill but but with a
concern that I that I will
explain in the way of introduction I'm a
lifelong resident of New Hampshire and
have been actively involved in law
enforcement since
1962 I've served as police chief in
Guilford lebedin and retired after 19
years as police chief in Dover after a
brief political career that included
Service as a state representative and
member of the regulated Revenue
committee I continued to develop a
police Consulting practice that has
involved working for the past several
years with a civil rights division of
the United States Department of Justice
on police
matters the present language of this
bill um talks about the ability for an
involved party presumably a police
officer to seek closure of a portion of
the hearing that would disclose
confidential perhaps salacious
information related or perhaps not
related to the
allegations that we also support however
the bill
suggests that the party must prove Pro
with specificity that the portion of the
hearing will reveal confidential
information that creates a compelling
interest outweighing The public's
presumed right of access Mr chairman and
members of the committee the suggestion
that the
person perhaps an open session prove the
confidentiality uh uh is important
negates the whole purpose of the
confidential hearing we suggest uh
legislation be made
clear that the council the council
itself shall have the authority to
privately and a non-public session here
and consider the request for closure and
rule on such requests in closing I very
much appreciate the time and attention
and emphasize the Chiefs are supportive
of public hearings but do suggest there
are times when perent evidence may be
unduly and
unnecessarily invasive of an officer
privacy or in the case of potential
criminal proceedings may be unduly pre
prejudicial I assure you that we are
happy to work with you in any way
possible to clarify these few concerns
and I'll be happy to answer any
questions you may have
today thank thank you for your question
and the chair if would like to ask a
question and I want to thank you in
advance for taking my question
so if I understood your testimony
correctly if the concern is one of the
concerns is that if an officer word
raised the issue of
confidentiality that the discussion and
I guess presentation of that argument
before the the board would have to be
done you would want that to be private
as well because by asserting it you are
essentially breaching compen is that yes
yes Mr chairman that that's correct uh
uh
although it's not clear it suggests that
the person presumably in officer would
have to prove uh that this should be a
confidential matter and we'd like it to
be clear in the legislation while we we
believe the hearing should be public uh
the legislation should be clear that the
council uh in non-public session would
be able to hear the reasons for uh
making that uh public making that
non-public and rule on it uh and then if
it was uh the ruling was that it would
be public well that would be the ruling
but if it was uh found to be uh uh an
issue that should not be made public
then that would be the ruling as well so
uh the standards and training Council as
you know includes uh the attorney
general and at least two judges so it's
not a body that would uh you know not uh
would take this uh uh obligation
lightly seeing No Hands raised I want
to thank you again for your
testimony seeing seeing no M of the
public with their hands
raised at this point
will the public hearing on House Bill
471 will be in
recess Mr chairman we had 64 people who
testified uh or I'm sorry who indicated
support for the bill uh we had two
people who were
opposed uh just point of order you said
in recess you in recess were
closing I'm leaving it open just in case
I forget someone if you recall last
hearing I other day I actually closed
the hearing and there was a
representative Joe Alexander who was
trying to testify
that I couldn't let testify so I it
happen saying recess for now appreciate
that
Mr yes we we have have some
down
everyone have the in the room have the
print out of the amendment for House
Bill
now no I'm just asking makeing sure I
don't want
to representative M did an excellent job
explaining the
amendment he was the only one
ready I don't want
to do second
time
here
this at this time the chair is
gonna open the execu or reopen the
executive session on House Bill
we when we left off representative Muse
you you had you were discussing an
amendment there was members of the
committee who didn't have an opportunity
to review that
Amendment they're either in the process
of reviewing it now or all have already
done
that uh I will allow you to uh I
recognize you to make a motion to offer
the amendment if you want to speak on
the amendment again I know it was a few
hours ago I will allow you
to repeat any what You' said before if
you'd like
to thank you Mr chairman uh let me just
make
double thank
yous
that uh uh for uh for HB 498 I'm putting
forward Amendment 2021 d02
55h uh essentially this amendment uh
now comprises the entire the entire bill
um what we've essentially done is we've
responded to some of uh judge King's
concerns by eliminating the uh the 10
County commissions to appoint bail
Commissioners uh and also essentially
leaving the administrative the
administration of bail Commissioners uh
pretty much as is what we've also done
uh and and what the bill is really all
about now uh is making making sure that
bail Commissioners finally do get paid
uh we've been having this conversation
on and off for the last three years uh
there's been a study commission that was
put together that representative
Alexander and I both served on um and
one of the things that we that really
came across to us is the hardship uh
that this causes to people who really
are just trying to help our our police
uh and who are just trying to do the
right thing as Citizens um so
essentially what the bill what the bill
does is it requires that the bail
commissioner's fee uh be paid uh by the
court if the if uh uh if in incy is
determined um and one of the things that
judge king told us in his testimony was
uh he suggested that we actually Define
indigency the uh
uh sometimes these things are can be a
little bit hard to remember and recall
but one of the things that was part of
last year's Criminal Justice uh uh
Senate Omnibus Bill that actually passed
and was signed by the governor um was a
provision that essentially ask the
administrative Court uh to do that and
to define those circumstances so what
this what this amendment does is it
leaves the requirement that these folks
you know be paid if incy is determined
it leaves that requirement intact but it
also uh just includes uh A little nudge
and reminder uh for the court that this
is something that we
had asked them to do uh last summer when
we passed the previous bill um and part
of that the idea isn't just to keep
kicking it back and forth between the
the circuit court and the legislature
but um one of the things I think that's
really come across to me having spent a
lot of time over this the last few years
is the real expertise lies in the
circuit administrative Court uh with
this and they are in the best position
to determine uh to to determine uh how
that process should work uh and uh and
to to create a process um that ensures
that uh that people who can pay do pay
and the people who really can't afford
to pay aren't aren't aren't required to
um so that in a nutshell is what we're
what we're trying to do here and and
hopefully we can agree on this and put
one long-standing problem
uh that's important to a lot of people
um behind us
thanks
represent that was
cool
okay that was
actually thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question Mr M
representative m u I just got two two
quick
questions are you so you want to you
wish to be recognized to ask represent
music question
yes uh the questions are
uh when a bail
commissioner sets a go goes and does
whatever he's supposed to do uh it's
three o'clock in the
morning how does he can't decide what is
energent uh and
he how does the the administrative judge
or somebody saying this you know you're
Indigent uh make that decision uh and
decide whether or not to let this guy go
on his personal recognizance or not uh
and then I got one more question
afterwards the bail commissioner uh
payment of the fee uh isn't isn't my
understanding is that payment of the fee
is not required for somebody to actually
be if you don't have if you don't have
the money
um you and and there is no reason to
hold you then
uh what what can happen is that somebody
can walk out without without necessarily
paying the fe uh and that creates an
issue mail Commissioners with collecting
the the best the best case scenario is
that the people have the money on them
or they have their checkbook or
something like that and they're actually
able to pay the bail commissioner at the
time of
bail
okay follow up just just before you ask
the follow I I don't repres I believe we
have to make make the motion again and
then I don't believe it was seconded
this time around so I think we have to
second so I'm raising a point of order
on
myself that motion has been
seconded by representative Hopper
represent tesman you may ask question my
my last question and the really
important one is we there's no question
or no answer as to how this gets funded
I mean you the the last Bill had a a
large Financial uh Clause to it of 800
and some thousand uh is that still on it
is it how do we fund
that the uh that that's a that's a
actually good question it's not not part
of the the nature of this particular
Bill itself so I didn't dig into that
I'm wondering if that's part of
um
question I think the I think the part of
the issue is is that the funding uh the
the funding for that one of the things
one of the reasons to have the the
circuit court involved in the the design
of the process for determining IND
indigency is they can design it in a way
that's fair and also doesn't result in
the the large amount of money that we
saw in the fiscal note actually being
spent if you if you you know one way to
look at that that fiscal node and the
way it came across to me is if we
literally have no process at all other
than somebody being able to say I'm
Indigent and they they can walk out then
we wind up with uh with an expense of
that order but my understanding is is if
we you know if if good guidelines are
put around this um then the actual
amount of money is not going to be
anywhere near
that
okay represent news if I can just
inquire that so the fiscal note was give
or take on the original Bill around
$800,000 but is that is that figure
Quantified based
on no one paying the $40 fee or is that
take into consideration I heard
testimony about 40 to 50% of the times
the the $4 fees paid right
away I think I think it was basically
Quantified around the fact that um
that's sort of what's happening now so
it's about 40 or 50% of the of the
people who are involved just basically
saying I don't have the money um and
part of it is the consequence of not
really having guidelines around you know
uh what determines Indy for the purposes
of the B fee which is different you know
and judge king reminded us of this too
it's different from being Indigent in
terms of having representation or
councel which tends to be much more
expensive the the baill commissioner's
fee is
$40 so one of the things one of the one
of the the challenges as you may not
necessarily want want to apply exactly
the same standards you apply for in
agency of council which would be much
more expensive for something that only
costs
$40 representative Maron I have a
question for the
chair yes okay I'm befuddled a little
bit but that's not uncommon for
me what I'm interested in being clear on
is we did pass this with a 20 to nothing
vote and we're now just debating the
amendment no that's incorrect what
happened was when we opened the
executive session I believe on Friday
February
5th when we open the executive session
representative Bert was recognized for a
motion of ought to pass and that motion
was seconded after it was open for
discussion representative bur decided
wish to withdraw his motion
and it was withdrawn but as a precaution
in housekeeping matter we decided to do
that by a roll call vote the re the
reason why we did a roll call vote is
because on a normal circumstance we
could just did a Voice vote but every
vote has to be done by roll call since
we're
participating hybrid right now so that's
what that was the 20 nothing vote was I
believe to
withdraw most of our
pass so we're back to square one
well we've made some progress I I would
say that there's been now an amendment
because but by withdrawing that motion I
believe was what inspired this amendment
to fix the concerns that a lot of commit
had also address some of the testimony
provided by judge king so I think the
amendment
does there's been
progress
say yes so to make it clear for me and
maybe some other members I'm not 100%
sure but sometimes I'm in that same boat
with there with me we got to First do
something with the bill and if we do an
AR to pass we could do it with an AR to
pass and with an
amendment is that
correct yes an amendment can only be
offered with with a positive motion so
it the motion it's not the Tas but then
you offering an amendment correct have
we done that at this point V on we're
not we're not voting on the AR to pass
it's it has to be but there has to be a
positive motion pres
presented that's ought to pass amendment
I understand that are we looking at that
if this point in time what we need to do
now is is actually adopt the we need to
adopt the amendment we got pass the
amendment then we do not pass with
them point a question
I was under the impression and and and I
defer to some senior people
here you have to pass the bill first and
then put an amendment to it no the
motion will be on to pass for Amendment
thank you we we have to adopt the
amendment if if the amendment fails then
we'll vote to pass on the original bill
as drafted thank you for clarity
so or
representative
Bard thank you Mr chairman a couple of
points a has I have served as
a and the first thing you do in a bill
that looking at is uh to adopt an
amendment does not have to be positive
motion to adopt Amendment so if the
amendment is adopted and there
is is that a point of order that you're
making I making a couple of comments my
well my understanding is that in order
for an amendment to be presented there
needs to be a positive motion present my
that is my source for that is the CL so
if you look if you look at the CL work
sheet that tells you the recording of
the moot motion the motion to adopt
amendment is the first border of
business yes I correct and what I'm what
I am saying is you representative Bo let
me just explain
this okay have to adopt the motion first
but it has to be you can't have an A A
an amendment on an itl motion so what
I'm saying is that there's a positive
motion right now and then you're
offering the Amendments so we're now
going to vote on the amendment all right
oh let's understand so the other thing
is as far as uh the money uh this bill
has a fin Financial note on it so it
will be going to finance and finance
will uh decide on
money uh so we don't have to worry about
that right now thank
you
representative Bourne uh so just so the
members understand we're supposed to he
said represent B corrected his analysis
that there where cage to not always
factor in the fiscal side of things
however I am uh my own opinion my as a
representative I don't ignore the fiscal
notes if if the fiscal is not not proper
I don't feel that I'm obligated to
ignore it but in this case I will say
the fiscal not aside
we have bail Commissioners not getting
paid and they doing a public service I I
can't wrap my head around how this has
been going on that long and I I know
there's been a lot of work put into this
trying to come to some resolution there
was a commission I know two members
sitting on the committee today were
involved in that and bipar and effort
so and I just know if I was doing a job
and not getting paid I I probably
wouldn't continue to do it so the I
really respect the bail commissioners in
their Public Service they're providing
and
this sols that I mean I couldn't imagine
getting out of bed at four o'clock in
the morning or 3 o'clock in the morning
driving a half hour to to do a do my
public service and then not get paid for
$40 then to drive
back so we're gonna we're g to move the
question
um represent H you making a point of
order yeah point of order uh Mr chairman
um just because because it has a
physical note it depends on the finance
committee how swamp they are they can
choose not to even hear this so it
doesn't necessarily go to the finance
committee it should but it may
not
that's that is a correct statement uh
they they the second committee can
always wave the second committee they
can wave it off so that's happened
before it can happen in
finance I just I just want to say when
we were um looking at this I what I
remember distinctly is of Representative
wel saying that um look at line 10 and
just drop everything after
that Bas and that's what they did yeah
I'm waiting to support
repres all right representative Muse
would you like to make a motion of to
pass and offer the amendment officially
so it can be we can then call the role
and I'm I believe represent Hopper is
interested in seconding that okay like
to make an motion to uh to pass uh the
amendment to HB
498 represent H you like the second
thank you yes
sir the clerk willall the
role if if the question is if o if to
adopt the
amendment number 202- 0255 H if you are
in favor of adopting the amendment
please say yay if you are opposed please
say
nay we're in the voting
mode Vice chairman Welch
yes representative Alexander yes
representative popper yes representative
green yes representative Wallace yes
representative
yes representative true
no representative Pratt
yes representative
morston yes the clerk votes yes
representative Harriet G yes
representative
pakus
give represent
pagus
oh sleep
yeses you do need to turn your video
on oh I'm
sorry no
problem I had to teach you old dog new
tricks yes it is did it come on
yeah representative Bo n
yes representative Hughes
yes representative Newman yes
representative balen yes representative
Conley yes representative kle Knight yes
representative Le Branch
yes chairman abis the chair votes yes Mr
chairman the vote vote is not 19 y one
Nay by a vote
of 19 Y and one nay the amendment is
adopted representative M would you like
to we sort of already did speak on your
motion to pass Amendment but you like to
just anything else you wish to add to it
ready
call I would like to move that pass uh
House Bill
with
Amendment with as
amended and second by representative
Welch uh cler will uh seeing no hands up
for discussion oh excuse me
represent um speaking speaking to the
amendment physical note is still
attached to this there is still $800,000
per year fiscal note attached to this I
find it to be intellectually dishonest
to write in the bill that the court is
going to pay this the court is not going
to pay any of
this the state of New Hampshire is going
to pay
it and following the
money the taxpayers are going to pay
this
$800,000 and that is why I can't support
bought the bill it's got an
$800,000 Bill attached to it that
appears every
year and this budget year is the first
year it'll appear so I that's why I
cannot support the
amendment
seeing no further hands raised the clerk
will now call rooll if you in support of
the motion of ought to pass with
Amendment please say yay if you are
opposed please say
nay Vice chairman Welch
yes representative Alexander yes
representative Hopper
yes representative green
no representative Wallace
yes Representative testerman
no representative true
no representative Pratt
no representative
Marson
no the clerk votes no representative har
gri yes
representative
panus
yes representative
o'n oh I'm sorry he's not here
representative bordon a
yes representative Muse
yes representative
Newman yes representative bden yes
representative Conley yes representative
kle Knight
yes the branch
yes chairman
abbis the chair votes
yes Mr chairman the vote is 14 to
six I vot of
14-6 the motion of the motion of a the
pass with Amendment
passes representative Muse will you be
preparing the uh majority
report will it be a Minority
Report I believe there will
be before we leave
today now closes the
executive session of house build
198 now open the public hearing on house
bu
507 I'm just going to move this table
back because this look cosmetically
pleasing when I set it up this whole
section room can't hear you hear people
I take my gear you don't have to take
off any I I don't mind what do you want
you want the table move I'm just
move
yes all right just knock me out
I need the
chair
broke drum roll
please you got
it it's not an exact I did break a chair
Edna when I was
testified
read good
start
that only works for them yeah I don't
think you you would hear it it doesn't
broadcast our sound into the room I
think she's correct it won't won't
because we're all on mute in here except
for
that the chair calls representative
Amanda Balden
speak bu
507 thank you Mr chairman um thank you
colleagues for hearing my testimony
introducing house 507 today HP 507
eliminates so-called noof warrants
within the state by ensuring that police
only need to make an announcement before
entering a premisis the bill carvs out
and allows the destruction of property
if necessary for the purposes of gaining
access to a premises so a warrant may be
executed according to the New York Times
SWAT raids resulted in the deaths of 13
officers SE between 2010 and
2016 in 2012 one such Nook raid led to
the death of the chief of the Greenland
New Hampshire Police
Department the Michael Maloney memorial
fund which was set up in Chief Maloney's
memory to provide charitable services to
New Hampshire First
Responders cless
you tells the the heroing story
succinctly um he was 8 days from reti
on April 12 2012 Chief Michael Maloney
was requested by members of the New
Hampshire attorney general's drug task
force to assist with the execution of a
search warrant in Greenland New
Hampshire they were they were
immediately met with gunfire and four
sustained gunshot wounds as the officers
hastily retreated from the front porch
Chief Maloney entered the line of fire
pulling critically wounded officers to
the safety of a patrol car ordering them
to the Portsmouth Regional Hospital
Chief Maloney returned to the immediate
vicinity of the gun bottle to defend
other wounded officers it was about time
that he was fatally
wounded officers from the DOA New Market
Rochester and UNH police departments
were also injured in the shootout and
some required
hospitalization after this incident the
Attorney General imposed a suspension on
no knock raides executed without a
tactical team and invested in more
equipment to keep police officers safe
the AG next designed implemented a
warrant risk assessment Matrix in an
attempt to better analyze and predict
when no knock raids will become
excessively violent as you can see noock
raids present some of the most dangerous
assignments during a police officer
shift in the case of Chief Maloney the
shooters died in a murder suicide during
the ordeal no one survived to be held
accountable for chief Maloney's death
but if they had it's possible it would
have gone the way of Deputy Adam st's
death in a 2013 incident in Bolson
County Texas
police made a surprise raid at the home
of Henry McGee to collect evidence of
his marijuana growing operation as
officers entered the home un announed
McGee opened fire fatally wounding
Deputy solders McGee was initially
charged with capital murder which
carries out which carries the death
penalty in Texas but his attorney argued
self-defense because officers had not
announced themselves prior to entry
McGee was able to argue that he didn't
know whether a criminal was entering his
home in the end a grand Jerry agreed
that McGee had acted in self-defense he
served only 18 months on the related
drug charges and has since been
released when we ensure that police
officers make just one clear
announcement before entering the
premises we deny a murderer the
opportunity to claim self-defense and
evade responsibility after they take the
life of a police
officer at times police even mistakenly
raid the wrong address which results in
an innocent family's home being raided
in 2014 drug enfor forcement officers
broke down the front door of a
Manchester home to find a grandmother
inside with two
grandchildren an officer's weapon
misfired and the grandmother was shot in
the back while she was reaching for a
grandchild police found no drugs in the
home and no arrest were made as the
people they were looking for didn't live
there
anymore when law enforcement does not
announce their presence the inhabitants
of the home could conclude that they're
the victims of a home invasion the
Manchester grandmother was not armed but
this isn't always the case especially in
a state like New Hampshire furthermore
consider castle doctrine the idea that
individuals can use deadly force to
defend themselves against an Invader in
their own home this is a concern that
this committee dealt with just last week
nof raids conflict with the fact that
people are permitted to defend
themselves in their own home as it
stands it's unclear who would be held
accountable if a law-abiding gun owner
attempts to defend her home if she
misperceives a raid on the wrong address
as being a home invasion will she lose
her second amendment rights will she be
charged with a crime and imprisoned for
defending her home and her family no
knock raids put police officers in
unnecessary danger no knock warrants in
combination with castle doctrine are
arest for disaster to protect police and
the public alike we need to ensure that
police properly announce themselves
during raids thank you happy to take any
questions representative Maron thank you
Mr chairman thank you for your testimony
and your your
bill my question is this time does this
apply to just New Hampshire L
enforcement or would this pertain to
Federal oh thank you for your question
um I don't think that we have the
ability to dictate how Federal
authorities um behave in our
state and so um I believe that this only
would apply to uh New Hampshire police I
mean that's a good question it's
something I haven't considered but um I
think considering that we've had had
bills in the state before which were
attempts to control the types of things
that police can uh Federal authorities
can do in our state I think we've had
bills about preventing police uh Federal
authorities from collecting or rounding
up guns I think we've had bills about um
ice uh you know immigration so I think
that there's um I think that your
question might really be um a
constitutional debate as to whether
state can control Federal authorities um
that might be a state versus Federal
authority issue um but I would I would
uh venture to Guess that this bill only
applies to um police within our control
as a
state follow represent Mar yes I have a
follow I understand do you understand
the reason why in the law as it stands
now that there is thing is a no not
warrant can I'm sorry can you rephrase
the question are you just asking me if I
understand or are you asking me to
expand upon what I believe the reason
is want to clarify your
question yeah I'm curious that to know
whether you understand why there is such
a thing as a no not
why thank you for the question
it's my understanding that the purpose
of a no not warrant is to prevent the
individuals who would be serve with the
warrant from destroying evidence however
it should be noted that
unfortunately um
because a noock warrant can really only
be justified in situations where there
are not large amounts of drugs because
keep in mind if if you suspect someone
of having a large amount of drugs
then odds are very low that they'd be
able to destroy that in a short amount
of time in the time it takes to announce
yourself which is really the difference
between a warrant and a no knock warrant
is just saying hello I'm the police so
in that amount of time if it's very
difficult to destroy the amount of
evidence that the suspects are believed
to have then as I understand it the no
KN would would not be issued so if
someone has bricks and bricks and Bricks
of cocaine or what have you um they're
not going to entertain a knowof warrant
uh odds are because there's no
justification there's no it's not
believable that they'd be able to
destroy that evidence however if uh a
judge considers a request for know not
warrant and they see that the suspect is
believ to only have a small amount of
drugs then they're more likely to
approve the request for no enough
warrant but unfortunately the position
that that puts policemen in is that
they're now risking their lives uh
risking gunfire risking violence um
risking death for a small amount of
drugs for only being able to take a
small
am issued in situations where maybe
maybe someone could argue it's worth
risking a policeman's life but the vast
majority of the time it's just not worth
it and it seems like if someone has a
small amount of drugs you can probably
just pull them over um I'm not a
policeman but I know that have other
ways uh to detain people to uh make sure
this search happens and if you have a
small amount of drugs then while and
they not want maybe may fit the
requirements because you could argue
that they could destroy that small
amount of drugs the question becomes is
it worth risking the death of someone's
father someone's husband you know or
someone's wife just to get a small
amount of
drugs
one representative Mar one
last are you aware and if so how many no
KN warrants do we have happening in a
years time in the state of New Hampshire
thank you for your question um unless
someone has statistics to provide us my
understanding that statistics of this
kind aren't kept in New
Hampshire didn't understand it's my
understanding that statistics of this
kind are not maintained in our state
thank
you
representative test thank you Mr
chairman uh I'm torn between two
conditions one you know not and you make
a mistake and somebody inside the
apartment or wherever is injured by the
police
officer the other one is you go through
the identification process that outline
in this bill and the person inside the
the uh apartment has time to get a
firearm and the policeman is injured
now how do we make a decision which
which is the more important the
policemen or the people
inside um thank you for the
question
I'm not aware of a lot of situations in
New Hampshire where there's an attempt
to execute a warrant and notice is given
and then it's met with violence um it's
I would suppose that there's just a
tendency against this and I'm not saying
that there haven't been incidents of
violence against police in New Hampshire
there's been many of them and we're
aware of them and there's roads named
after those people you know traffic
circles and and such um but I I don't
believe that many of those incidents
occurred when um PE when police were
serving uh a warrant and announce
themselves but I'm not sure if I really
addressed your question because it was a
little
complex have then if you want to ask me
another you described
in you described in in great detail what
happened over in Greenland where the
police came on the porch basically they
came under Fire there were a lot of
injuries that it's very similar to a
situation where they knew what was the
the the
perpetrator knew they were coming for
whatever reason and and had time to to
to gather his arms and and cause a lot
of problems and that's no different than
you know a no knock Warrant Where you
you tell the person hey I'm I'm looking
for you I'm I'm going to come in and and
you know you all be ready well they may
be ready and you get shot again so I you
you you clearly stated the issue in the
Greenland one but you know I I'm at a
loss here to just determine what you
know which is the more more important
person inside or the person
outside um thanks for the question it's
like maybe you're trying I would imagine
that you would believe that the life of
the police officer is very important and
it sounds like maybe you're trying to
determine whether um it would be more
likely for there to be violence if
policemen announce themselves versus if
they don't and that is the focus of the
bill is that there have been
high-profile incidents in New Hampshire
where police officers were injured or
killed because they didn't announce
themselves and the unfortunate
consequence is that when they don't
announce themselves eles and someone is
killed or someone is hurt the person who
hurt them cre evade responsibility by
claiming self-defense because they
didn't announce themselves so that's the
trouble and it's it is probably
impossible to determine whether uh
violence is more likely to occur if they
announce themselves versus if they don't
um
but we can at least ensure that when
there is violence people will be held
accountable because police announce
themselves and they and they at least
give people um they take away the
opportunity for the shooter to say I
thought it was a home invasion I didn't
know that the police were there if I
knew it was the police I would have
cooperated they could say things like
that and there was the man in my uh
testimony that I mentioned in Texas who
did exactly that and instead of the
capital punishment he got 18 months in
jail for pot you know and that's um a
light and day difference on how that
case could have turned out um in light
of what he did and he's you know
literally a free man having killed a
policeman so I think that
the I think that the consequences of not
announcing themselves are so severe that
it's important to establish a pol policy
of announcing um Ved for police uh so
that we can at least hold people
accountable even if at the end of the
day we can't predict the future I hope I
addressed your
question
repres
Proby what police have
enter at what point do they say they are
the police that
specified how far can this go without
somebody
KN um I think that that's a question
better directed that maybe um if there
any policemen signed up to speak today I
think that they could speak more
authoritatively on that
um thank
you seeing seeing no further question
excuse me representative
green
I are you familiar with the show out in
brw
I'm sorry you'll have to remind me is
there a followup yes please follow up is
there going to be a question there too
yes it will
be she asked for some information on it
uh it was a knock situation uh it was in
a 55 and older
community uh the policeman knocked and
entered the place of residence and he
was shot on the spot and killed and then
there was uh other policeman showed up
and it was SWAT
Sheriff's Department local police and in
the end uh the person inside the house
decided to commit suicide and set the
place on
fire that's what happened and that's
what happens when you do a
KN so my question is it's all doesn't it
depend on the type of the situation
whether it should be a knock or no
KN thank you for the question
yeah it does depend but generally the
criteria comes down to whether um
whether there is a likelihood that these
suspects will be able to destroy
evidence um otherwise a normal warrant
is
expected
and um that is why I mentioned in my
testimony that after the incident with
Chief Maloney in uh Greenland uh the
Attorney General did put together
some um what's the
terminology a matrix of risk assessment
to try to determine um or try to predict
when any given uh raid might become more
violent than expect you know than would
normally be reasonable I suppose um so
that they could better prepare to
protect
themselves um and that was they they
decided to design that system because
they realized that just uh a noof raid
by itself was far too dangerous for
police to participate
in um but unfortunately I just don't
remember that story and maybe the names
of the uh officers involved might ring a
bell how long ago was it about six years
ago and I think I know what you're
referring
to sorry I'm a little I'm not going down
there just one one at a time try try to
be
recognized
you have aoll question yeah I was going
to ask the committee if anyone knew what
the officer's name was that was skilled
in that
incident now's not the
listen gson
walls I respect the Fallen officer if
you know the name yes is representative
uh officer stepen Rell from the
Brentwood PD one of my
constituents it's not going any I mean I
don't mean do with disrespect to the
officer but
we have a witness testify that let the
witness T answer
question seeing no further questions the
witness is excuse thank
you before I call the next witness on
our list um representative
representative lebranch you on the list
now I I should have corrected this last
time
and I was actually initially wrong about
this during orientation it was a point
of
order talk to the clerk and I I now see
the light if if you're the prime sponsor
of a bill then and you're a member of
the committee you're substitute the
committee you at that point cannot
participate in the public hearing as a
member of the committee if you are a
co-sponsor but don't testify you can
still sit on the committee and ask
questions to Witnesses so you're on the
list to testify but you're free to wave
that off and still participate as a
member of the committee and ask
questions to the witnesses if you so
choose I'll leave that discretion to to
your you to make that call thank you Mr
chairman for the clarity uh I was going
to testify anyways and I have my remarks
prepared I'll wave my right to uh ask
any questions of the other
witnesses that being said we call our
representative
Le Branch thank you Mr chair and thank
you members of the committee uh for the
record I'm Tony lebranch I represent
Amhurst New Hampshire which is Hillsboro
22 um and I'm here to say that we live
in a country of Freedom Every Man's home
is his castle we also live in a country
with the Second Amendment where we can
own AR we can bear arms uh so if you
were home sleeping in bed and you heard
the door break down what would you do if
you were a gun owner would you protect
yourself protect your family and protect
your property you don't know who just
broke down your door is it an officer is
it somebody breaking into your home so
that is what I'm asking of this
committee what would you do if the door
broke down at your house maybe the
police are at the wrong address maybe
you're Innocent but you do not know who
is at your door and I'm scared that
people will have their guns taken away
their rights taken away they will be
given a felony conviction because they
didn't know who was at the door who
broke down their door so that is all I
wanted to say think about what you would
do when your door is broken down and you
do not know who it
is representative Hopper uh thank you Mr
chair thank the representative for
taking my question we just heard
testimony that the Attorney General
wrote guidelines for uh no knock
warrants recently do we know of any um
no knock warrants that have gone AR rise
since the uh the new
outline besides what happened to bana
Taylor in the state of Kentucky I do not
know of any New Hampshire examples uh
since that new
guideline thank
you uh seeing no testimony I want to
thank the representative for his
testimony and you are
excused representative Norm
silver
thank you thank you Mr chair can you
hear me okay we can just fine repres you
turn the video I've been promoted I'm
gonna promote the witnesses to panelist
so they have the option they like to
turn do you want video on or not it's at
the it's the witness's choice okay I'll
just I'll leave it thank you for the
opportunity to speak about this bill uh
I would urge the committee to deem it in
expedient to legislate it seems to me
that there are three basic situations in
which a noock warrant might be
justified where there is a known
proclivity of the occupants to be
violent against law
enforcement there's known to be firearms
on the
premises and there is a a Bonafide fear
of Destruction or secretion of evidence
and
Contraband basically it seems to me that
the the number one job of government is
Public Safety and our law enforcement
officers are on the front lines on a
daily basis and they have a very
dangerous job when they're serving
warrants as opposed to prohibiting
outright no knock warrants I suggest
that there's two possible ways to deal
with them first of all RSA 595 A4 has
the provisions for the affidavit to get
a search warrant for a neutral magist
rate if they we should put in perhaps an
amendment that that section could be
amended to have specific Provisions to
justify the issuance of a no knock
warrant such as the things the outlines
of the the situations that I outlined as
far as the concern about law enforcement
breaking into with a no knock warrant
breaking into the wrongful premises it
seems to me and one of the the basic
problem is is that they have immunity
for making mistakes so if we want to
deal with that issue which is also a
slippery slope perhaps we reduce or
eliminate that immunity based on
mistakes if they make a mistake based on
negligence or gross negligence and go
into the wrong premises and damage the
wrong premises or injure someone then
they ought to be held responsible for
that but don't in the the majority of
cases they're not going to be going into
the wrong premises
they need to protect themselves and by
doing by having an affidavit in support
of an onok warrant which lays out
specifically under oath why it's needed
I think that that's should be
satisfactory and should solve this issue
so I urge the committee to itl this Bill
thank
you seeing no questions I want to thank
the representative for his testimony
thank
you Sergeant
Greg
Greg yes sir can you hear me yes we can
hear you
s thank you sir uh dear representative
abis and the members of the committee my
name is Gregory dulio and I'm a sergeant
with the Manchester Police Department
I've been a resident of the State of New
Hampshire and a police officer for the
last 15 years I currently serve as a
first L supervisor of the special
enforcement division special
investigations unit will we deal with
the detection of organized criminal
activity intelligence gathering and
narcotics enforcement I'm also a team
leader for the Department SWAT team I'd
like to thank you for the opportunity to
speak before you in opposition of House
Bill 507 and on behalf of my department
and also the New Hampshire Association
of chiefs of police I just want to speak
briefly about the no knock warrants and
knock and announced warrants I both have
a pretty good experience personal
experience with both of them
unfortunately the no knock warrants have
recently gained negative national
attention due to a few tragic incidents
that have occurred outside of New
Hampshire no knock warrants are highly
effective and if executed properly
provide the highest level of safety for
the public officers and suspects if 507
were to pass officers would not have an
option to execute a no knock warrant and
would be held to a knock and announce
warrant
in New Hampshire tactical teams across
the state take great pride in their
investigations preparation and execution
of these warrants I can speak from
experience that I have seen the benefits
of no knock warrants in which a suspect
has attempted to arm themselves upon our
arrival if a no knock warrant had not
been executed the result of that
investigation could have ended with a
lethal engagement instead of a peaceful
surrender as far as the sponsor of the
bill uh who presented it
earlier it seemed like she kept on
saying that it was for the preservation
of evidence that was the reason why this
bill is being brought forward that is
not the reason for no knock search
warrants um like the last gentleman that
spoke earlier he talked about
individuals inside of a residents that
are possibly armed we're trying to
contain them within the residents upon
our arrival to basically eliminate what
happened down in Sunrise Florida
recently with two FBI agents were fairly
shot and killed when they went up to a
door and they knocked they knocked first
which required the suspect inside the
house to arm himself and shoot the
police offices that road
side I do have to limit accept my apolog
I do have to limit testimony the general
public to two minutes per witness you
just mind providing
a statement to conclude your
testimony yes sir uh just in Clos and I
ask that you find host Bill 507 in
exponential legislate in if you have any
questions I'm more than happy to to
answer
them representative Conley thank you Mr
chairman thank you um Sergeant question
I asked earlier I wonder if you could
shed some light on can you explain the
process of a noof warrant uh at what
point you would identify yourselves as
police once you enter someone's
home yes absolutely um a no knock
warrant is obviously a search one
authorizing highly trained police off
officers which is usually our SWAT team
or other SWAT teams throughout the state
to enter a premise without first
knocking announcing their presence or
purpose immediately upon entering the
premise and I and everyone understands
is entering the premise just everyone
thinks that the means that the police go
running through the premise all we're
doing is creating an opening whether it
be a door or window and immediately upon
the opening of a window of a door loud p
announcements are made to the point
where people block several blocks away
from where we are can clearly hear that
we are the police so the individuals
inside the residents know that we are
the police and we are not there to do an
armed home
inv by us being able to do that we can
control where people are inside the
address and prevent them from Gaining a
firearm or potentially harming other
people with inside the
address
uh representative calling recognize for
a followup question
follow and this is purely uh for
information gathering I'm not asking for
any reason would you not be able to
arrest most people in U or interdict
them in situations that would uh you
know when they're walking to a vehicle
when they're you know is that a
possibility if you do that uh to the
extent possible to avoid these
potentially dangerous knock or no knock
situations yes that is uh 100% we do
that uh daily we take all these um
factors into account and if possible if
we can safely take someone into custody
without having to conduct a no knock
warrant we would 100% would do that
before executing a warrant like that um
it is our goal is to provide our
officers our community and the people
that these people reside with inside
this address um their safety is are is
Paramount at that point in
time representative Hopper uh thank you
Mr chair thank you Sergeant for taking
my question uh we heard earlier that the
AG put more new
guidelines um to uh help amarate any
problems with no not warrants you know
of any issues since the new guidelines
came
out
no sir I do not know of any uh any new
issues sir thank
you representative Marston thank you Mr
chairman thank you assigned for taking
my
question I'm hoping you know the answer
but for the edification of myself and my
fellow members here before you have a no
not warrant you must present a a request
for one before a federal judge is that
correct sir it depends if the case is a
federal case or if it's a state case if
um if it is a state case it would go
before a district court um or a superior
court and then um obviously if it was a
federal case it would be brought before
the a USA's office and they would pre
they would look at the facts of the case
and they would uh they would uh justify
whether what type of Warrant was going
to be issued at that time represent Mar
you follow yes thank you
Mr s how many no warrants do we have
happened in the last year in the state
of New
Hampshire I don't have those numbers um
right off hand for you
um all I can say is um as far as a
Manchester Manchester does execute them
align with knock U knock and announce
warrant as well um but I can't give you
a a number um a definitive number at
this
time represent Mars another followup
question yes thank you Mr your best
guess on the
number did you hear my question yes sir
I'm just uh taking a minute to think
about the the number of warrants I would
I would say probably about 50 50 no
knock warrants along with a handful of
knock and announce warrants depending on
if it was a federal case or
not thank
you representative
Jeff thank you Mr Mr chair um thank you
Sergeant for taking my question um do
you know what the difference is with or
what addition that um that's been added
to the no
knock can you um clarify that question
having a tough time understand what
you're asking it was spoken that um
there has been I guess an addition or
updated no knock warrant that came out
of the court so I'm just curious as to
what was it that was that was something
that was implemented by the Attorney
General's office after the Greenland uh
officer involved shooting um and that
was uh guidelines that were set forth at
that point in time I do not have them in
front of me at the
time thank
you Sergeant the chair has a question
and I want to thank you in advance for
taking my
question so in addition to the
destruction of evidence
is the thought of evidence being
destroyed is one reason to get a know
War I always understood that the other
scenario would be circumstances
where the officer safety would be
jeopardized by knocking or announcing
your pres so one of the reasons why the
offic
would not anounce their presence for
their own safety is
that is there any is that a correct uh
circumstance where no not warrant would
be
sought so you're I just want to make
sure I'm clear on what you're asking so
you're asking that if an officer would
feel that his safety would be in
Jeopardy yes by announcing their
presence sometimes correct I'll give you
a prime example um these these no knock
warrant Wars are usually weak you know
approximately about a month to several
month long investigations in which we
learn um through Intel Gathering
confidential informats some stuff along
those lines about people having firearms
with inside the residence with us going
up and knocking on a door or a window
um it's the officer safety that we're
concerned about that this person would
potentially go grab a firearm um and do
harm to the police because most of these
investigations sometimes we receive
information about resistance to the
police um so yes that's uh that is one
of the reasons
[Music]
why I thank for taking my
question seeing no further questions I
want to thank the sergeant for his
testimony and you are excused thank
you if if there are any members of the
public that intend on testifying
got our in attendance please raise your
hands
now sopia welcome
back thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee for taking my testimony
today again my name is Sophia bondolino
I'm 14 I live in Manchester and I'm
speaking today on behalf of the New
Hampshire High School Democrats in
support of HB
507 I am in support of hb7 as I believe
it is a step in the right direction
towards solving the issue that plagues
this nation police brutality this
country has seen the danger and tragedy
that comes along with Nook Warren most
pointedly earlier in 2020 when we were
all shaken by the murder of Briana
Taylor on March 13th 2020 the Louisville
Police Department entered the apartment
where bana Taylor was sleeping along
with her partner Kenneth Walker these
officers were issued a no knock search
warrant for the apartment but these
police officers were not in any clothing
that indicated they were with law
enforcement and did not clearly identify
themselves before entering the apartment
with a battering ram the events that
unfolded ultimately left an officer
injured and an innocent unarmed black
woman dead I would also like to address
something that has been mentioned before
today by pointing out that Kenneth
Walker did have time to find his gun and
fire it even though the officers did not
announce themselves neglecting to inform
Walker of the situation did not stop him
from using force it simply made the
situation more chaotic and led to more
pain for everyone involved including the
officers hp5 was 7 contains two vital
points that will be crucial in
preventing future tragedies like these
first the police officers must identify
themselves clearly to anyone who could
be in the residence and may only enter
using Force once due notice is given
secondly the police officers must be in
clearly identifiable
uniforms had Mr Walker known that the
Invaders were police officers on March
13th and was able to respond accordingly
Rihanna Taylor would still be alive
today this bill is not only about the
difference between knocking or not this
bill to many people of color in the in
the state of New Hampshire could save
lives do not allow branna Taylor to have
died a fruitless death but use her
Legacy to build safer and better
communities and to reform law
enforcement in this country I urge the
committee to join the New Hampshire High
School Democrats in support of HB
507 thank you again for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused
Sher
wac yes can you hear me yes we
can yes hi um my name is Sher wack and
um I'm just a member of the public
however um
I'm I'm quite interested in in this sort
of thing I have education and judicial
studies and a degree in
criminology uh although I do not
currently work in the field
um I wanted to speak today uh in support
of abolishing uh the no knock warrant
um I I understand what the officer that
spoke earlier was saying um however I
would have to agree with what uh uh the
member of the committee stated earlier I
believe it was the member from
Hillsboro um
and excuse me it it's true um in
that under the Second Amendment yes we
do have the right to own
firearms
and if your door were to come flying
open um in the darkness of night or even
during the
daylight uh most people would be quite
startled by it and I think if you had a
firearm nearby would be likely to grab
it possibly use it because as he said
you have no idea who that might be
uh also I think
um under the Fourth Amendment um of the
United States
Constitution
uh there is a plethora of case law out
there um on search and seizure um and
the the main thing tends to be
reasonableness
uh and warrants have to be very clearly
spelled out
exactly where it is they're searching
exactly what property they are looking
for uh the exact names of the
parties um they can't just show up at
this R uh except my apology we have to
limit
testimony to two minutes so if you just
please try to uh conclude your testimony
at
uh you have to un unmute
yourself
may I
continue yes we just we have to limit
testimony to two minutes per witness so
uh we I was just notifying you let you
know your two minutes has expired please
include your testimony oh if my two
minutes is has expired then um I
understand and uh well I I guess I will
uh refrain from any any further
testimony um however I am in support of
abolishing no knock
warrants and I I thank you for your time
and
attention thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused
calling Sergeant Michael
Lang I'm here can you hear me we can
hear you
Sergeant great thank you good afternoon
representative abis and members of the
committee my name is Michael Lang and
I'm a sergeant with the Nashville Police
Department I am a lifelong resident of
the State of New Hampshire and I've been
a police officer for 12 years I
currently serve as a firstline
supervisor in our Professional Standards
Bureau and I'm a team leader on the
department SWAT team I'm here to testify
opposition to HB 507 on behalf of my
department and also the New Hampshire
Association Chiefs of police I agree
with everything that Sergeant Tulio said
and I would like to reiterate that no
knock warrants are of tremendous value
to Tactical teams throughout the state
executing search warrants is in my
opinion the most dangerous task officers
perform in the course of their duties
and banning no knock warrants will lead
to more of us getting severely injured
or killed part of my job as a team
leader is planning search warrant
services and quite frankly I can't
imagine having to serve a search warrant
on a suspect who is known to be armed
and dangerous but having to knock first
this will only give the suspect a chance
to shoot through the door or to lie in
wait to sit in the Ambush when we do
make entry which is exactly what
happened to the FBI agents in
Florida I do think there are some
misconceptions about nonok warrants and
with a little education people wouldn't
be calling for a complete ban on them
for one there seems to be a belief that
when a no knock warrant is served that
we burst through the door in jeans and
t-shirts and rush through the house
without identifying ourselves in New
Hampshire this is simply not the case we
use highly trained well-marked officers
who issue clear announcements that are
nearly simultaneous to the entry and
another myth is that we just use no
knock search warrants to preserve
evidence or quote to get the dope again
simply not true in Nashua we do not let
the need or desire to save drug evidence
dictate our tactics rather we ask the
court for a no knock warrant because we
need to arrest someone in a house who is
believed to be armed and dangerous and
likely resistant to the warrant
service in reference the example that
was provided about Greenland in 2012 I'd
really like to clear something up that
was not a no knock warrant service
although these Drug Task Force officers
applied and received a no knock warrant
that is not how they served it they
knocked and
announced but when those attempts were
futile that's when they made entry and
received
gunfire a subsequent review of this
incident by the attorney's general
office indicated that
fact and also noted that the delayed
entry provided the
suspect Sergeant Lane Sergeant Lane I
accept my apology we do have to limit
testimony of two minutes per per per
person so if you don't mind just
including your testimony within a sent
sentence or
two yes sir I understand the Attorney
General said quote more than sufficient
time to prepare his armed respon resp to
the entry in my opinion no knock
warrants should not be banned because
they are needed in some circumstances
and in closing I ask that you find HB
507 inexpedient to legislate thank you
for your
time representative Newman you recognize
for
question yeah yes thank you Mr chairman
and Sergeant Lang thank you for your
testimony and I just want to just
clarify something that you said about
safety of offices reference uh obtaining
um evidence so
is my understanding correct if I think
that there is always a safety concern
about some someone being Al armed and
potentially um is going to use that
Armed Force against the offices is that
the only time that you have a no
knock sir thank you for your question
and state and federal law carves out
exceptions to the knock requirement one
is evidence preservation and the other
is that the uh officers for some reason
face an increased level of of threat to
themselves when they make entry every
Tactical Team is different every state
is different in how they do it and when
I indicate that uh we here in Nash don't
do it for evidence uh that's what I mean
so we we don't do no knock warrants for
evidence we do it when we think that
someone inside is armed and they might
be resistant to the warrant or they
intend on harming us or somebody else in
the
house represent and you recognize for a
followup thank you Mr chairman So based
on what you just said um do you think
that
the you would be more acceptable to a
warrant to a law law like this um being
passed if it clearly um allowed for no
knock warrants on the for the safety of
the officer but prohibited them for the
acquisition of evidence
sir I think that would depend uh I would
hate to see it banned outright um
anytime evidence was s because depending
on the nature of the crime uh the
evidence could be crucial to building a
case so I think what would be better
would be uh a judge's review on a
case-by casee basis for every no knock
search warrant whether or not it's for
evidence or to protect the safety of the
officers who are going
inside thank
you
representative
Muse yes thank you for taking my
question one of the things that I'm
curious about is when noo warrant
started to become something that police
departments uh were doing I I don't
recall ever watching a 1940s 1950s or
even
1960s movie or TV show where they did do
yor were where no knock warrants were
actually being done so I'm curious is
this a a relatively new thing in
policing or is it something that's been
around with us for a long
time uh sir I would know exactly uh when
they gained popularity I do believe the
War on Drugs maybe in the 80s led to um
them becoming a little more prevalent
with the the need at the time to
preserve evidence and uh you know kind
of kind of as we has evolved as a
society um I don't have any St for you
but I'm pretty confident in saying that
at least in New Hampshire um the
practice of conducting them for for
evidence preservation has gone down will
we still try to use them when we can um
if there's an armed threat
inside representative Muse you
recognized for a
followup yes I'm also wondering how you
evaluate the success of uh of serving a
no knock warant
and
um what kind of what kind of process
there is around for just sort of
evaluating um actions you know a little
bit of a kind of a almost like a Monday
Morning Quarterback review kind of a
thing that police departments may do
after they go through the
process sure uh I think I want to touch
on the risk assessment thing that got
brought up by the sponsor earlier um she
was almost putting in in text that the
risk assessments are done to evaluate
the danger of the person or the house
and while that's true I believe she was
indicating that if there was a a
heightened level of threat then the
warrant simply wouldn't be served and
the police wouldn't take any kind of
action that that's simply not true risk
assessments are put in place um to
evaluate how dangerous somebody is and
it's not a matter of serving the warrant
or not it's a matter of who serves it
whether it be Patrol and detectives or
if they seek the advice of a Tactical
Team um so if the Tactical team does the
evaluation and they make the
determination uh that their
participation is appropriate at that
point they evaluate whether or not
they'll serve a knock and announce or a
no knock and then to get back to your
question after the warrant is served um
we have what is called an after action
review and we talk about everything from
the planning process through the warrant
service and uh we do evaluate on a
case-by Case basis whether or not it
worked and to touch on the second part
of your question how we evaluate if it
worked
um it's it's it's usually obvious uh
we're able to U make an entry point into
the residents like sergeant pulio said
and then people surrender
peacefully um and if nobody gets hurt uh
that's kind of the the main goal here
regardless of the situation and that
that means we were
successful thank
you representative board day thank you
Mr chairman uh thank you for taking my
question uh have you or anyone in your
department ever gone to the wrong
address when serving a
warrant I'm sorry could you repeat the
question I say have you or anyone in
your department ever gone to the wrong
address when serving an a
warrant uh yes sir in one circumstance
we uh we did we mustu a second floor
apartment for the third floor
fortunately we were able to determine
that a mistake had been made before we
actually made
entry thank you
representative Conley thank you Mr
chairman thank you sir foring
question how often is somebody injured
in one of
these serving of this warrant this way
of entering someone's home whether that
be an officer U or someone other than
the subject of the
warrant sir thank you for the question I
can't speak to how often people in
general are injured but I can tell you
that nsha we've been fortunate to avoid
that Al
together represent Cony ask for a
followup yes thank you sorry that
question was not well I meant within
your specific Department did I
understand correctly that in your
experience nobody in ASA other than the
subject including the officers have been
[Music]
injured sir I'm sorry you muffles I
couldn't hear at the end of your
question did I hear correctly that in
ASA no nobody other than the subject of
the warrant has been injured in in your
experience in
ASA are do you mean innocent do you mean
like um bystanders or officers is that
what you're asking bystanders and
officers yes uh we we have had an
officer injured um it wasn't necessarily
a result of the the fact it was a know
KN warrant he uh he cut his hand on a
piece of glass on the exterior of the
house and I don't I don't want to be uh
speak in totality here but as far as I
can recollect right now I don't recall
any bystanders getting injured during
the service one of these
warrants representative
PR
youday a question for
you the inces of home inv
they sir I'm sorry again I couldn't hear
you I heard it home invasion but I
didn't hear the
question I don't want to say that it's
frequent um but our our detectives do
deal with it
um on a regular basis to be honest with
you it's so I don't have uh an exact
number um but it does
happenes you want to be recognized for a
followup question
pleas sir I'm having trouble hearing you
but just so I can make I understand the
question you're asking how a homeowner
would know the difference between a home
invasion or a no knock search
warrant okay uh like sge Theo said uh
the difference is uh a very loud police
announcement these are not stealth uh
missions by any means um we use a
combination of PA systems in our
vehicles loud verbal announcements at
the door and and as part of our best
practice uh we make sure those
announcements are made before entry
regardless if it's a knock warrant or a
no knock
warrant representative
Newman you mute
yourself
represent Newman do you have a question
no I didn't have a question I might have
my hand might have looked like it was
raised
inadvertently representative
n thank you chairman and thank you
Sergeant for taking my question uh you
mentioned uh before when representative
Bardon a question um about going to the
wrong floor of an apartment building my
question is when you don't
knock uh for a warrant and you storm
into a community living situation that
affects multiple people how do you
notify the rest of the
community um I think I'm going to try to
answer that with h two parts first as
far as storming in um I want be clear
that that's it's our best practice that
we don't storm in um whether it's a
knock an announce or a knock like
sergeant dulo said we do what we call as
a breach which is is essentially opening
a door or window and then we make ano
announcements from that point and then
as far as the rest of the community uh
we do everything we can in every warrant
service to evacuate the people in the
immediate area surrounding the place
that we're trying to
search
representative night do you have a
followup
question yeah thank you chair I just um
can I wonder what that looks like let's
say there's a children playing outside
in a apartment building and you have to
go in what what is the protocol for that
how do you know do you find their
parents these are
miners um they're W witnessing that is
this
okay
uh we take extra steps as far as the
timing of these warrant services to make
sure that uh kids are in school and we
do everything we can in the planning
process to mitigate those kind of
concerns but if we get there um we make
sure we Scout the location ahead of time
and we do everything we can leading up
to it to clear um uninvolved people you
know especially children out of the area
in the immediate moments leading up to
the warrant service and um I I don't
want to get too much into what that
looks looks like uh know for our own job
reasons but um you know we really go out
of our way to make sure that everybody's
out of the area before the warrant
service thank you Sergeant seeing no
further hands raised I want to thank the
sergeant for his
[Music]
testimony
Mark Morris Mark
Morrison Mr don't
see that be a number on
there we'll go with the phone number
anyway we don't we don't know your name
we have your number we'll uh we're going
to call you to testify I think the
number is is it 316 would just please
state your name for record where you are
from and whether you're testifying in
support or in
opposition
to hello Mr chairman can you hear me yes
I can thank you very much uh my name is
Mark Morrison and I am the President of
the New Hampshire Police Association and
I
am calling today to uh testify against
HB
um most of the testimony you've heard
today I would simply be repeating but I
think something that has rung true
throughout the testimony is is the
dangers faced uh by law enforcement
certainly law enforcement today the the
ability to have as a tool although
extremely um strict Protocols are in
place to use this tool the no knock
warrant um these warrants are not you
know simply approved you know without
scrutiny these warrants go through a
very strict scrutiny process and are
signed by a neutral and detached you
know third- party judge um
it's a it's a critical
tool to remain in
place to allow law enforcement to do
their jobs in the safe manner as
possible um taking into account the
absolute dangers you know that are
facing officers
today um New
Hampshire does it a little bit better
than a lot of the rest of the country
which is why we have these strict
protocols already in place and I would
encourage
um you know the committee uh to to
please listen to the testimony from the
officers that have testified today and
keep this valuable tool in place uh
keeping in mind that we already have
very strict you know protocols
associated with it and with that I'll
take any questions thank
you repres views
thanks for taking my question um I'm
just curious about what type of
protocols New Hampshire may have in
place around no Kno warrants that other
states um who might be having we are um
things that they may not
have well without being able to speak
with specificity I I think what you've
seen um through the professionalization
of law enforcement in New Hampshire is
have having very strict protocols and
the biggest is having the neutral and
detached third party the judge uh sign
off on these these are not you know
warrants that you can have signed by a
justice of the peace or or some other
you know party it has to be a judge that
um in addition to the you know the the
protocols that individual agencies have
in place and and Nasha was a perfect
example you heard testimony that even
though authorized to make a no knock
warrant for um evidentiary
purposes they don't do that so um many
many police departments have an even uh
more strict standard than they may be
allowed under law and that that's sort
of you know the the type of example exle
that I would use of of things that we do
here in New
Hampshire representative M recognize for
a followup
question yes thank you um if have you or
has your department Revisited any of the
protocols that were in place prior to
last summer based on last some of last
Summer's
incidents I'm sorry s i I missed the
beginning of your question could you
please repeat it sure I'm I'm just
wondering if your department Revisited
any of the protocols maybe change some
of them uh in response to some of the
incidents that took place last
summer I I do not believe that uh our
agency I I work for the lary police
department and we are part of the
Southern New Hampshire Special
Operations unit and you know we have an
ongoing you know sort of process where
we are always uh critical of our own
performance and try to do it you know
better um all the time so we would have
a normal uh
evaluation uh of any operation that we
did um immediately following that
operation and I can tell you i' I've
been in law enforcement for over 22
years and you know the number of no
knock search warrants um that we've been
involved in is certainly in in relation
to all other warrants is very small um
and they are only reserved you know
really for the most
dangerous uh search warrants where you
know the safety of the officers or those
around you know that location would be
utilized thank
you
representative Newman you
recognized yeah I just have a quick
question about who reviews the uh the uh
evidence who reviews it when you're when
you're it's a no knock for evidence did
you say that they are all reviewed by a
judge and is that in the
law well in order to get a search
warrant you would need the search
warrant to be signed off by a judge and
the no knock provision is a specific
attachment to that warrant application
you know there would need to be uh very
specific uh facts and circumstances laid
out as to why you would need that and
that is already in place
today represent new you have a followup
question Roger just a quick one that I
before just previously you said they
don't do that I was wondering who the
day was you mentioned uh justices of the
pre peace Etc but what I'm hearing from
you right now is that that it's it's
always reviewed by a judge and is that
correct yes
sir thank
you see seeing no hand hands raised I
want to thank the Ser for his
testimony thank you very much
Joseph
bber good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Joe Ebert it's
EBT I'm a captain with the New Hampshire
State Police and I oversee our
Investigative Services
Bureau uh much like the speaker before
me I I I think I I want to be respectful
of your time and the other individuals
who wish to testify almost all of the
points that I was going to address have
been addressed and discussed um one
thing I did want to say and this comes
from more of a a personal place but
having worked on some of the cases that
were mentioned previously uh the murder
of Chief Michael Maloney the murder of
Officer stepen arel I I take very very
very seriously as does by agency the
review of any warrant service and there
are a number of uh in within the state
police there is a number of checks and
balances and we try at all cost to avoid
a no knock warant so I I know that uh uh
much has been discussed about elsewhere
in the the country and I understand that
and I understand why that's being
discussed but I wanted to make sure that
the individuals of this committee and
anyone who's listening to this uh uh to
this broadcast knows that we always take
the safety of the public and of course
our our Troopers and anybody else and
within law enforcement who are involved
in a warrant service into account and we
hold that as the absolute most Paramount
of uh of outcomes so having said that I
am absolutely willing to take any
questions that the committee may
have representative Newman you have a
question no I do
not your hand your hand was a a digital
hand not your
phical seeing no questions I want to I
want to thank the officer for his for
his time and his and his testimony thank
you
sir can can you hear
me chairman abis can you hear
me yes I can yes I can hear you thank
you good afternoon uh former rep Jr hle
dun Barton speaking on behalf of
myself I signed in an opposition to this
bill and the reason I signed in an
opposition to this bill is a is a tragic
story that I heard several years ago
about Berwin Heights Maryland and I want
to repeat this testimony of what
happened in Berwin Heights Maryland so
that we understand the
consequences of a noock warrant executed
poorly we've heard a lot of testimony
today that there's a lot of checks and
balances about executing noock warrants
in New Hampshire differently and that's
great but can we be better and in Berwin
Heights Maryland in 2007 sorry 2008
there was a raid on the mayor's house
because they believe believe that a
package of marijuana was to be delivered
to the mayor's house and in the process
they held the mayor and his
mother-in-law hostage and shot their two
dogs Google barwin Heights Maryland it's
worth reading the story heard this
person speak in person once and it was
very eye openening to feel to hear his
side of the story on a no knock raid
conducted
poorly I understand that New Hampshire
they're not doing it just to preserve of
evidence that's what we've heard in
testimony but I am very concerned that
we don't have yet the perfect solution
of trying to protect the individuals
that are in the apartment or in the
house protect the officers who are
conducting um this warrant and I think
um representative silver hit it the nail
on the head that maybe having the judge
do more in terms of signing off on the
authority of a no knock warrant is is
perhaps the next step in terms of
improvement under the current
law as I said I signed in an opposition
because it only takes one bad no knock
warrant where someone ends up dying and
there's no way to recover the Injustice
that happened so I would ask that you
would make sure all the necessary checks
and balances are in place as a committee
um when you review what to do with this
Bill thank
you
thank you representative Alexander I do
have a question thank you Mr chair um
thank you um Mr hle for taking my
question um you signed in in support of
getting rid of no knock warrants correct
I guess I was unclear by yes thank you
representative Alexander I did sign in
in getting rid of no knock warrants
because I think there is the potential
for a case where it's executed poorly
and someone ends up at similar to The
bwin Heights story where
it's executed at the wrong house or for
the wrong reason and if if I can just
for those who don't have the time to go
look this up this was where the
intendent UPS driver I as I understand
it was the intended recipient of of this
package of of marijuana but they didn't
realize that so they had a different
officer actually deliver the package and
then they conducted the raid on the
house and they held his mother-in-law
hostage while he was getting out of the
shower it was a mess so I I would just
ask that we make sure we have every
check and balance in place before we
start issuing no knock
warrants and for the record sometimes
politics makes funny bed U funny allies
in this case if I look at the sponsors
they tend to not be on the issues that I
share but this is one where I think
there's there's a real Liberty issue at
stake repres Marston thank you Mr ch
thank you for tting my question Mr H
just a quick question in the regards
that if what you say is true then we
would all be living in a perfect world
would we
not thank you Mr Maron that's a good
question yes we are far from a part
perfect world and I I I honestly think
that those that are conducting these
warrants um and these searches are doing
their best I'm not saying they're not
what I'm saying is we we as a continual
improvement process should always be
looking to see if we can make it better
and I think the committee has an
opportunity to do
that see seeing No Hands
raised thank
youman
David
melder
G
Hera
huh double
Che no
[Music]
number yeah I'm
fine see seeing no members of the public
with a hand rate at this time we
will we close the
uh end the hearing on public hearing on
House Bill
507 sorry represent
Muse chman we had uh for HP 507 we had
62 people signed in in support we had uh
seven signed in in opposition and we had
one person sign in as
neutral ruse can you repeat those
numbers the clerk yes uh 62
supporting seven opposing one
[Music]
neutral uh I see I do see a person
member of the the public with their hand
raised just to
explain that uh once once a member of
the public testifies that they they're
not to testify more than once that's why
we we didn't call you a second
time I think what we what we're going to
do just be take a 10 minute break I
think we can open up
repr I'm sorry
interrup I think what we'll do is there
we then um some executive sessions we do
have some more bills to EXA why don't we
take a 10 minute 10 minute breather
we'll be in recess for 10 minutes and
we'll we'll make a Time certain you want
to just do
4:15 that work
everyone the committee will be in recess
till
[Music]
4:15
representative
Harbor I was busy h to it you
are would you like us to wait a little
longer yeah okay now
we the chair is now opening the
executive session on HB
[Applause]
507 she recognizes representative Hopper
to make a motion
I've KNN you for a lot of years so it's
nice to see you still recognize me um
thank you Mr chair um i' make a motion
for to legisl
507 representative true
second represent H do you wish to speak
on your motion basically it's almost
like the uh Bill we EXA earlier there
seems to be
um a lot of issues with no knock WS
around the country but
it's it do it seems like they're used uh
very judiciously
and we didn't really hear a lot of test
testimony about how bad they are in the
man so it seems like
a a fix of a problem that isn't doesn't
exist thank
you chair I open the this up for
discussion D wish to
speak
see no fur the hands raised call a
question M raised oh excuse
me represent tagas accept my apology
certainly I just would like to speak on
this bill and clear a couple things up
in the Greenland shooting was a not a no
knock warrant they had a warrant and
they were going to knock but didn't get
a chance to because a guy behind the
door had a gun that he wasn't supposed
to have his mother bought it for him he
was bad from having it any guns at
all and I think we need to stop and
think about what we are doing with
police
officers as far as rules and regulations
we put on them
that we are not walking in their
shoes and I feel as though this bill is
a bad Bill thank
you
agre representative
Muse one of the reasons I asked one of
the officers about
when when law enforcement agencies
started doing no nor not warrants is
because uh it literally seems to be
something that started um specifically
with the war on drugs and I think one of
the things that we've seen continuously
and one of the reasons why these
warrants are problematic across the
country and uh and why we've heard so
much about them is because people in
minority communities tend to be
disproportionately affected by this type
of law
enforcement um it's
I can't imagine what it must feel like
sitting there watching your television
not you know not having any idea what's
going to happen next and then having uh
police come through your door um and
this has happened Time and Time and Time
Again across the country it's happened
in minority communities it's it's an
element to policing that really seems to
be new in the last 40 years
and uh and I think it's one of it's a
symptom of the militarization of our
police force on another bill we actually
heard an officer refer to uh bullets and
tear gas as
Munitions we're talking about law
enforcement and civilians here and you
know to me this bill is an opportunity
to ramp this back down a little bit um
to force us to consider Maybe some
different ways to enforce the law um uh
I would like to see us pass this
bill representative
um thank you
Mr I want toate that the issue with no
not
warrant the issue with no not war is not
whether they're a useful tool a
chainsaw is a useful tool but if I let
my husband have one something bad could
happen
that's also why my husband doesn't have
a motorcycle
anymore I think he's
got listen representative hoer please
sheing a
joke I am I'm making a joke but but I'm
trying to convey a meaningful point
which is that we heard a lot of
testimony today that is an important
tool to affect a certain outcome and I'm
sure that that's true that this is a
useful tool given the outcome but tools
can be dangerous as is the case with
chainsaws which terrify me and I think
that we found pretty
consistently that the difference that's
created when you announ then knock or
knock and then immediately announ which
is the difference created by this SP
highlighted by this
bill that's where the danger lies
because if they KN and
announ the people inside in the timean
between the knock and announ may feel
justified in uh attacking whatever they
perceive to be happening and then later
as we saw in the case with the man in
Texas if they are charged with murder or
whatever it is that they end up doing to
the police who had a warrant in every
right to be there um they may be able to
argue that they were acting in offense
because they didn't know who was at
their home home and so then we have an
injury or a dead person and then we
don't have any justice for the affected
person for the family who lost them and
the person who made a bad
decision goes free and it seems
like um castle doctrine heavily
conflicts with the way that no function
in New Hampshire and I'm not speaking to
other states
Kentucky Taylor or any of those
situations because our c is way that our
state phes it we have our own practices
in our state and there just seems to be
an essential conflict between those two
concepts that you have a right to defend
your property when you perceive a threat
and then if you perceive a threat but
they actually have a right to be you
don't know this and you attack them what
happen who is at fault who's responsible
for the situation will anyone be held
accountable if there's a loss of life or
an injury or are people who attack
police always going to be L free because
they can claim that they thought they
acting in their own self-defense so I
think that that's really the issue here
um and it's not what is not issue is
whether no not warrants are an effective
tools thank you
for representative
Welsh I think what we heard today in the
testimony I'm just guessing it might
have been let say a dozen incidents
where things went
wrong nobody testified as to how often
it's
successful there's hundreds of times
that they use these war and they're
successful I'm I'm
there
seeing no further hands raise the matter
will we put the question a
motion is inexpedient to legislate the
clerk will call the role if you are in
support of the motion of
inexpedient legislate please say yay if
you are opposed please say
nay
Vice chairman Welch abut
yes representative Alexander yes
representative Hopper yes representative
green definitely yes representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true yes representative
Pratt
no representative morston
yes the votes yes representative Harriet
G absolutely
no representative panus
yes representative of he's not here
sorry um Representative
bordon
no representative
muse
no representative Newman
no
representative
gold Mr chair I'm sorry I skipped right
over top of Representative
um oh I'm sorry
she my apology carry on Representative
bden
no representative Conley no
representative kle Knight
no representative of branch
no chairman abis the chair votes
yes Mr chair the vote is 11 yay
n by vote of 11 Y and nine
y excuse me by a vote of 11 Y and n y
motion of inexpedient inexpedient to
legisla
task will you be preparing the
majority
[Music]
the number again
119 motion was it
Wallace po w
true and true hoer and true
okay
we will now open up the chair will now
open the the executive
session on House Bill
197 recognize representative rhs for a
motion we be offering an
amendment thank you Mr chairman I would
like to make a motion of a to pass with
Amendment and the amendment has been
passed around to
everybody what's the amendment number
the amendment number is
2021 D2 I'm sorry D
yes
you wish to speak to your Amendment yes
I would thank you Mr chair uh the reason
that we had the amendment drawn up was
because when we heard testimony on
Friday there seemed to be a lot of
concern and some confusion about the
definition of riot in New Hampshire and
after hearing the testimony we thought
it was best to just strike that from the
bill Al together because it did
not it did not justify I'm sorry did
not undermine the
bill having it
out will anyone wish to speak uh about
the motion open it for discussion excuse
me the
amendment just representative Maron I'm
B it I guess and I'm not sure if that's
the right word
question wasn't that in the original
Bill itself
197 yes the amendment the original Bill
had also added a section A subsection uh
e uh the amendment strikes to subsection
e and any reference to riting has been
removed
from is removed by the amendment
the what I have here for the
amendment to
02498 looks to me like d is is worded
just exactly like what it is in the bill
correct but in the original Bill there
was a after d was e e is now gone by
it's by the EV it's
removed again point of water it's do
state in the amendment that we
eliminate well it's not a point of order
it's a question about the amendment okay
and we can open up for discussion so
this is not we can discuss the
so the original Bill had a subsection e
under which the amendment would be
removing that subsection the bill would
have added subsection e subsection e
does not exist in the law today if you
adop the amendment and pass the Bill
subsection e would still not exist in
the law and that section was was
designated and address and use the
terminology RI and and I believe that
the motivation behind the amendment was
influenced by the testimony before the
committee
where it's very easy to confuse a
peaceful Gathering where you can have a
100 people peacefully Gathering
and out of those 100 people you can have
one person with the you know air horn
and out of those other one person can
exercise extremely po judgment and throw
a rock at someone's car or whatever and
that would justify deadly force not only
against the person that used the the
through the rock but also the person
with the
air and that that to me was very
persuasive testimony that it was an
unattended consequence of the original
bill this amendment resolv olves that
issue and I think especially for the
people who are peacefully protesting and
that's that's their objective I can see
why they can find it very concerning
especially if you have two three th000
people at your event and is one or two
individuals that decide to engage in
violent
Behavior it shouldn't because the the
riting definition has the work
tumultuous and that was the problem and
that has to do with specifically the
Hampshire's definition of riting it
wasn't that the definition other states
might have other definitions but I
think having the word comm in there made
it
really difficult to allow that snare
because that fact kind could have played
out and that would be unfortunate
because if that did play out the person
inside the vehicle would actually be
legally justified in using the force
when I say Justified it's because the
law allows it but that's why we are felt
that that was not we is the amendment is
not believ that's an we don't believe
that's an acceptable use of force and
should not be allowed under the law
under that circumstance because someone
who's not intended to be violent or
intimidate someone could very easily be
drawn into it
inadvertently no fa of their
own that's what the that's what the
amendment addresses which I I felt was a
very
important issue I think it's very
important that we address that I'm glad
these
represent represent Mar yeah thank you
Mr
chairman my my being naive maybe
or but I've seen amendments before and
when they come
through if in this case they would have
stated that we are crossing
out that line six of the bill which is e
and all of that up until B of effective
date this amendment doesn't state that
so the way I read it okay you put in D
which is the same as what's there and is
still there but section e is not the
current law the bill was making section
e or trying to make section e the law so
by amending the bill and taking out
section e section e already doesn't
exist in the law today
but you're not taking it out the bill
still has it in it
no maybe that's I
said taking out
four I got it now thank you I will tell
you this if the amendment fails the
chair would not be supporting the bill
as as the original
Bill correct so that's that's that's
where I I my head is at I feel very
strongly about that it was well point if
I may speak was well pointed out to me
that the is
G representative board
name thank you Mr chairman I will be uh
supporting this amendment uh is an
improvement of a very bad Bill that is
completely
unnecessary but I cannot support I do
not want the bill to go forward without
the amendment thank
you representative
Muse you Mr chairman one of the concerns
that I have about um about the amendment
itself is what it appears to do is to to
take a bill which at least in some way
uh tried to draw some limits around this
uh and it
actually creates almost no limits at all
um so we've been spending a lot of time
talking about protests but much more
common in this state are incidents of
road rage and uh one of the things that
I'm you know I'm very concerned about is
that you know an active
simple assault combined with a little
bit of
stupidity uh could increasingly become
you know an action that gets people
killed um and with this law it would
make it lawful in some of these cases to
do that so I'm just questioning the the
um whether whether passing something
like this is really good
judgment
I I will
say
that eliminating the rioting section I
know we were talking about protests and
whatnot but that a lot of the testimony
we heard really focused on that section
of the bill the amendment does remove
that whether I would say and I would say
this with a lot of confidence that even
if you don't support the amendment as
pass I still the original draft of the
bill uh is to me unacceptable I think in
this case and it was said by we we'll
discuss the amendment once it's adopted
but I think if it's adopted but then
we'll discuss the underline merits of
remaining representative
Newman thank you Mr chairman I will just
Echo rep representative Muse's uh
objection to the amendment in the Bill
for um expanding this law to
vehicle and that thank you represent and
just to point out that that language
about vehicle was in the original bill
it's survives with the
amendment so we can debate that what I'm
saying is after after the
Amendments voted on I would say that we
we put that matter to vote and then we
can disc discuss the issue of adding the
vehicle to subsection D which is what
would be remaining
of what was originally hb1
97 hands up is
that seeing no seeing no further hands
raised the matter we put the question of
whether to adopt amendment number 202 1-
0249 the clerk
will the clerk will call the role if you
in support of the of the adopting the
amendment please say yay you oppos
please say
nay Vice chairman Welch yes
representative Alexander yes
representative hoer yes representative
green yes representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative TR yes representative
Pratt yes representative morston
yes CL votes yes representative Harriet
GFF
yes representative
pakis
bordon
yes representative
muse
no representative Newman
no representative Balden no
representative Conley
no representative Klein Knight
no Representative
lebranch
no chairman
abis the chair votes yes Mr chairman the
vote is 14-
six by a vote of 14 y six days the the
amendment is adopted
now the motion of to
pass question yes represent Marson who
seconded Ro's
motion representative Wallace thank
you I I will open up uh the discussion
on now
the motion of about to pass
representative KN your hand is
raised thank you
chairman I just want to go on the record
here saying that I'm extremely Disturbed
at what I'm seeing happening when we
have the voices of our people sign in in
such great opposition yet we are not
going to represent that I don't
understand who we really trying to
protect here and who we're really
listening to in terms of uh fairness and
that's all I'll have to say on that I
will be voting against
this representative
board thank you Mr
chairman I will be voting against this a
to pass as amended all the testimony we
heard on this bill uh justifying it are
covered in in Sub in paragraphs a b and
c d was not uh something that anybody
brought up examples that there was a
need and in fact if I had my brothers I
would repeal paragraph d as being Uh
u a little extreme because it says
you're allowed to use deadly force to
commit
uh prevent unlawful Force for a
commission of a felony well as we asked
the uh people that were sponsoring this
bill about what is unlawful uh
Force um none of them really give me a
definition but we do know that
uh uh
deadly force well it is but we also know
that battery is unlawful force and
battery is should not be a reason for
someone to die
um so if I have my brothers I would
repeal paragraph D from the from the
statues completely but I certainly would
not extend it today thank
you
representative Marson thank you Mr
chairman I'm just I think I'm a little
behind the time but was there a motion
to adopt to to ought to pass and who
made that who
second oh stage makeing a point of
order
yeah
board is
recognized have we gone through the
process of making a motion to to pass an
amendment you know these days really
we're in all of us we're all fatigued I
don't even I'm trying to think now no
you Mr we
haven't have
not we're discussing the underly bill
got all right can't be talking about
something without a motion
we just were
yeah representative BRS you are
recognized for a motion Mr chairman I
make a motion of ought to pass with
Amendment for House Bill
197 representative Mar
second thank you for pointing out that
but you didn't say point of order this
time that was anyway makes
back to the
discussion
so I understand there was a lot of
testimony I I just want to say I respect
to disagree I think the the voices were
Listen
to I heard a lot of testimony about a
lot the majority of it overwhelmingly
addressed when was uh folks on the
writing
language and I will be honest going into
the the hearing I was uh in favor of
passing the bill as it was drafted and I
changed my
my based on the testimony so I may not
be adopting every
every piece of policy that they that
testimony from the public provided I was
listed and and I think a lot of members
of the committee were and that that's
shows what but the amendment was
supported and past so just to think that
we weren't we were ignoring the public
and I took that consider very serious
like I see how that can be a problem
especially given what's what's going on
in society today it was not I I changed
my mind so I listen I I I encourage
people to come here and that's that's a
good thing that people provided
testimony the committee absorbed it and
I think that that that's that's a
positive
outome may not be perfect for everyone
not able to like everything about it but
I think
it's something to to
recognize in regards to the use of force
involving the
vehicle so it's unlock force it can be
battery it can
be most most uses of force involve some
type of battery in one way or another
it's
just could be that too I don't know how
you're going to be committing that in
the commission of a felony against the
vehicle
[Music]
but in the vehicle yes that's true the
back I'm I'm use a different example but
I understand what you're saying but it's
it's the unlawful Force but also in the
commission of a felony and it's against
the person inside of you so it takes all
those elements to come together so the
unlawful Force alone will not give rise
to someone being able to use deadly
force and I believe it was it was Tes
believe from Dr Hannon where he said if
you're allowed to use this type of force
inside of your
home your car is it's still property and
you're inside your car which is I know
it's not your home but it's it's
parallel that so I I I believe that's a
good analogy to
justify of the
vehicle it could be an
RV that now I'm not sure if it's an RV
if that would consider your home that
may
bew but dwelling in is already on there
as well so that's where you live you
already be allowed to use what
well that would also be your dwelling I
suppose and you would already be allowed
to use the deadly force if a lawful
force
was that's the way I look at it's not so
simply the unlawful
for representative Maron thank you Mr
chairman I don't think what I'm going to
ask is a point of order but
representative Muse does a great job of
giving us support and opposed and was
that done on this bill at any time and
could he give it to us
now he most yes he he did he
did uh he did do it I can have him do it
again I will say that what again we took
the biggest section out of the bill so I
don't want to discredit the public vote
on that now I'll allow represent M to
read that to the committee again yeah
thank
you represent let's that representative
Muse read that and then I'll acknowledge
representative uh
Newman I'm sorry what what do you I'm
not understanding what you want me to
read uh representative Marson wants you
to read the the the numbers for the
people who from the public who were in
support of the bill and who were
against so for HB 197 as originally
written there were 79 people who signed
in in support and
9971 who signed in against
it Marson that that
also explains some of the justification
for the
amendment represent
Newman thank you Mr chairman I'll make
note of the fact that I waited for
recognition because I'm I want to raise
a point of order but I'm unsure if it's
valid um we took vote on an amendment
without a motion being seconded and and
my point of O order is is that V is that
vote on that Amendment still valid or do
we have to vote on it again well first
of all the I will say it is a valid
point of order so I will accept it as a
valid point of order the point of
order it wasn't it's not rais time we
already the vote is ended but when the
vote when the motion was made was ought
to pass the introduce an amendment and
that was seconded by representative WS
then when I open up to the discussion I
believe that is
when I it was the chair's oversight of
not recognizing representative roads to
act a formal motion a to pass
with so that the oversight was after the
amendment was adopted that's my
understanding so we do we do have a
motion now now now that motion's been
made and that was corrected by re that
was well he didn't say point of order
which was ironically out of order but at
the same time he raised the point of
order uh that's how I interpreted and it
was acknowledged
correctly thank you Mr chair for the
clarification I was just trying to make
sure we the process was
correct
signal participating at home if if your
if your digital hand is up I'm getting
good enough at this that I actually can
see it just make sure your hand is down
if it's not just be conscious of see no
further hands
raised oh me representative G right yeah
you know I never considered road rage so
I have to thank um representative um
Muse for bringing that to light and we
all know that New Hampshire has a lot of
road rage and I'm sorry you know I
thought about this and I know I cannot
vote for
this because I don't think we have
really thought about all the other
consequences that could be a direct
result of passing this
bill
seeing no repres rose yes thank you Mr
chairman I just have to say
as as a person that has a family member
that was killed in a
vehicle I actually was not the sponsor
of this bill but obviously I'm the
co-sponsor of
it crime does not have boundaries it
does not have property
lines and I'm a firm
believer I don't care where you go I
don't care what state you visit I don't
care what county you're in you should
never under any circumstances lose your
right to protect yourself or to protect
your loved ones period that's
it my cousin is dead because of road
rage he's dead and he was not allowed to
protect
himself thank you Mr chair
chman representative Conley thank you
and representative
I you know I debate whether anything at
all this just stries me as an
extraordinarily broad expansion of the
self statute know if uh that
one uh one enters there and they're
doing
there that is clear in stat that
selfi
vehicle just a broad situ there are
countless scenarios encounter
areas basically everything is a great
area um it allows one's perception of
what might happen
uh for in response I think it's just
should
[Music]
pass representative
Testament I've remained silent on this
quite a while
U and what really bothers me is we're
spending an awful lot of time
fixing problems after they're a problem
the real problem is that for 50 60 years
we haven't you know we have devastated
our families with you know a a whole
series of of laws education systems and
so on and they cause problems like this
there wouldn't be a problem of having to
defend the home or having no knock
warrants or things like that if we took
care of our families and it just really
upsets me that we we argue about these
kinds of laws and we don't sit down with
our families every night and have dinner
thank
you
know I'm sure all be home with the
families right now
we bring
this not seeing any
any hands rais matter we put the
question motion is ought to pass with
Amendment CL will now call the role if
you are in support of the motion of O to
pass with Amendment please say yay if
you are
opposed please say
n Vice chairman Welch yeah
representative Alexander yes
representative Hopper yes representative
green yes representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative Tru yes representative
Pratt representative Marston yes the
clerk votes yes representative Harriet
GFF no Representative pacus
no Representative gour no representative
muse
no representative Newman
no representative golden no
representative Conley no representative
Klein Knight
no representative Le
branch
no chairman abis the chair votes
yes Mr chair the vote is 10 yay N
N I got
11 oh thank you you were 11 not 10 my
apolog make sure that's
correct I put under the right line
number
represent Ro will you be preparing the
majority
report we I believe Mr Wallace is going
to be doing
that right will someone be preparing The
Minority
Report
here ication doing like three of them
already in between bills I just want to
let you know
representes in between Bill I just want
to let you know I received an email from
a someone who I don't know personally
they I made I complimented you last
Friday about how helpful you work to the
committee and the person thought I was
not being sincere and I actually had my
notes to address that because I was
being
sincere and
uh I would B me being upset was that
that when we compliment each other
people don't think think we're actually
complimenting each other so I just want
to let you know that that was sincere
I'm not sure who interpreted that way
what but it doesn't mean a lot because
we've been uh struggling with technology
and I think it's more difficult for it's
you're doing an exceptional job
especially if you're not in the room so
I think you're doing a great job and I I
the chair definitely app the whole
committee appreciates it my my mother
tuned in and she even said oh that that
David Muse is really helpful so it is
recognized I do appreciate it and
that that was that was sincere and as
was this statement now we have yeah we
have it
is we
do I appreciate that Mr chairman thank
you Mr chairman
repres
hoer I don't know if this is a inquiry
or what but I just don't understand how
representative moose should stay outside
all day without a
[Music]
c snow tomorrow so it's good thing good
thing we had clear weather
today uh
representative
uh yes uh Mr chairman I just have a
quick question uh when representative
Muse reads the numbers of opposed and
and for a bill um could that possibly be
done at the beginning of the executive
session until after the vote instead of
after the boote vote it's technically
supposed to be done before I end the
hearing I keep for some reason for the
life of me keep forgetting and I don't
understand why so representative m i
just completely delegated that to him
but he can't see me reaching for the the
orange
G so is that a yet followup Mr
chairman let's move on to the next exec
session this should be at the end of the
public yeah we we'll talk to the end of
the public
heing well I I know uh what I'm seeing
represent M been doing a great job he
doesn't see me going to pick this up
that's
[Music]
why uh we have House
Bill
Mr
chairman
one now open the executive session for
House Bill
253 here recognizes representative Wells
for a
motion we retain
23 is there a
second a
second I respect the
dean someone in the room
the room was real close with hand but
representative P
seconds the motion to
retain is there wish to be any
discussion represent
board uh as I told you earlier I put in
an amendment uh for that should be
delivered on Wednesday that corrected
the two major areas that uh this bill
needs one is to no longer make it a
mandate and the other is to uh make the
changes that the Department of
Corrections asked for uh including them
as well as other law enforcements um I
don't see any advantage to uh retaining
this bill uh those uh amendments are
very uh small and I think that they
would allow our committee to pass it
representa
well I still think this is a 28a issue
we cannot mandate to the cities and
towns things that we not will to
pay that's why I think we should retain
it and to investigate whether or not
there is a way around
it
uh representa bo thank you chairman and
that is one of the reason the reason for
one of the Amendments that I made was to
change the language to uh May rather
than shall which no longer makes it a
mandate and that's all you really need
to uh uh not make an a mandate but since
that funding is still there uh we can
test to see what how much money is
available and where where uh how how a
shortfall there would be for uh the
Monies to be
raised representative
pakus yes thank you Mr chairman I second
to retain it because we have so many
bills in that are addressing this issue
and I believe in the body cameras but I
do not believe in ask in the city's
in towns to pay for it thank
you representative
Testament when you take the word sh out
and I'm against the bill all together
but you take the word shall out then you
just might as well throw the whole bill
out
because it it's
meaningless if if you you're not going
to bandaid
something don't make a law about
it representative Wallace thank you Mr
chairman I just wanted to add on to
representative Welch's point that this
is a uh downshifting of costs issue uh
this bill clearly should have had a fin
a fiscal note attached to it and it
doesn't so it's dead out of the gate
just on that basis alone in my
opinion thank you representative boss in
respect to the fiscal note my
understanding that there a house rules
that would require fiscal note in
addition to an RSA now I'm not I'm not
I'm not sure how that happened here
would there was
none if I'm wrong with that
it's but it's just not there so the
other thing I
mean we not it's one thing they have an
unfunded mandate which is violation of
AR 28 I I think the body cameras don't
don't bother me now it's actually a
something that will help both law
enforcement and civilians but we need to
one it' be nice to know how much it cost
before you mandate two because the state
needs to pay for it but we still need to
know your cost this needs a lot of work
I will say I haven't gone through I
skimm through Senate Bill 96 but what I
Envision is and representative Pak kind
someone hinted alluded to
this that hasn't passed in the Senate
yet we don't don't know it's to make it
out of there but if it does I get the
feeling it would come to this committee
we can kind of pick and choose the best
of both worlds and work on it then
considering that we have about well
going into today we have still have
about over 50 bills in committee we have
to get out by March
11 which is a bigger concern I have for
this committee because they this this
may be important but we may have bills
that just don't get active on because we
don't have the time and the resources
actually
do that's why I I support the motion
to repr Maron thank you Mr
chairman I think this might be a point
of order but do we have any amendments
to this bill at the the wedes new or I'm
not news but Newman spoke about I
believe and I'm just saying why are we
discussing something that isn't in our
hand
so he we hav the amendment hasn't been
drafted yet he's representative bate
inquired about an amendment I I find it
acceptable that if there is an amendment
either on his way or intention that use
it as a point of I know that he's not
arguing the amendment he's basically
arguing don't retain it because the's
coming don't retain it to work on it he
repr I mean to speak for represent bne
is saying he has already worked on it is
is what I gather from this
yeah representa Mar thank you one last
thing does does representative Muse have
a support and oppos numbers on this
piece of
legislation yes there were there were 71
people who signed in in support and
there were three people who signed in in
opposition thank
you and and just in in in respect to
that those numbers again I I support the
the concept of the body cers I just
think this bill as presented I think
is it's just violates article 288 in
there's no FIS but we can we can fix
that in this committee and I think we do
that when we get 96 EXC 96
I
that no if we pass it it's a bigger
problem now if we retain
it what is
what would that do to the March
11 if we it it won't be heard until
next amendments that are draft they can
still draft we'll put them with a bill
we get a fiscal note and we can consider
the whole
thing Consulting with the vice chair the
the bill would be held in all like till
next next year here however an amendment
to Senate Bill 96 could literally pick
this bill up and put it in there with
the fiscal note so for the people who
want to address that we we have plenty
of notice it's it hasn't even passed in
the Senate yet so that's something maybe
they put in
consideration it is a it's different
though it's just
obviously some homework to do
representative
Newman yeah I I just want to raise uh I
I'm not going to be support supportive
of of making it not
mandatory um and I support that from my
belief that we P we this
legislature has constantly passed
unfunded mandates down to cities and
towns for many years by in requiring
mandatory increases to property taxes
for the cities and the towns because
they can't they have to have a budget so
they have to raise their property taxes
and it's because of the state
not living up to their original pledges
to support pensions and education so we
don't talk about it in that manner but I
think that's an unfunded mandate to the
cities and the towns so that's one
reason why I would oppose
this representative
Newman and I have could I have a
followup representative uh represent
Newman you for follow thank you uh and
the other thing is I I looked up in the
house
rules the uh what it means when you um
itl a bill and when you retain a bill in
my understanding of what I read and I
don't know if it's correct or not my my
understanding is correct and it said
that when you retain a bill in the first
year that in order to in order to bring
it up in the second year you need it has
to be approved by a majority of the
rules committee so you I just don't
think you automatically can just bring
it up the second
year we did it with the red flag last if
you recall say again you did it with the
red flag Bill HP
687 we were both on the subcommittee we
had a lot
of good sport all I'm doing is is is
just telling you that I looked it up
today I never knew where the authority
was and that's what I understood from
what I read we can talk about this some
other time represent representative
news one of the things that I just
wanted to make sure um that was said is
we did hear some testimony uh that
indicated there were real advantages for
communities to be doing this at the same
time and so one reason communities would
do this at the same time would be if it
was required and so you know if you take
a look at the overall cost that would be
spent you know on these systems um you
know if if all New Hampshire communities
were able to purchase this equipment
through some sort of a like a joint RFP
to have uh rfps for things like cloud
services and things like that that tend
to add significantly to the cost one of
the things that you know that strikes me
is it's a way to actually make it less
expensive to get to a very good outcome
um you know fairly quickly so so what I
would one of the things I would urge is
rather than doing the New Hampshire
thing which is sort of throwing it back
on communities to figure out you know
you know you know have giving them the
option of doing it or vers versus not
doing it is to is to phase it in over
several years so so for instance make it
make it a requirement but do something
potentially like change the the
effective date or or maybe lay out you
know three years or something like that
um at the end of those by at the end of
those three years all communities would
be required you know to have this up and
running um the advantage of that is we
have this we'd have this uniform
uniformly across the state in the long
run it would probably cost less you know
all of the police who testified even
though they testified that they were
neutral um they're main area of
opposition seem to be trying to do our
job which is trying to figure out how to
pay for it um and you know if you it it
strikes me that if
we you
know don't necessarily try to put it on
ourselves all in the first year to
figure out how to pay for it all at once
we may be able to get this thing get
this thing done and accomplished um and
again there just seem to be you know a
lot of real genuine benefits to doing it
it's it's one of the key recommendations
of the leak commission and and it really
seems to be something that we all want
to do um you know what I would just sort
of suggest is you know if we retain it
um we meet on it and we really do try to
work this out because this this is a
real opportunity here and I hate to see
you know an
opportunity at you
know I think think they're so rare in
this area it would be it would be great
to be able to find a way to take
advantage of
it Muse I will tell you
that we may disagree on how to get to
the end game but I think you and I agree
on what we want the end game to be we
both like I think we both agree that a
version of this bill at one point should
pass it it protects civilians it
protects police officers but it's our
job to figure out how to do the funding
and and we don't even know how much it
costs because there's no fiscal note and
we got to then address the funding side
we will do this in this committee I'm
not to Simply as a chair if I didn't
want this I'm not going to retain a bill
just to retain it I would if that's the
case I would I would be arguing to
itl there's no need to retain a bill and
just hold on to it on a subcommittee
that we don't even know when it can be
so the idea is and I've even gave
recommendations that when Senate Bill 96
comes this can turn to Amendment into
that and we can work it out and figure
that again we we see that bill when it
gets here if it makes I I will say when
it comes to the unfunded mandate and
I've always since my first day in this
body first day in this committee I
always said if I find something to be
unconstitutional I like it or
not I will I won't support and I this is
one of the ones I'm not I'm not exactly
happy about the situation but rather
than itl it I'm I want to retain it so
we can our committee we can fix and I
think you're motivated to do it I I get
the uh feeling that representative colle
is motivated to doing this I think the
committee is motivated working on this
so let's let's let's
move hands hands up line up in the road
so let's let's work on this together and
I think we can figure it out because
there is some work to needs to be done I
don't think we should just pass it
knowing that it has a unfunded mandate
issue represent Maron thank you Mr
chairman on this motion um my first
inclinations was that I wanted to see
this bill itl but on the basis of
Representative Welch and panelas having
a retain it I will vote to
retain repr Auber thank you Mr chairman
um just one of the things that I don't
see I don't know enough about it but I
wonder if the state Poli I know that
there was a recommendation that the
state police get
cameras I don't know if there's anything
in the works to make that happen but it
seems like if we retain it we can make
we can use this as a vehicle to at least
mandate that the state Bel
to and if we orchestrate it correctly we
can attract towns and cities to join on
with the state police to use the same
maybe the same software or or retaining
information or ability to retain the
information to cut the cost to the towns
to attract attract
towns to the process instead of
mandating towns to the
process that's that's an excellent idea
kind of like a risk pool with insurance
I I hear
you very good idea I have no idea
uh details that that's that's good
thought representative uh Newman and
repres news are your hands up from
before or they up
again you can say they're up again I I'm
not mad Mr chairman my is up up again
representative Newman Mr chairman my
hand is up thank you Mr chairman I also
would re would would vote for retaining
the bill so that we could really work on
it next year but again I'd like I'd ask
the uh the chair to uh check on the
house rules because with my reading it
says in the second year you have to have
a you have to have um the approval of
the just a majority approval from the
rules committee to do that and that
might be a result of when we changed
last year's rules to the N the 2016
rules so I'm not sure why that is but
that's what it appears to
be representative Welsh is going to
respond that he may be more familiar
with the rule that you're referring to
I first of all representative every bill
that gets drafted goes to the floor of
the house
eventually so I don't think that we're
going to have to worry about the rules
committee because the the motion to
retain is something that I put
in how many years ago 20 years ago and
the whole idea was to save time
because we don't have always have time
to go through a difficult bill this this
will be a difficult Bill I'm in favor of
of body canas all the reasons that prer
but we I don't see how we can do this on
28a we don't know how much it cost we
got to find these things
out a point of a point of
water
I point of order you're
recognized I believe if we retain in
committee that's a committee requirement
when you rain on the
floor the point of order is is it's a
it's a when a parliamentary rule of
procedure is not followed by the
committee and if for example when I
forgot to recognize representative rhods
for the motion of B the pass the
amendment just simply open up the
discussion on an amendment motion that
was never made that was a valid point of
order but a question about the procedure
uh just the question for informative is
not if you ever just don't because the
point of order I have to address it
right away that that the point of order
is out of order if you have a question
you can ask it to the chair or to
represent well myself we can address it
just because representative Newman was
in the middle of asking a question and I
had to cut him off to address the point
of order
but your point of war
was apologies it's no I'm just just
explaining it
that's so let represent representative
Newman finish his question and then I'll
recognize repres Mar for the
question Mr chairman thank you can you
hear me yes yeah okay I'm I'm looking at
the house rules and I'd like just to
respond to representative Welch through
you if I could okay let's let's let's
focus on the we can discuss the rules
after we we disc deide the question
because the rules have nothing I've gone
I've lived this dream before and I know
how long this can go on for and it can
go on for a long time so we're gonna
we're goingon to call the question right
now thank
you thank
you will call the role if you in support
of the motion to retain please say yay
if you are opposed please say
next Vice chairman Welch
yes representative Alexander yes
representative Hopper yes
representative green
yes representative
Wallace he said
yes up
yes wait hold on a second I accidentally
put I hold on for a minute please please
take a TR
representative test yes representative
TR yes representative Pratt yes
representative morston
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Harriet Gaff
no representative
pakus
yes representative representative bouret
yes representative Muse
yes representative Newman
yes representative bden
yes representative Conley yes
representative F Knight
no representative Le Branch
yes chairman abbis chair vot yes
Mr chairman
172 by a vote of
seven it's 20 it's 18 to
two I got do okay hold
on MAR I apologize that was that was a
proper point of
order glad I was wearing this you could
see see the
full we don't we can play it back
20 of us
here there's 20 of us here yeah I know
that's I don't know where I got my
number off I have I have the right
people I have the right days and
Nam well we were raining this so we're
not Del to the clerk this is
recorded uh it's very exciting to go
back and watch
it just try to remember how long we are
into it TimeWise you have any more
bills
uh if I can just ask a question of the
committee we we have we do have one bill
that we could exactly it was HB
471 uh I think for the most part a lot
of us support that bill the only concern
that I have was raised
by it raised it but anyway it was a
concern about if what's the procedure
for for when someone wants to bring up
the issue confidenti should that be
behind closed
doors as well how do you argue the is
whether something's uh should be
confidential not public without
breaching confidentiality that would
require if we choose to address that
that would require Amendment so I don't
know what the feeling of the committee
is I would hate to see the bill fail
because of
that they're they're okay with it
who wants to take up the challenge of
the
event we talking about 471
yes representative P
pelagus yes thank you Mr chairman I just
want to make sure that we all realize
that this is during a
certification
meeting like they have done something
that they are going to be thrown out of
the police department you know what I
mean it's not just any disciplinary
hearing there
is and I think people were kind
of thinking it was it's it's just if
it's before the board of directors and
they're going to make a decision whether
he's going to stay a police officer or
he's
go
thank so what what I would say is if if
we can if there's an amendment we are
meeting again on Wednesday for another
long
day
then my it's not 100% but my
understanding the fallowing Wednesday
we're likely to meet again which is
17th so penil that in your calendar but
it's not
100% I thought we were meeting this
Wednesday oh we're meeting this
Wednesday too
okay
so we uh
there's there's no other business
meeting so
can I
didn't all right uh the criminal justice
Public Safety Committee is
adjourned see you wed